right from the start software
development comprise two different
departments the development team that
develops the plan designs and builds the
system from scratch and the operation
team for testing and implementation of
whatever is developed the operations
team gave the development team feedback
on any bugs that needed fixing and any
rework required invariably the
development team would be idle awaiting
feedback from the operations team
this undoubtedly extended timelines and
delayed the entire software development
cycle there would be instances where the
development team moves on to the next
project while the operations team
continues to provide feedback for the
previous code
this meant weeks or even months for the
project to be closed and final code to
be developed now what if the two
departments came together and worked in
collaboration with each other what if
the wall of confusion was broken
and this is called the devops approach
the devops symbol resembles an infinity
sign suggesting that it is a continuous
process of improving efficiency and
constant activity the devops approach
makes companies adapt faster to updates
and development changes the teams can
now deliver quickly and the deployments
are more consistent and smooth though
there may be communication challenges
devops manages a streamlined flow
between the teams and makes the software
development process successful the
devops culture is implemented in several
phases with the help of several tools
let's have a look at these phases
the first phase is the planning phase
where the development team puts down a
plan keeping in mind the application
objectives that are to be delivered to
the customer
once the plan is made the coding begins
the development team works on the same
code and different versions of the code
are stored into a repository with the
help of tools like get and merged when
required this process is called version
control the code is then made executable
with tools like maven and gradle in the
build stage
after the code is successfully built it
is then tested for any bugs or errors
the most popular tool for automation
testing is selenium
once the code has passed several manual
and automated tests we can say that it
is ready for deployment and is sent to
the operations team
the operations team now deploys the code
to the working environment the most
prominent tools used to automate these
phases are ansible docker and kubernetes
after the deployment the product is
continuously monitored and nagios is one
of the top tools used to automate this
phase
the feedback received after this phase
is sent back to the planning phase and
this is what forms the core of the
devops life cycle that is the
integration phase
jenkins is the tool that sends the code
for building and testing if the code
passes the test it is sent for
deployment and this is referred to as
continuous integration
there are many tech giants and
organizations that have opted for the
devops approach for example amazon
netflix walmart facebook and adobe
netflix introduced its online streaming
service in 2007.
in 2014 it was estimated that a downtime
for about an hour would cost netflix two
hundred thousand dollars however now
netflix can cope with such issues
they opted for devops in the most
fantastic way
netflix developed a tool called the
simeon army that continuously created
bugs in the environment without
affecting the users this chaos motivated
the developers to build a system that
does not fall apart when any such thing
happens
so on this note here is a quiz for you
match the devops tool with the phase it
is used in
a
b
c
[Music]
d
none of the above
today more and more companies lean
towards automation with the aim of
reducing its delivery time and the gap
between its development and operations
teams to attain all of these there's
just one gateway devops
and if you're also looking forward to
doing the same and excel in devops check
out simply learn's postgraduate program
in devops design and collaboration with
caltech ctme the program can help you
master several in-demand devops skills
and tools like continuous integration
and delivery devops on cloud kubernetes
docker and much more my name's antoine
victor and i'll be your instructor for
this devops training in this training
we'll look at what is devops the devops
life cycle devops tools talk a little
bit about version control and then we'll
get into ci and cd that's continuous
integration and continuous delivery and
then we'll follow on with configuration
management containerization and finally
finishing up there with monitoring so
let's go ahead and dive right in with a
definition of devops so what is devops
really well devops largely is a cultural
shift it's an organization-wide cultural
shift towards delivering business value
to the end customer now this means that
development and operations both have to
work together now because devops is a
clipped compound which includes only
development and operations it might seem
like devops is just for developers and
operations staff but the reality is if
we were to include everything that
devops really contained devops
containing development operations
obviously but also quality assessment uh
security configuration management
infrastructure management network
management and so on and so on and so on
the the name wouldn't sound cool it
wouldn't be a good marketing term anyway
anymore so let's assume for now that
devops includes not just development and
operations but everything on the
software delivery pipeline from idea to
business value making it into the
customer's hands so developers
continuously want to develop and test
code so they're building new features
they're rewarded for delivering new
features to the end customer on the
other hand the operations team is in
charge of keeping the network and the
production software in a running state
so for them
less changes are better so you can see
we've got kind of opposing missions here
between development and operations
development wants to deliver new
features but the operation of delivering
new features tends to cause downtime
which the operations team are rewarded
for maintaining the opposite of that
which is uptime so in order to
get these guys working together the
development team and the operations team
working together to enable continuous
deployment we have to automate a lot of
these historically manual processes so
what we're really talking about here is
the devops life cycle or the software
delivery life cycle where we plan and
again because we're talking about the
entire team working together here we're
planning but not planning everything we
plan just enough to get get the next
iteration done and then we code but just
enough to complete the features that we
plan to deliver in the coming release
and then we compile or build that
solution and once we get a successful
build of that solution then we go on and
test that solution and only on
successful completion of all of those
tests uh do we move on to the next phase
where we integrate the code that one
team member has just submitted got a
successful build on and then a
successful test run then we take that
code and we integrate it with all the
code that was written by the other
developers on the team and then we test
it again and once we are successful with
that integrated build and that
integrated test run then we can move on
to configuring the environment that
we're going to deploy this successfully
compiled and tested solution too that's
where configuration management comes
into play it's best to avoid
configuration drift and incorrect
configurations by automating this
process of configuring those servers
that we're going to deploy our solution
to so with configuration management and
automated configuration our goal is to
automate this process so we can be more
consistent and reliable and once we've
configured the system that we're going
to deploy to then we want to use
automated deployment to deploy to those
systems that have been configured in a
consistent way one now we want to now
deploy to them in a consistent and
reliable way and finally once those
solutions are deployed successfully into
our stable consistently configured
environment we want to monitor the
ongoing use of those solutions to make
sure that users are getting the features
and the performance that they expect
from the solution that we've delivered
so let's start at the beginning let's
say we want to build a website for a
company we might have a customer that
comes to us and says hey i want to build
a new website for my organization and we
might respond you know you can use
devops tools and techniques to build
your website and streamline your
delivery process hey that sounds like a
great idea let's do it so let me hire
some developers testers and operations
guys who can develop and test and
maintain the website and then after
gathering all the requirements the
developers can start building the code
for the website and store each version
of that code in a source code repository
but for now we'll call it github let's
say we're using github so we've got a
couple of developers and we've got our
github repository to store all of our
solution artifacts so at this point
we've done a little bit of the planning
we've collected some requirements for
our customer we've started on the coding
we've stored some of the code in our
local git repository or maybe we're
using uh the microsoft stack and we
might be using the tool formerly known
as team foundation services uh it's now
called azure devops but as far as source
control uses the same foundations as git
so we get our code into version control
so you might have multiple files that
the developers have created developers
are working on file 1 file 2 file 3 and
they check those files in the github
repository as version 1. another team of
developers might be working on different
features that might impact those same
files
so they're working on file 3 but have
made a couple versions of it a couple of
iterations to it so they're on file 3.3
while team 1 is only on file 3. as we
merge those different branches of
changes together we create version two
of the solution but if anything goes
wrong anywhere along the way we've kept
those branches of changes separate so
one will not affect the other this is
the benefit of version control and
source control tools like git and github
so the basic architecture of git here we
have a working directory we've got a
local staging area where we prepare
changes that we've made to be committed
to the local repository and then to
share those changes with other
developers on the team
we can push the changes out to a remote
repository to receive changes that other
developers have made or other team
members have made we can pull those
changes down from the remote repository
so back to our website project here uh
now the developers have built the code
using whatever tools they chose to use
whether it be dot net eclipse or some
other editing tool uh we can then take
that code
and make sure that code is valid by
compiling it packaging it and then
having the code verified by our quality
assurance team now in order for other
team members to access this code it's
best if it's moved to that central
repository the github that we were
talking about earlier so our developers
write their code they compile it make
sure it runs and the tests all pass
locally and they can push that out to
our central repository in github now
we've talked about planning we've talked
about testing and we've talked about the
uh the compiling and the source code
repository but we didn't really talk
about how that compiling is being done
so one of the ways that we might build
java code is by using a tool called
maven now maven is what we can use to
define how our build is going to be done
and automate our build process so once
we have that planning and building phase
done our solution has been tested and
stored in version control we might want
to run some additional tests for that we
need the testers the testers are going
to test the code that we built to make
sure there are no errors that perhaps
weren't caught by our our automated
testing that was part of the development
process so the testers are going to
perform functional tests they may rerun
some of the unit tests created by the
developers system tests and user
acceptance tests to fully vet the
solution to make sure that it's ready
for prime time so again at this point
we've done a little bit of planning
we've done some coding we've done some
building of that code and some automated
unit testing of that code and now we've
passed it off to the qa team so they can
do more exhaustive testing of that
solution now some of the additional
tests that the qa team might run would
be ui automation tests exploratory tests
smoke tests to find issues that may not
have been exposed by the low-level
testing unit testing that developers may
have done during the development process
using test-driven development once the
qa team is finished doing that
additional testing making sure that we
didn't miss anything with our automated
testing process then the operations team
will need to integrate those changes
along with anything that's already out
there in production maybe a previous
version of the solution existing data
from an old database or what have you we
can use continuous integration to make
sure that all that code all those
changes that are being made by different
team members is compiled and tested and
deployed together on the production
servers in a consistent way so again
we've gone from planning to developing
or coding rather and building that code
and testing that code to integrating
those changes with changes that the
other developers on the team have made
and finally running additional tests and
after all of our tests are passed
pushing that solution out to production
servers or production like servers as we
prepare for additional tests like load
and stress tests now this operation this
automation process of moving these
resources out into the qa environment
and on into the pre-production staging
environments and finally off into
production there are several tools that
we can use to automate this process some
of the more common tools listed here on
the slide jenkins bamboo and travis ci
that's continuous integration and of
course azure devops not here on the
slide so a common example of using ci
and cd and jenkins is again we have our
developers doing their work hopefully
writing their tests first so when they
complete their work they can commit
their work to our source code repository
and that act of committing the work the
source code repository can cause a tool
like jenkins to automatically fire off a
continuous integration trigger to build
that solution test that solution and if
it passes potentially deploy that
solution off to the next environment but
if it fails we can reject that check in
to the repository and send notification
back to the developer or other team
member that introduced that defect
allowing them to fix that defect before
it causes any problems for other team
members now of course if that build and
that test run passes then jenkins can
automatically move that change that
version of the solution onto the next
environment now that next environment
this case is the qa environment where
now the testers have access to that
solution and the testers can perform
more exhaustive exploratory testing uh
user acceptance testing and so forth if
they then find any errors then they can
push that feedback back down the
development team who can then fix those
uh issues and then resubmit that code
through the continuous integration
pipeline now if the testers don't find
any defects then they would promote or
approve that solution for promotion into
the production environment or again we
might have a more complex environment
where we push from qa into a staging
environment where we then continue to
run load and stress testing so so far in
our ci cd pipeline here we have the
developers making the changes we have
the developers pushing those changes
into a code repository like git we have
the build system or the continuous
integration system like jenkins
detecting that change in git and then
automatically compiling and testing
those changes submitted by the developer
and on the test framework side we have
unit tests which are most likely written
by the developers as they're writing the
code or before they write the code if
we're using test driven or test first
development and then we have web ui
testing done with tools like selenium
and then integration testing which could
be additional unit tests uh run with
those ui tests and other acceptance
tests on our integration server now as
we move on from continuous integration
to continuous delivery and continuous
deployment there are other tools that we
can employ like serena and pivotal cf as
well as google's cloud platform azure
and amazon's aws to assist in this
automation of delivery and deployment so
uh a textbook definition of continuous
delivery is to be ready and able to
deploy any version of our solution to
any supported platform at any time um
continuous deployment is basically the
same thing but without the ready enable
with continuous deployment as the name
implies you are continuously deploying
uh every change that successfully makes
it through compile and test
automatically to the production
environment or at least to a production
slot whereas continuous delivery we're
just ready to deploy it because we've
done all of our compiling and testing
maybe even we've done some more
exploratory testing manual testing and
even some automated load and stress
testing but in any event the solution is
ready to be deployed it's just not
deployed yet with continuous delivery
with continuous deployment as the name
implies we have actually deployed the
solution so now the solution is deployed
the operations team is going to want to
make sure the systems and deploy the
code onto the production environment in
a consistent way for that we need
configuration management to help make
sure the systems are configured in a
consistent state and functioning
properly for the version of the software
that's about to be deployed this avoids
configuration drift and incorrectly
configured devices using a configuration
tool like ansible puppet or chef we can
make sure that the configuration happens
automatically and in a consistent way so
every deployment is either successful or
fails the exact same way it failed last
time because the failure was part of the
automation some devops tools that we can
use for these uh configuration
operations um our puppet docker chef
and ansible now these tools are the most
common tools used for this deployment
and configuration automation phase of
our devops delivery pipeline so again
configuration management is the process
of systematically managing and handling
changes to a system in a way that
maintains integrity over time how does
it do that you might ask well it does
that by doing the configuration in the
automated and consistent way so the same
way we take our code and we compile it
we test it and make sure that it's past
those tests and compile successfully we
can take our configuration and do that
in the same automated way and once we
have a configuration automation script
that works successfully we can then take
that configuration automation script
that playbook that recipe or what have
you and store it in the source code
repository along with the rest of the
solution artifacts the code any
documentation that we might have
collected or created over time and put
it in that central source of truth
github or our central repository or
whatever tool that you choose now we
have everything either in our artifact
repository that would be the output of
our build our deployment package or in
our source code repository which is all
of our source code documents
configuration files and so forth we have
a central source of truth for all of the
resources necessary to successfully
deploy this solution so even if we had
nothing more than our source code
repository our artifact repository and
bare metal resources we could reproduce
this solution so puppet's an open source
configuration management tool for
deploying managing and configuring
multiple servers in an automated way
very consistent so we basically have uh
the notion of nodes for the the puppets
if you will that are controlled by the
puppet master so what basically happens
here is the node sends the data about
itself to the puppet master the puppet
uses that information to compile a
catalog that shows how that node is
supposed to be configured but if over
time something changes
and that node reports back the puppet
master that the configuration is
incorrect incomplete or has changed
something that's non-standard then the
puppet master can then push down uh
updated configuration to keep that
server in a standard state consistent
with its stored configuration and all
the other nodes that are necessary for
that solution to run now as far as
deployment to these different servers
and configured resources an easy way to
make sure that deployment is consistent
is to really avoid the redundant
configuration and deployment of those
solutions to multiple servers
individually by deploying into a
container and then using that container
to replicate that configuration across
multiple devices and resources
containerization is basically the
process that allows software to run
reliably when moved from one computing
environment to another because it's not
dependent on the local computing
environment itself rather on the
container host if you will basically a
virtual machine requires that we use up
a lot of resources and install a full
copy of the operating system inside of
that virtual machine and that virtual
machine basically needs all the same
hardware that the operating system needs
to run containers on the other hand uh
live inside of that host machine and
effectively are segmented from all of
that hardware and requirements of having
a full operating system they're
basically small containers inside of the
existing operating system so we get the
same level of isolation without all the
overhead requirements of having a full
virtual machine with installed operating
system this allows us to easily deploy
the containers without all the headaches
of installing an operating system and
redoing the configuration so docker
containers are basically standard units
of software that package the code and
all other dependencies so that the
application runs faster and it's
reliable from one computing environment
to another again because it's not
dependent on the underlying hardware or
even the underlying operating system but
just the container host so the
operations team verifies that the
website is functioning correctly and the
entire architecture is working properly
and once it is then we can continue to
monitor the website on an ongoing basis
and make sure that performance doesn't
degrade over time to check and see what
features users are actually using and
what features that they're not so we can
send that feedback back the development
team so they can make changes as needed
to make sure that we're meeting the
requirements of the customers so
operations team monitors collecting
feedback from the website and doesn't do
as much good to collect that feedback if
we don't have an easy way to push that
feedback back into the team that built
the solution in the first place so some
tools that we can use to collect that
monitoring information to collect that
ongoing usage information are splunk
nagios and new relic tools i'm sure
you've heard of before for monitoring on
the enterprise scale and being able to
collect that log information to collect
that
monitoring information that those key
metrics and display them in an easily
consumable way so basically monitoring
is that process of detecting examining
and reporting if there are any faults or
threats in the entire infrastructure so
not just with the hardware but also with
the operating system with the software
that's running on that operating system
with any of the containers with the
network with the memory anything that
might impact in a negative way the
execution of our solution should be
collected and alerted on using our
monitoring tools so nagios allows you to
monitor the server and check and see if
there are any underutilized resources or
if there are any task failures that need
to be addressed or any other critical
issues that might cause a negative
impact to the service of our customers
so basically nagios has a plugin that we
install that allows it to load resources
or log data or alert information from
those remote servers and send them to a
central location where they can be
aggregated and displayed through the web
interface this allows operations team
members that are monitoring those
systems in production to easily see and
aggregate that data so they don't have
to go and look at individual reports
from every single server that they're
responsible for if there's a problem
then the tool will notify the admin
about the status of whatever resource is
having an issue choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
and in this demo we are going to
demonstrate uh some of the uses of the
common commands in get so we're going to
use get version to check our get version
i will use git help to list some of the
help commands there and then we'll use
git commit
git add get init and get status to
manage a basic get repository so let's
go ahead and get started uh you can see
i'm on my c drive in a git repos folder
here so i'm just going to right click
and say get bash here
open a bash command prompt here and
we'll increase the size of the font so
you can see it better there and here
we'll start with uh just get version you
can see i'm running get version 2.21.0
for windows and uh to see what's in this
folder we'll do an ls as you can see the
folder is empty i do not have any
repositories yet so i'm going to do a
make directory and i'll make a directory
called uh hello java see i've got my
hello java folder now so i will change
directory into the hello java folder and
here we'll do a get status to see if
this hello java folder is a repository
no it is not a repository yet because we
just created it so we're going to do a
git init to initialize this repository
and you can see now at the end of the
command prompt here we have master
indicating that we are in a get
repository and we are on the master
branch so now if we run a git status it
says we are on branch master there are
no commits yet and there is nothing to
commit so let's create a new file and
we'll create the file hello dot java see
we have that file now i'm not going to
bother with the vim editor in here i'll
show you why in just a few minutes here
but i'm going to go into
my hello java folder and i'm just going
to edit this file using notepad and i'm
just going to create a very basic class
here and my class is going to be called
hello so i'm going to create a public
class hello and my public hello class is
going to have a single
public static method that's spelled
static correctly that returns no values
and is called main this method accepts
string array as
the argument list
all this function is going to do
is simply print something to the console
so this will print hello world to the
console so we're going to do that by
doing a system dot out dot print
line and what we're going to print is
hello world can't have a programming
demo without at least one hello world so
there it is so that's our class
i'm just going to save our class and
close the editor here you can see we've
got our hello java file there on the
windows explorer again double check that
it's here and we'll do a cat hello dot
java to see that we do have those
contents of the file now if we do a git
status you will see that we have our
hello java with untracked changes so in
order to be able to commit our new java
file to our repo we're going to have to
do a get
add and the name of the file we want to
add in this case hello java adding it to
the staging area where if we do a git
status we'll see now it's green it's a
tracked change but it still has yet to
be committed to the repository so to
commit we're going to do
git commit now normally what i want to
do is put a dash m in my commit message
but i want to show you why i didn't use
the bim editor earlier by doing a git
commit and it says hey you have to add
your commit message so here's this text
based editor for you i'm not really a
fan of this text-based editor but if we
start typing we get the insert command
and we can type added hello dot java
file and then we have to hit escape to
get out of insert mode and then we have
to type colon x
enter to save and exit in the case of
creating a file to open notepad to
create the file or in the case of
committing to just use the dash m switch
and put your message right there on the
commit line we do our git status again
you can see that we now have nothing to
commit because we have committed our
change already now the next thing that
we might want to do here is to
push our changes to a remote repository
like github but if we try to do a get
push
normally we would call that remote repo
origin and we'd want to push to the
master branch to try to do that without
first specifying uh where that remote
branch is it's going to give us an error
message and the error message basically
says origin does not appear to be a git
repository and could not read from the
remote repository make sure you have
correct access rights and the repository
exists
make that message a little more clear if
we delete where we are trying to go we
just do a get push it tells us that we
first need to specify a remote
repository using get remote so if we do
get remote
add origin it wants them the url to our
remote repository so to get to that
uh what we'll do here is we will launch
a new instance
of the browser and we will go to github
on github here
we are going to
first create a new repository call our
new repository hello let's call it hello
world we'll accept all the defaults here
and create our repository and then it
gives us here
the url to our repository so i'm just
going to copy the url to the clipboard
and then switch back over here to my get
remote ad and i'm going to paste in the
url to that repository now i have a
reference to my remote repository and
now we should be able to successfully
commit our changes to that remote
repository but before we do that let's
take a look at the repository you can
see this repository has no files in it
it's completely empty it says we can
create a file or upload an existing file
or import code from another repository
all we are going to do is complete our
get push to the origin master enter and
after a few seconds here you'll see that
our push completed successfully and we
can switch back to the browser and do a
quick refresh and you can see that our
one file hello.java has been added with
our commit message added hello.java file
or class in parentheses so at this point
we have created a file added it to our
local repository and then pushed that
file to our remote repository where we
then might be able to share that file
with other developers or other team
members working on this solution we are
going to do another demo here on jenkins
uh and in this demo we are going to
first create a basic jenkins job uh to
run a windows batch command and then
we'll build another jenkins job that
pulls a very simple java class from
github and builds that java class and
executes it as part of our jenkins job
so first thing let's take a quick peek
at jenkins here uh and in jenkins a
couple of key locations that you're
going to want to be aware of are the
manage jenkins area here and inside of
managed jenkins we have the area where
we can do our global tool configuration
and this is where we would set up tools
like maven for compiling our solutions
the jdk for accessing java there's our
maven access if we want to set up docker
containers as part of our jenkins jobs
we'd also want to set up a reference to
our docker installation here
we're going to do a pretty basic demo so
we won't have the need for any of these
tools but if we go back to our dashboard
and then back to manage jenkins there's
also an area here where you can manage
the plugins that are installed in
jenkins now here shows the updates that
are available and since i just installed
jenkins and loaded all the updates there
are no new updates available but if we
click on the installed tab you can see
all of the default or rather recommended
plugins that jenkins loaded after
installation after installation it'll
basically ask if you want to do a manual
installation of just the plugins that
you want or if you want jenkins to go
ahead and install the recommended
plugins and this is what you get if you
install the recommended plugins for our
purposes in a later demo we'll be using
the get plugin and you can see here
that's installed by default as part of
that recommended setup okay so we're
going to start by creating a new jenkins
job pretty basic jenkins job here and
we're going to call it
uh hello
jenkins let's see i've done this before
and we're going to set that as a
freestyle project so we can build it
from scratch and in this demo we're not
going to pull anything from github we're
just going to send a very simple command
and so we're going to scroll down to the
build step and we're going to add a
build step called execute windows batch
command and in this windows batch
command we are just going to echo
something to the console where we're
going to say hello
from the jenkins job and we're also
going to display the date and the time
that this request came in and then we'll
go ahead and save that and now when we
go and build this project very quickly
we get a success because there wasn't
much to execute and then if we click on
the build there we go look at the
console output you can see that we
successfully ran this job and printed to
the console hello from the jenkins job
wednesday 320 2019
39
and
29.96 seconds
success so let's up the ante a little
bit let's go back to the dashboard and
now we'll build another new project this
project we'll call this one yep you
guessed it hello github and i again
we'll make it a freestyle project so we
can build from scratch and we're going
to tell it that we're getting
this code that we want to build from our
remote repository so it's going to want
the url to our remote repository just so
happens i have that open over here we're
going to get our hello world repository
here so i'm going to grab the clone or
download and copy the link to the
repository once i have that link i can
come back over here into github
i'm sorry into jenkins and i can paste
that link to my github repository now if
your repository requires authentication
you'll want to go and add that
credential
in your jenkins credential provider and
add those additional credentials that
you want to use here believe i've
already added the credential for that
github account so all we need to do now
is just add our build step and our build
step in this case is again going to be a
windows command or windows batch command
and we're going to do java
c for the java compiler and we want to
compile
hello
dot java and then we want to run using
the java runtime the hello java class
that we just created so now we can go
ahead and save and then we can now build
this job a small delay while we compile
and the blue sphere there means that we
were successful with our compile and run
of this job if we go and look here in
the console output we can see
that
we compiled our java hello and then we
executed our java hello and got hello
world on the console that concludes our
jenkins demo and in this demo we are
going to
install puppet and the puppet agent on
three nodes in aws so to that end we'll
create three instances in our aws
console here we'll start with the puppet
master instance and we'll create that on
an ubuntu server and we're going to use
a t2 medium with dual core cpus and four
gigabytes of ram now we're going to put
it into a security group that has all
ports open just so we don't have to deal
with any firewall issues and we'll just
double check in the instance details
subnet usage
we'll let it go ahead and create its own
subnet here and then we'll review after
it's created to make sure that our other
nodes end up in the same subnet as for
tags here we're just going to add a new
name tag and we're going to say puppet
master and then we will launch this
server and use the
oregon key here since we are using the
oregon data center go ahead and launch
that instance and we'll view this
instance again just to review the subnet
id that it's on and it's on subnet
with the last three characters of 4d4 so
now we'll go ahead and launch our two
nodes again using ubuntu server this
time we're just going to use the t2
micro one cpu one gigabyte ram because
it's in our free tier eligible tier so
we'll go ahead and again set the
security group to everybody all in
review and launch and then we'll update
in the instance details the number of
nodes we're going to get two nodes this
time 12 two nodes this time and then the
subnet and going to use that
4d4 subnet so that we can access the
master node and then we'll add a tag a
name tag called puppet nodes and review
and launch and we'll launch those nodes
again with the oregon key and we'll
launch those instances all right so if
you view our instances we've got our
puppet master and i'm gonna edit these
names here and call this puppet nodes 1
and we'll call this one puppet nodes 2
just so we can keep track of which is
which now first things first here we
want to connect to our puppet master
using putty and to do that we're going
to use its public ip address and then
we'll go launch putty here i've already
got a setting here for puppet master but
we need to paste in that updated ip
address and then just to make sure
that we are using the correct key and
there's our oregon key now we can go
ahead and connect but before i connect
i'm going to go ahead and save that and
now we have a connection to our puppet
master then now that our nodes are up
we'll connect to the public ip of our
puppet node 1 again using putty agent
connection here paste in our proper ip
address and again just double check to
make sure we're using the right
certificate and no we're not so let's
change that to our
oregon key and again we'll save that
just so we can reference it easily later
i'm going to move this window over here
and then go and connect to node 2 using
its public ip and again to putty we'll
use that same agent setting we shouldn't
have to double check and make sure that
the certificate is correct because we
just saved it just in case anything has
gone horribly wrong yes we see we're
using the same organ i'm not going to
save this one i'll just switch the ip
back and forth now we have a connection
to our second node so we now have node 1
node 2
and our master node over here so now we
can begin to add our settings so first
up on our puppet master we are going to
set its hostname to puppet we're going
to do that using the hostname ctl set
hostname command and we're going to do
that using a super user do and set that
hostname to puppet now we'll do uh the
same on the nodes setting them to puppet
agent and puppet node respectively but
before we do that let's go ahead and
edit our host file so that we can tell
the system what the local ip address is
for our puppet master now to do this
we're going to go back over to aws we're
going to grab our puppet master and grab
its private ip address then we'll jump
back over to our puppet masters host
file and we'll paste in that ip address
along with the name of our server puppet
then we'll use control x
y and enter to save that file now we'll
do the same on each of our puppet nodes
we'll first set our agent to puppet
agent and then we will set our node to
puppet node and then we'll go back and
edit the host file on each of those
machines and again we're going to grab
that private ip
for our puppet master and we'll include
that
as well as the name of that server and
we'll do the same down here and then
control x yes to save the changes enter
to save that file name control x yes to
save the changes and enter to save that
file name so now that we've got the
basic dns info set up we can continue on
with installing resources on these
servers so to do that we're first going
to do
sudo apt get update to update the
package repository and we'll do that on
all three of these servers here first on
the puppet master then on the agent then
or rather than on node one then on node
two and once our update is complete we
will then
do a wget to set the puppet labs
installation repository and since we'll
need to install
the puppet master on the puppet master
obviously and then the puppet agent on
each of our nodes we'll use this same
statement on all three nodes so wget
https colon slash
apt dot puppet labs dot com slash puppet
labs dash release dash pc one dash
x-e-n-i-a-l
dot d-e-b go ahead and execute that on
the puppet master on node one and on
node two and then after that we want to
reference the package again on all three
nodes
sudo
dpkg dash i puppet labs dash release
dash pc1-xenil.deb
[Music]
again we'll execute that on all three
nodes because we'll need access to that
repository to install both the puppet
master as well as the puppet agent on
all of our nodes and then we'll do a git
update to update our package
repositories again again on all three
nodes we'll do that and finally on the
first node we can go ahead and install
the puppet server so we'll do that with
a super user do
apt get install puppet server dash y
obviously that's going to be a little
bit different than what we do on the
puppet agent on our nodes so on those
additional servers we're going to
execute super user do at get install
puppet dash agent so puppet agent this
time instead of puppet server so sudo
apt-get install puppet-agent dash y
we'll do that on both of our nodes here
and then we'll jump back to our puppet
master so that on our puppet master we
can complete the configuration by
editing the puppet server configuration
file and we'll do that with the super
user do using the nano editor to edit
etc slash default slash puppet server
now in this file we need to modify the
java args so we can adjust the memory
allocation for our puppet installation
or change that from two gigabytes down
to 512 megabytes so do that by adding
xms 512 m and xmx 512 m to the java args
and then again we'll control x yes to
save and enter to save to this file now
that we've got the memory configured we
can go ahead and start puppet server and
to do that we'll use system ctl start
puppet server super user do system ctl
start puppet server and once we've
started the puppet server then we can go
ahead and enable it for auto start when
the system starts back up again and then
before we can go any further on our
agents we'll want to set up a manifest
file to install something on those
agents and for this demo we'll do
something pretty simple and
straightforward we'll go ahead and
install maven so that we can later build
java projects but first let's enable our
puppet server for auto start now our
server is up and running we can check
the status of our server using system
ctl status puppet server check and make
sure our puppet server is up and running
we can see here that it is active it's
up and running that means we can now go
ahead and add our maven manifest file so
we'll do that this time using the vem
editor and we'll do that with the super
user do vim and then the path to our
manifest etc puppet labs slash code
slash environments slash production so
we're working with the production
environment here and in the production
environment we have a manifest folder
that we are going to create a file
called maven dot ppn now in this file
we're going to specify a node
configuration for default nodes so
that's every node that we encounter
we're going to set up a package the
maven package to be installed so we're
going to ensure that that package is
installed and we'll close our package
reference as well as closing our node
configuration and then we will x
enter to save that file all right so now
that we've got our manifest file over
there we can go to our two puppet nodes
and on those puppet nodes we can edit
their puppet configuration files so that
they can reference the environment that
we want to install our configuration
from so we're going to edit using nano
again using the path etc puppet labs
slash puppet slash puppet config and in
this file we are simply going to add a
reference
to a main section and then we'll include
certain name and we'll set the cert name
in this case to puppet dash notes node
one and then the server equal to
puppet and the environment
equal to production and again we'll
control x
and y to save and enter to save to that
file we'll do the same down here on node
2 and again we'll create a main section
we'll add a
reference to the cert name puppet dash
node 2 this time and then the server
will still be puppet and the environment
will be production and one more time
we'll control x yes and enter to save
the file now that we've got that set up
we can go ahead and start our puppet
agent service so we'll do that with the
same command that we used earlier sudo
system ctl start puppet this time
instead of puppet server both servers
and then we'll configure those servers
for auto start and just to make sure
everything is doing what it's supposed
to be doing we'll try to telnet to the
puppet server see there that we have
successfully connected to puppet on its
private ip the same thing down here on
node 2 make sure node 2 is good also
successfully connected to puppet so now
we can go back to our puppet server and
the act of starting the puppet agent
service on each of our nodes should have
sent a certificate signing request to
our puppet master just to make sure that
we have secure communication so let's
take a look at the cert list on puppet
to see if we have a list of two
certificates to do that we're going to
use uh super user do
opt puppet lab slash bin and puppet cert
list this should give us a list of the
cert requests that have come in and you
can see there we have one from node one
and another from node two now we could
either sign these requests one at a time
by adding puppet node one and then
puppet node two or we can sign the
requests all at once using this command
super user do slash opt slash puppet
labs slash ben slash puppet cert sign
dash dash all that will sign both of
those requests with one command instead
of having to execute two separate
commands successfully signed both of our
cert requests and now we can go and
execute our configuration now before we
do that let's just double check and make
sure maven is not installed here we try
to do an mvn-version
we get a message that says command mvn
is not found but can be installed with
sudo app install maven so that tells us
very clearly that mvn is not installed
on either of these nodes so now we can
run a super user do opt slash puppet lab
slash ben slash puppet agent test and
this will attempt to go out to the
master uh server the puppet master and
retrieve manifest files that are
configured for this node or in our case
default which is all nodes that connect
and then it'll install whatever's in the
manifest so we'll run that first on node
1 and then we'll run that same command
on node 2 and you can see that ran very
quickly in 0.04 seconds and now if we
run mvn
version you can see that maven
3.5.2 was successfully installed on both
nodes and that concludes our demo of
puppet running on aws so from this
section the key takeaways are that
devops is largely an organization-wide
cultural shift it's mostly cultural
there's a lot of tools there's a lot of
technologies that we'll talk about but
for the most part devops is a cultural
shift from one way of doing business
from one way of developing software to a
new more agile optimized way of
delivering software and resources to do
that we need tools obviously so uh
things like version control we talked
about git and github and once we have
some changes loaded into version control
then we also need to have some system in
place that can detect those changes and
then make sure that those changes
haven't introduced defects by making
sure that they still compile or build
and after we get a successful compile
making sure that those changes pass the
tests and that automated tests that we
have in place don't start failing after
we've made a change and then using those
same tools we want to make sure that we
get that successfully compiled and
successfully tested solution off into an
environment where we can do more
exhaustive testing where the qa team can
do some manual testing some exploratory
testing or do more in-depth automated
testing and then finally we want to move
into an environment where the operations
team can make sure the configuration is
done correctly we can make sure the
infrastructure is in place before we
begin to deploy in an automated way to
those production environments and again
with that deployment we want to make
sure that we're doing it in an automated
consistent and reliable way so we'd want
to use an automation tool like puppet or
chef or ansible now to simplify the
deployment plot process and make the
deployment process more repeatable we
can use containerization and
consideration tools like docker to allow
us to deploy in a repeatable reliable
way while minimizing the need for
excessive operating system configuration
or dependency on multiple virtual
machines and finally using log
aggregation tools and monitoring tools
like nagios and splunk and elk we can
collect all the information from these
multiple servers on our devops delivery
pipeline and make sure that we're
alerted instantly if anything happens
that would negatively impact the service
to our customers now in this one this
tutorial by simplylearn is designed in
such a way so that we can give you a
basic understanding that how exactly git
really works now in this one we are
going to talk about various concepts uh
which we involve in git we are going to
also talk about the various kit commands
which we are going to talk about here
and a variety of things and different
kind of demos are also a part of this
one
now git is something which is a really
popular at
right now over here before the git
servers was quite popular and a lot of
organizations were actually using it but
now git is in kind of a version control
system which helps us to track the
changes just like any other version
control system into us a particular
working copy or into our particular
laptop now it's having a certain
benefits which is exactly not available
in any of the other version control
system so it's used to coordinate the
work among the developers so different
developers are actually
collaborating with each other with the
help of this version control system they
are able to track the progress the
senior developers or the
leads or the managers can always find
out that what are the different changes
a developer is doing how the different
commits are happening there so uh it's a
wonderful feature of a version control
system that you get out of complete
tracking you get a complete history so
any person can go ahead with the version
control system and they can really find
out that what exactly it's happening
into this one so all those features are
definitely provided by git also it is
used to have act as a kind of
collaboration tool so that multiple
developers can really push their source
code to this remote repository and then
again it also provides us the tracking
mechanism to track the overall progress
of the development
so the main work of git is to manage the
projects and a couple of repositories
are managed here and in these
repositories you manage your work you
manage your source code and the
developers perform various kind of
activities like checkout check in push
pull different activities they do to
interact with the source code
right so git can be useful for both
programming professionals like the
developers and all and non-programming
particular professionals also now as a
devops engineer if you are not doing the
programming still you can use the get
repositories for having your files for
having your source codes your scripts
you can store ansible scripts you can
store a puppet script you can store
python shell scripts all that things you
can do it for you it is a kind of a
source code for developers they can
store java source code.net source core
android projects so that's a kind of a
source code for those particular
programming language or for those teams
now that is the reason why git is a
really helpful over here because it
provides the comfort or it provides the
help to both the programming
professionals and the non-programming or
non-technical professionals also
right
so uh it also helps in coordinating the
work among the team because of the
tracking feature history feature and the
collaboration here so uh different
developers can actually use these
repositories so that they can push their
source code to this single location and
then in fact different developers can
you know take updates they can even find
out that what other developers are doing
so they can uh do the uh sync up and uh
even if someone is not giving you the
you know the particular details still
you will be able to get it from the
repository so that's a kind of a good
collaboration mechanism or tool which
can really help to increase or improve
the communication between the different
developers so what exactly is a git
repository now a git repository is a
place where we keep all the files
related to our project stored there now
there are two types of git repositories
one is local repository and one is the
remote repository now when we work with
git version control system so what
happens
that we have a central remote repository
which is available there on the git
server now this is something not present
in local system it's an remote server so
when you do a clone activity when you
you know bring that repository into your
local system now what happens that in
git version control system it does not
creates only a working copy but in fact
a local repository is created now this
local repository is having the link up
or it's having the connectivity with the
remote repository so whatever the
changes you will do if you push your
changes to the remote repository that is
something which will be possible with
the help of this version control system
so here it's not like every time you
will be interacting with the remote
repository whenever you feel that you
want to push some changes to the remote
repository at that moment of time there
are some couple of operations like push
and pull activity which you will be
using to interact from the local
repository to the remote repository so
local repository is the one which you
will be bringing on when you clone the
remote repository now remote repository
is the repository which is having the
main important source code so using the
local repository you will be interacting
with the remote repository and that's
how the various kind of operations you
know you can do the modifications
whatever the comments you have performed
you will push it you will pull it so all
those activities you will be able to do
with the help of local and remote
repository so these two type of
repositories are available which we can
further use to make our changes and
perform our particular source code
changes here
right now let's talk about some of the
uh git commands because ultimately when
we work with the get version control
system we have to do a various kind of
operations like pushing the comments
performing the merging so all those
commands let's talk about that
now the very first one the basic
commands over here is that git config so
git config is the mechanism using which
we can configure the username and email
id now why we require this when you will
be doing some git comments or you will
be doing the modification so as a
standard feature of version control
system it preserves the author details
like whatever commit it wants to do
whenever he wants to create a new
version it has to invent uh some of the
author details now this author details
involve an email id and a particular
username
now this email id and username if you
don't configure in that case some dummy
system related email id and username
will be picked up so in that situation
we will not be able to understand that
whether the
particular check-in is done by a
developer or it's being done by a
particular machine so for better
understanding to get a better comfort
that's the reason why we use the git
config over here to configure the
username and email address over here
then we have git init command now this
kit in any command is used to create an
empty bare repository so this command
when you run you will be able to create
a bare empty repository and after that
you can further on do the modifications
you can add some comments you can add
some files and all that stuff you can do
over there pretty much
then when you add some files now what
happens that when you do uh you want to
go for a git commit activity before that
the files should be present in the
staging area now staging area is a
location where you will be preparing or
you will be storing the files temporary
before even performing any kind of
comment so get add and get commit
command is something which is executed
into a sequence first of all you will
run the git add command to bring all the
changes or all the change file into a
staging area and when you've done the
git commit command so all the files will
be committed now git commit command will
not take up how many files you want to
commit because whatever the files you
will put up into the staging area git
commit command will read all those files
and it will perform single commit for
them so if you feel that you want to
only check in two files out of 20 files
please go for the git add command and
first add only these two files into the
staging area if you add all the 20 files
into the staging area then all the 20
files will be modified and a new commit
will be created there
then we have git diff command now get
diff command is used to change to see
the changes made to the files to see the
difference you can use get diff command
with the branches also to see the
difference between the two branches
so git commit command is something which
make sure that all the uh changes are
saved permanently into the local
repository so get add and get commit
command are executed into a sequence so
that first of all you can add the files
to the staging area and then git commit
command will pick up those files from
the staging area and preserve
permanently as a commit into the local
repository
then we have git reset command get reset
command used in various types one time
you can use it as in kind of just to
reset the changes in the files and in a
certain way you can also use it to
delete the comments from the git
repository
get status command displays you the
state of working and the staging area so
uh git status command also tells you
certain particular features like what
are the different files which is you
know in the modification state uh how
many files are there present in the
modified states so all those information
is something which we are getting from
the git status
git merge is a very uh good feature
because whenever we work with the
different branches so get merge is a
mechanism to move the changes from one
branches to another so if you are
required to do the modification to the
develop branch and you want to move
those changes to the master branch in
that situation we have to merge develop
branch into the master branch so it's a
kind of a mechanism to move the changes
from one branch to another
then we have git push now till get merge
command all the commands you can run to
the local repository uh which means that
you don't require any kind of remote
repository you can simply
work on the local system and without any
network connectivity with the remote
repository you will be able to perform
those changes
but git push is a mechanism to push or
move the changes from the local
repository to the remote repository so
whatever the comments you have done
every time it will not interact with the
remote repository only when you run the
git push and pull command that is where
you will be performing the interaction
or communication between the local
repository and the remote repository
push is to push the changes from local
to remote repository and pull is
something which is pulling up the
updates from the remote repository to
your local repository
right now let's talk about some of the
basic git operations here now
so far we have seen that one of the
different basic git commands are there
which we use time to time to perform the
various operations and various tasks
within the version control system of kit
here now let's talk about the some of
the basic kit operations as such here
now first one the very first one
operation over here is the initialize of
a git repository now this is something
which we perform to create a kind of a
new repository or a new project then we
have add operation
to add some files then
add operation is used to add some
changes or modified files to the staging
area git commit is something which is
used to create a new version of the
group of files
then pull is to bring down the changes
from the remote repository to the local
repository then push is there to push
the changes from the local repository to
the remote repository so these are some
of the basic operations which we perform
so that we can move the changes from one
state to another and the first one is
git init command now it's used to create
a new and empty repository where a
repository over here now once they get a
init command is executed what will
happen uh you will run the git init
command in a folder for example i have
created a folder called gate repo and in
that i have initialized or executed the
git init command now the moment you did
the execution of git init command so
what will happen a dot git directory
will be created in that system
so this dot get directory represents
that you are working right now onto a
git repository
you can also further run the git status
command and find out that okay this is
the repositories preserved over here but
if you don't have the dot get directory
it means that it's a plain folder and it
is not a kind of a git repository
now remember dot git folder is only the
folder which is created there there will
be no files which will be created as
such in this one so git init is only
creating a bare empty repository onto
the system
right now once the repository is
initialized so you can further on go
ahead and add some files some folders or
whatever stuff you want to perform in
that repository
right so in this diagram you can see
that when you run the git init command
you will be able to see the dot get
directory created over here and you will
also see that that's the only folder
structure which is created as such over
here so on windows machine you will be
able to see it pretty easily because of
the file name but usually in the linux
platforms dot git is specifically
designed or is known as an hidden folder
so all the files and folder with dot in
front will be considered as hidden there
so in that case you can run ls hyphen la
rt to get on and to see the content over
there
then we have add operation now once you
fire the modification has done so once
you all the changes are performed there
so you will be adding the uh in order to
perform the comments first of all you
have to add the files to the staging
area so staging area is in a particular
temporary location where the git commit
command will look upon and all the files
which is present in the staging area
will be picked up and all of them will
be preserved or will be converted to a
git comment so before running the git
commit command git add command is
required for the files to be added so
that we will be able to move them to the
comment here now in this case you can
see that git status is the one which we
are running to check on which status we
are right now and uh we have modified
like a file called alpha.txt so git add
dot is what we are trying to run over
here
and uh then you can see that from the
red color earlier it was an untracked
file but now it's became in tracked
files and it says new file and then
further we did the git commit so at that
moment of time what will happen that
this file will be completely checked out
into the repository and uh further after
this one commit if you run git status
command there will be no file present
there so git add and get commit command
are executed into a sequence so that
they will be able to have a proper
commits there now the commit is in
situation where you will be changing
your history of your repository it make
sure that uh the changes which you are
doing is permanently preserved into the
gate repository so git commit command
requires a particular flag called hyphen
m now hyphen m is something which is
there for providing custom message for
what reason you are doing the git
comment now if you don't provide this
message your git commit will fail but
you need to provide a message to specify
that what is the reason behind
performing this commit activity so that
is what you are trying to provide over
here with the hyphen name over here and
preserving and providing the details
that yes this is the reason why you are
performing a commit activity into your
local repository
so you can see here that we are giving a
particular comment message called beta
gamma but
in real world you will be providing some
comments like fixed develop bug 120 or
fix this feature or fixed you know this
functionality so that we will be able to
see from the commit message that what is
the reason behind this commit here so we
don't have to unnecessarily go inside
the commit and find out the details all
the details we should be able to get it
from the commit message so that's the
reason why it's very important that we
provide a valid commit message
right then we have the next operation
over here is the pull now pull is
something which is used to fetch the
latest updates from the remote
repository and then merge those changes
back to your local repository so just
kind of operation in which we are taking
up the update from the remote repository
the purpose of taking update from the
remote repository is that because
different developers are collaborating
or uploading their source code to this
remote repository so in that situation
if we want to take some updates from the
remote repository that is the reason why
we will be using the git pull command to
get those changes and merge it into your
local repository
then you can have some example like we
can run the command called git pull
origin master now it will copies all the
files from the remote repository to your
local repository so it will do a sync up
of master branch of remote applicity
into the local repository master branch
you can have the uh it's in combination
of two commands one is a git fetch so
first of all it downloads all the
content and then get merged it combines
all the uh sequence of comments into the
specific branch so it's internally when
you run git pull command it fetches the
uh specific contents now when git fetch
command runs it does not uh really
changes any kind of modifications into
your local repository uh ultimately when
the git merge happens that is where the
code changes into your local repository
but if you alone run git fetch command
it will not perform any kind of changes
to your local repository right here you
can see that we are pulling up the
details so here we are pulling up the
details of our first triple and when
that is done so we will be able to see
some details out of that
right now then we have git push command
which is used to and push the changes
from your local repository to the remote
repository you will be doing a various
kind of comments into your local
repository so at some moment of time you
need to sync up or move those changes to
remote repository that is where we will
be running the git push command so git
kubush command is required it needs a
network connectivity and before get push
command if you want to do some changes
you can do that and once you want to
share or you want to bring those changes
to the remote repository that is where
you will be able to run the git push
activity as such so this is a kind of a
mechanism using which you will be able
to push some changes from the local
repository to the remote repository
so here you can see that we are pushing
the changes from the master branch of
our local repository to a remote
repository and in this case as you can
see that it says here as a new branch
because the remote repository was empty
and there is no master branch present
over there so that is the reason why it
says new branch over here
so these were some of the git operations
which uh talk about that how we can do
some basic information and basic stuff
over there but now next thing which we
have over here is the advanced git
operations now in this one some couple
of operations involved
as in git branch
then we have the get merge and then we
have the get free base here now the
first one is the branch now a branch is
in kind of a way of doing a parallel and
independent development over here now at
some moment of time you feel that the
developers needs to work on the source
code or the changes independent of each
other so in this situation you will be
giving either a feature branch or a
development branch to different
different developers they will be doing
their respective changes to these
branches and then further on you can do
the sync up and you can merge the
changes to a single branch according to
the requirement
so the commits are done isolated from
each other so if you're doing some
comments in developed branch it will not
put any kind of impact on the master
branch so get branch command is used to
see to create a branch to list a branch
to delete a branch or to particular you
know rename a specific branch also
then we have merge when we are working
talking about branching then merging is
also an important task so the merge
command is used to
move the changes on one or multiple
changes from one branch to another so it
is a mechanism to perform a sync up of
the commits from one branch to another
so git merge command is used to combine
two branches and uh it's in kind of a
mechanism in which we find out a single
base a common base and then on top of
that we move the changes or we combine
the two branches here
now git previous is also performed for
the same approach but the process of
rebasing refers to moving or combining a
sequence
of a commit into a new base comment so a
git rebase is something which is doing a
little bit restructuring of the commits
and normally get merge command is
involved in which it can you know
preserve the uh specific base comment
and uh on top of that it can add up your
comments and it can do the modifications
but when we talk about rebase rebase is
something which is combining the commits
but it also preserves or it may end up
in having a new base commit as such over
here so get reverse is somehow doing
some modifications and
restructuring the overall
baseline of the comments
right so git rebase command is used to
integrate the changes from one branch to
another here
now these were some of the advanced
features which is there which is
primarily used by the development team
to do the modifications in different
branches then use the merge or rebase
command to move those changes across
different different branches here now
let's talk about github now what exactly
is a github there now there are some
common uh scenarios where we think that
okay git is different and github is
different uh no it's not like that
ultimately github is nothing but an
organization which internally uses the
get repository only so they are using
the git solution only but it's kind of a
web-based graphical interface which is
given to you
just to you know have a better
interaction with the git repositories so
it's kind of a get repository hosting
service which is available there so for
example you have the various hosting
machines like godaddy is there different
other windows are there but ultimately
they provide the same virtual machines
like linux windows and all that
similarly here also they are all using
the gate only but they are providing it
in as in kind of a good interface
they're providing you certain features
and these features are somewhere you can
have the security you can have the user
ways you can have the permissions so all
those features you get with the help of
the github here so it's a kind of a web
interface which is given to you just to
interact with the git repository to
create them to manage them to delete
them all those activities
so it helps every team member to uh
integrate with each other and at any
moment of time now this is uh something
which you can access anywhere if you are
using the public version of github you
can use the uh repository anywhere with
any network but if you are using a
private network or a private repository
in that situation definitely in your
office or into your network you will be
able to access but it primarily depends
on the way that how you are doing the
modification and how exactly you have
done the changes so far and so over here
right so it's one of the good
collaboration tool which is present
which primary you know talks about that
how we can do the modifications and how
we can move the changes from you know we
can have the collaboration between
different developers and they can really
do the changes and those modifications
right now one of the different features
which we have of github so let's talk
about that now some of the features are
present over here in this way that uh
represents it what are the mechanism and
understanding about the
specific github here
so let's talk about these features
now the very first feature of this one
is the easy project management now uh
it's a very good platform where you can
you know have different kind of access
levels project managers and you know
developers can coordinate they can track
and they can update their work
you can manage the repositories you can
manage the access you can perform the
changes you can perform the rollback a
lot of things can really happen there
and everything is recorded nothing so
even the account activity is also
recorded so if someone is creating the
repository is deleting the repository
all that information is there so it's
kind of a easy project management where
at a single location all the
repositories are there so it's quite
easy for you to manage and to work on
these repositories and to talk about
them
next we have effective team management
now it helps all the team members to
stay on the same page and stay organized
so it's in kind of a modernized tool
which is available there to so that
different people can you know work on
the same platform uh they don't have to
learn different different platforms here
as such on the same platform they will
be able to collaborate and they will be
able to uh you know work with each other
then improved code writing so there are
some features like you know pull request
which gives you
functionality before even doing the
merge activity you will be able to do
some review so it definitely helps a
kind of a check which is there that
before even doing some kind of uh
merging you should be able to review it
you should be able to see that what
exactly you are trying to do what kind
of comments you are performing and that
can really helps to you know do some
improvements to your source code to your
overall source code so that's an
additional check which is provided by
the pull request feature of github it's
not a typical merge only it's something
someone will review someone approve it
then only the merge activity will happen
now github uses different uh tools uh to
identify and analyze the issues there so
um there are some tools or features
which is available there in github where
you can also further on increase or you
know analyze the source code and analyze
the issues with your source code there
so development teams can work together
to you know to secure the software uh
supply chain uh these uh particular uh
say repositories are quite
and that is the reason why not everyone
have the access or default access to the
source code so this is quite extended
and due to this feature it's easy to
maintain the high quality of your source
code
right and then we have the easy code
hosting here so all the codes and
documentations are present in one
location there are millions of
repositories which is available there on
github and each repository is comprises
of its own source code and its own
different different people having the
access right and then it increased
safety with packages those packages can
be published privately you can have both
public and private access the packages
can be used or reused by downloading it
from github and other variety of
applications is there so if you're
working on open source in that situation
it will be publicly available if you're
working as a privately foreign secured
organization in that case it will be
available privately there
right so these were some of the various
operations which was there related to
git now let's talk about some demo and
see that how exactly we can go for that
implementation and we can see some real
operations of kit so let's connect to
our get simply learn lab over here a
linux lab where we can perform all these
various operations and we can see that
how exactly it works so let's log into
the lab
okay so we have logged into the simply
done lab over here in the linux now in
this one the various steps we will going
to do is step by step so first of all we
have our particular github account
logged in so that's the account which we
were using okay so we will create a
remote repository here so first of all
we will be preparing a bear empty
repository now after that we will be
adding some files we will be doing some
uh get comment activities and then we
are going to talk about like some
branching concepts and then the emerging
concepts and all that stuff right so now
let's log into the uh particular lab
here so i'm opening the terminal now
here does not requires any kind of root
access or those kind of stuff so i'm
going to create a folder structure with
the name called
repo so repo is the folder which i'm
going to create as such over here so in
this case right now as you can see that
there is no repository or nothing is
present here so i will run the get init
command which will do nothing but it
will initialize a bear repository over
here so as you can see that when you run
the uh get in it command you will be
able to see a dot get directory created
now this dot get directory represents
that you are working with uh empty where
git repository now once you get the
repository now if you have to execute
some git commands like i can run the get
status command which can really let us
know that yes you are working on a git
repository if you don't have the dot
gate directory definitely this kind of
response you will not be able to get
right so so far we have only added up a
particular kind of a get empty
repository over here now i'm going to
create some files okay so these files
i'm going to create so as i should be
able to do some modifications and i
should be able to add some files so i'm
going to create a file called
master.txt in this case when you edit
files i'm going to add like
my first repository over here so that's
what i need to do
so this is my master.txt file here so
once the master.txt file is created now
if i run the git status command what
will be the response the response will
show me that you are basically trying to
add a new file so there is an untrad
file new file over here in order to
track it and in order to add it to the
staging area we have to further undo the
git add command now get add command
alone will not work you have to further
on after that run the git commit command
also to preserve it or to showcase it as
an kind of a git commit here so first of
all i will add the master.txt file so
what will happen to the status so you
can see that the color of the file is
being uh you know changed from red to uh
green here green represents that this is
a new file and the master.txt file is
being printed over there so so far we
have added this master.txt file into the
staging area staging area is in kind of
a area in which we will be adding up
some couple of files and the whole
purpose of adding those files is that we
should be able to proceed to the next
level which is nothing but the git
commit activity so we are going to run
the git commit activity over here now in
this one i can say like
first commit according to my comfort i
can give whatever the message i want to
provide i can provide that information
right now in this case as you can see
that it picked up my default author over
here right so if i want to do that
modification if i want to you know
perform that activity and i want to
change my author details i can run the
get config command over here now get
config command i can go for global i can
say like user dot name i can have like
my name
some dummy ip i can provide here so what
will happen that all the further
comments which i will be doing that i
will be able to uh do and i will be able
to set up there right now my author
details is you know configured so i will
reset my author using this command here
so this isn't kind of a mechanism that
once your details is being changed your
username and email ids details is
changed you should be able to reset your
author details right so it will open the
commit message again uh you just have to
save it and after that the comment
should be performed here so earlier the
commit was uh being done with the
details called ubuntu which is the user
right now and some dummy ip address but
at any moment of time you want to have
your own username password so you can
say like git config iphone iphone global
user dot name you have added a username
here then you are going for get config
high fifth and global user email id over
here and after that what you have to do
you just have to reset the author
details so that whatever the comments
you have done so far that also should be
updated so instead of having a ubuntu
user under some random email id now
you're giving a specific author in this
case it's me a specific author details
as such into the history so once the kit
committee command is executed so what
will happen that entry will be made up
into the history now there is only one
commit which means that the last commit
which you have performed that have
eventually added up the kit commit
activity so this is the overall
mechanism that how exactly you can
create a bare repository then you have
added up some couple of files then you
added or executed git add command and
further on you did the git commit
command during the git commit command we
faced the difficulty the author details
was not proper then we added the author
details and then we reset our author
details so that we should be able to
perform a basic operation and uh this
mechanism should let us know that how
the execution and the performance is
happening here
so the overall mechanism you can perform
as such over here is that how exactly
this particular mechanism or this
activity is really performing right so
this is the way that how exactly the
overall operation is really happening
and you are able to get a kind of a log
kind of a history in the repository that
what is the change which is being done
who is the person who have performed the
changes now if you want to get the
changes that what was changed over here
so for that you can run the command
called get show
and the uh specific commit id
once that is done so what will happen
you will also be able to say that yes
you have added the content called my
first repo that is what you have added
so far in this commit here so these are
some of the basic operations which time
to time we perform so that we can do
some changes really to our particular
repository
right so this was some of the steps
there now further on what we will be
doing we will be basically performing a
branching mechanism so let's talk about
branching so right now
the branch which we have connected so
far is the master branch
you can see a static symbol in front of
which it means that you are pointing
down to this specific branch as such
over here so next what you're going to
do is that you are going to create a new
branch so we will say that i'm going to
create a develop branch here
so when you run the git branch hyphen l
here so it says that the develop branch
is created but it's not pointed down
right now so in order to move to that
branch so you have to run the git
checkout
command to move to that branch now once
you move to that branch you will be able
to see the static symbol is in front of
develop branch so this movement of from
one branch to another is important
because ultimately if you want to do the
modification to the develop branch you
have to be there in that developed
branch if you want to go to the master
branch you have to be there in master
branch so this is something which
ultimately you need to understand so
that there should not be any kind of
interface between the branches as such
over here
so this is the overall mechanism so now
whatever the commits we will be doing
that will be checked in into the
specific develop branch and all the
changes being will be performed as such
over there
so now the next activity which we are
going to talk about over here is that
how exactly we can proceed further to
these activities now what mechanism we
are going to follow over next over here
is that right now in this case you can
see that git branch hyphen l is there so
develop is being pointed out if you want
to see the difference so you can say
like get div master
so that will show you the difference
right now there is no difference as such
over here which represents the
difference is
not at all present so far in this case
right
so the next activity which we need to do
uh over here in this mechanism is
we will be performing some changes
to this master branch here so i will add
some content here saying
adding
content in develop branch
just to you know have a proper check so
that if somehow you know i will see the
files i should be able to see that okay
this is what i have changed in the
develop branch now these two lines are
there definitely when i'm going to see
the difference here again
when i run the diff command so it will
do a branch to branch comparison and it
will say that yes in this branch you
have some additions which is not present
in master branch right so that's the
whole idea the particular master branch
should not be touched upon if i'm doing
some modification to develop branch that
changes should be present in the
particular this branch only
now in this case what happens now we
know that git add command
and uh get
commit command we have to run
so i'm going to say like
develop
branch
right so just an uh kind of a message
you want to provide so that's done so if
i do the git log here so i should be
able to see a new commit instead of one
commit two comments are there
in master branch only one commit is
there that you can eventually check also
i can go
to the master branch and i can check
that also
so in master branch right now you can
see the last output is showing one
commit
this one is showing one commit because
it's present in the master branch this
one is showing two comments because it's
present in the develop branch so both
the branches are having two different
set of comments now definitely if you
want to move the changes from the
develop branch to the master branch all
you have to do is that you have to sync
up and how this sync up is done it's
done using the help of merge activity so
we will double check that on which
branch we are right now so we have
checked that we are on to the master
branch we have to merge the specific
develop branch into the master branch so
for that what we will be doing we will
be running the command called get merge
develop so when we do that what will
happen that it will eventually let me
know or it will eventually move or sync
those changes from the develop branch to
the master branch so earlier in the
previous situation master branch was
showing one commit but now in this case
it's also showing the uh specific that
commit also moved on along over here so
this is how the sync up really happens
and the comments really move from one
branch to another now in this case it's
not only the commit which is being
reflected but even the file is also
being updated over here as such so the
master.txt file is also showing that the
second line is being added as such over
here
right so this is the overall mechanism
and the system that how exactly this
whole activity is really working and how
we will be able to get some execution
and we will be able to get some
particular results out of this one so
this is the way that how the branching
and emerging really happens as such over
here so right now we are working on the
repository and this repository is
nothing but a local repository so so far
now next we will be talking about the
interaction between the github and this
local repository our remote and local
repository so we'll go to the github
remote repository here we'll click on
the uh particular new repository here
so i'm going to create a particular repo
called get repo here
the name is available but if i give some
different name so if it is not available
so that will not allow me to create a
repository
so here the public and private specifier
you have to select public anyone can see
but no one will be able to do the
modification unless we provide the
access
private nobody will be able to see the
content unless and until he is not
having the access so only modification
and view access both is restricted if
they have the access to the repo
we don't have to initialize the
repository with the readme i want to
create a bayer repository so create
once the repo is created you will see
three sections of the information first
if you want to create a new repository
on the command line and do that so you
can see that some of the activities we
have already done so far so we don't
require this section second section
saying that if you already have a
repository and you want to push it to
the remote repository so you have to run
these commands so these are something
which we need to really do so i am going
to run this command
now this command is something which is
trying to add the remote origin over
here
now why origin is required because every
time i cannot simply
use the lengthy url and i cannot
remember it also so you can see here
that it's kind of a shortcut over here
that origin is being referred as this
url so both for pull and push activity
we will be using this one
so you will be running like git push
or a gen
master
it will definitely ask for your
credentials so
you will give the url username
and you will also give the
password now once that is done so you
what you will see over here is that you
will be able to see that a new branch is
created because in github repository you
were not having any kind of code base
available so when you refresh the code
will be available there
but this is just the master branch if
you want to move the
particular develop branch here
it's the same details you have to
provide
the same username
credentials also are same which you need
to provide and once that is done you
will be able to see that develop branch
is also created as such over here so you
see two branches
two branches are in proper sync up and
you want to create the leader branch you
can do that you want to switch it branch
you can do that also
because of the dummy ip address you must
have seen that it's showing a particular
different username here because i have
just provided a different email id like
abc.abc.com so which is totally wrong
so id when you will be providing the
actual information about the username
that will be presented over here and
that should be displayed but right now i
just provided a dummy email id so not
the genuine one
so here if you click on this commit id
so you will see the content this is the
last commit which we were doing uh this
is the first commit which we did on that
part
so this is how you interact with the git
repository
right from the scratch we have prepared
this repository we have executed that
and as you can see that once the
repository is created you were able to
get a particular git repository on the
github there so that's it for this demo
to today's topic on maven tutorial in
this we are going to talk about the
maven here
now we will be talking about that how
exactly we can make use of maven here in
performing various kind of operations
whether it's a build compilation with
this kind of stuff there so let's talk
about it why exactly we use maven here
now me1 is something which uh is a kind
of a build tool which is there for most
of the job-based projects here so this
tool also helps us in building up the
source code by downloading some couple
of dependencies these dependencies are
something which is being configured by
the developers which a developer feels
that the project is dependent on and he
requires those dependencies to be
downloaded so uh this tool is
specifically used to build and manage
any kind of a job-based project whatever
the complexity of the topic or the
project is there so this tool will be
able to handle that particular
requirement or that project so it
simplifies the uh day-to-day work of a
java developer and helps them in their
projects for performing daily to daily
activities
right now maven also helps us in getting
the specific jar files for each and
every project so if you are going you
can pretty much make a jar file var file
or er file any kind of a package
mechanism you can follow for your maven
day so to download the dependencies we
don't have to actually go to the
official website of each and every
software you can easily get it uh the
dependencies of each and every
third-party band race on the
mvnrepository.com this is a website
which is present on which if you visit
you will be able to download the
dependencies which is required by your
project or by your
specific
project over here so it totally depends
on how exactly you want to download and
you want to get together a specific
repository over here so
mvnrepository.com is the one if you
visit you will be able to download and
go through all the jar files dependent
jar files as independences which you
require for your current project
right so now what exactly is a maven all
about so let's see on that part
so
maven is a popular open source build
tool which is uh developed by the apache
group and the primary uh ownership of
this tool is to build publish and deploy
several projects at once meven is
written in java and it can be used to
build projects written in c shaft scala
ruby etc so apart from java these are
the different programming languages are
the tools which is supported by the
maven here for performing the build
activity so the tool is uh used for
build and management of any kind of a
job-based project it simplifies the
day-to-day work of a java developer and
helps them to automate most of the
compilation or build
uh perspective tasks on the projects
right now maven is a kind of a
bomb-based project so it also known as
an project object model and it focuses
on of simplification and standardization
of the building process in the process
it take cares of all the followings here
bills dependencies reports
distribution releases mailing list so
all these uh things are being taken care
as in this particular process here and
ultimately it's an availability inside
the maven that how the overall build
process needs to be automated and
standardized here so all these
particular mechanisms is can be followed
as such over here so that we can have a
good uh standards and the
simplifications implemented as such here
now what exactly is a maven repository
all about
so maven repository is uh something
which uh is a
kind of a directory or it's kind of a
location where we have all the jar files
packaged all together in a single
location so depending on the software
which you want to download the dependent
java files can be downloaded from there
so the metadata refers to the pom files
relevant to each project here this
metadata is what allows maven to
download the dependencies now there are
three type of repositories from where we
can download the dependencies the first
one is the local repository second one
is the remote repository and the third
one is the central repository so these
are the primary three type of
repositories which is available there
for our specific maven over here
so whatever repository you want to
follow you want to access you can pretty
much access it and you can go with that
right
now the local repository will be primary
present onto your pc that's the way that
how it's present there and the
particular remote repository is
something which you can store on any
remote machine or remote server and the
central repository is something which
you can have it onto the internet so
usually the central repositories is
something in which we can actually host
our different kind of dependencies and
the jar files over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is saved so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine remote machine is
the location where you can actually
store all your particular dependencies
from where you can download these
dependencies whenever you require it so
this and repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from the remote repository
it's first downloaded if into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local it will be first downloaded from
the remote repository and then it will
be utilized or will be referenced onto
the local machine there
and central repository is refers to the
maven community repository there where
you will be able to see each and every
dependency present on that repository so
maven downloads the repositories from
here in the local repository whenever
they're needed or whenever required all
these dependencies are cached locally
from where it will be referenced in the
next or you know whenever we want to
refer that we will be able to do that
particular reference easily on that part
so this is the way that how the three uh
particular repositories or movement
repositories really helps us for
performing various kind of automations
as such here
right now one of the basic concepts of
maven here so some of the couple of
basic concepts which is present in maven
is like for the first time we have the
project object model so project bomb
reference to the xml file which has all
the information regarding the project
how this particular project should be
built up how the different build process
should be automated there it also has a
description of the project details
regarding the versioning version
information is also stored as such in
this xml file in this
particular
form reference file as such over here
the xml file is which is there in the
project home directory so maven is uh
something which search for the palm file
in the current directory if it's able to
find that particular pom file so it will
execute or it will proceed with the
build step otherwise they it will halt
there itself so this spawn file is very
important because it will act as a kind
of a build script and primary the maven
tool will be able to process each and
everything which is configured as such
in this
specific xml file there and according to
that only it will function or it will
proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
jar files so the java libraries which we
need in our into our particular project
so while uh working on the project we
may be having the dependency on couple
of dependencies so these dependencies we
have to actually download or we have to
actually refer and once these a
particular information or these details
are referred so what will happen that uh
we need to download these specific
dependencies from the particular maven
repositories so if the dependencies are
not present in your local repository
then maven will try to download it from
the central repository and cache it into
your local repository but first of all
it will look on into the local
repository and if it is not present in
local then it will go to the remote or
the central repository
then we have build life cycles and phase
and goals there so build lifecycles
consist of the sequence of build phases
and each field phase consists of
sequence of goals here now each goal is
responsible for performing a specific
task when a phase is uh running all the
goals related to that phase and its
plugins are also used to performing the
compilation preparing the artifacts
downloading the dependencies all
different things being done by the
plugins here then we have the build
profile so build profiles refers to a
set of configuration values now
generally we have the generic build
process for all the environments all the
particular code base there but sometimes
we do have some kind of a differences
there so that is where we can go for the
profiles because a specific profile can
have its own configuration and uh
whatever it's required for the build
process we can have different different
configurations stored inside the maven
build script here then with different uh
build profiles are added to the palm
files and uh which enables the different
uh build as such here so depending on
these profiles we can actually decide
that how we need to proceed with the
build process and how the different kind
of build automations needs to be
performed here
then a build profile helps in
customizing the build for the different
environments so that also we can perform
as such while workforming or while
working on the different components and
the different management here so a build
profile is something which you can
configure you can utilize and depending
on that build profile we will be
deciding whether to proceed further or
how to decide on that particular factor
so these are something which we need to
take care or we need to work according
to which we can decide that how the
specific configurations and specific
automation needs to be performed here
now
usually when we go for the um even there
so we have to use some couple of maven
plugins now the goal of using these
specific plugins is to automate some of
the basic stuff like compilation
creating the var file creating the java
file so when we are using the plugins we
don't have to configure the steps or
write the steps that how these uh
specific plugins should be installed or
should be referenced it's ultimately the
internal configurations which we are
looking forward or which we are using
while working on these specific plugins
so you can download some couple of
plugins using which we will be able to
decide that how a specific goals needs
to be achieved here so maven has its own
standard plugins that can be utilized so
if uh you know want to go for a custom
one so you can do that but pretty much
you can go for the default one and uh
you can pretty much have some specific
goals executed with the help of these
build plugins
now next thing is the maven architecture
so uh in maven what happens that uh
let's talk about the basic architecture
of maven here so
the maven is executable when it's
deployed so it usually uh reads the
palm.xml file which is the build script
here now once the specific pondered xml
file is being read out
so it will process the components it
will uh you know download or it will
process the dependencies plugins life
cycles phases and goals and even the
build profiles and uh if any kind of
interaction is required so it will try
to connect to the central repository or
remote repository and according to that
it will provide the information and
provide the details as such so mu
repository is something which is very
important because it's ultimately trying
to connect to the maven repository and
try to achieve the various kind of
automation here
so it's very important because
ultimately it's trying to help us to go
for the
complete end-to-end build automation
when we'll go for a specific palm-based
build automation
so um even is it will read the palm.xml
file then download the dependencies
defined into the power.xml file and that
dependencies are cached locally from the
remote or the central repository now
then create and generate a remote uh
report according to the requirement and
execute the life cycles phases goals
plugins etc so it will process the pound
xml file then and whatever the plugins
and goals or the life cycles which is
configured there step by step each of
them will be executed into a sequence
here
now let's talk about the overall build
life cycle of the maven here so what
happens that uh the maven build life
cycle is something which is a kind of a
collection of different steps there and
this is something which is followed to
perform a build automation for a
specific project so that they are pretty
much three steps which is being done so
first one is the default so it handles
the project deployment there second
handles the project cleaning which is a
clean there and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there
so these are the three built-in
particular life cycles which is
available there at the beaver level
which you can utilize to perform a
various kind of particular steps
execution for your project
all right so the build cycle has uh the
different build phases or stages there
because when we are performing a build a
variety of things needs to be performed
over here so the first one is the
compile then test compile is there so
compilation is there for the source file
and test compile is there for the test
cases test will execute the test cases
package will package the bundle then we
have the integration test to run the
integration test cases then we have the
verify then install goal is there and
the last one is the deploy which is
there to deploy the artifacts to the
artifactory so all these things are the
different phases and the stages which is
being followed as per a specific build
here so during these builds those these
are the different phases and these
stages which we normally follow for
performing the build automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific maven here so that is something
which we need to talk about that how the
particular automation needs to be done
or how we can actually go for the
configurations where we feel that yes we
want to perform or we want to take
certain benefits out of the
implementation of maven here
so for that what happens that we have to
see that the various kind of uh benefits
the first one is that apache maven helps
manage all the processes there such as
building documentation releasing and
distribution in project management here
so the tool simplifies the process of
project building it increases the
performance of the project and the
building process all together and the
task of downloading jar files and other
dependencies is also done automatically
we don't have to indulge in any kind of
download part as such manually over here
right and um provides easy access to all
the required information so maven makes
it easy for a specific developer to
build a project in the different
environments so we don't have to worry
about the environment we don't have to
worry about the infrastructure nothing
is required everything is available
there inside this package and you know
depending on the particular you can
write the source code on one machine and
you can pretty much do the build on
another machine and this is the reason
how the build automation really happens
on the first place because the developer
is writing the source code in one
location and the same code is deployed
onto the uh particular or built onto
this jenkins or any kind of build tool
there
right in maven you can easily add new
dependencies so you must write the
particular dependencies in the form file
so if you feel that you want to download
some particular dependencies so all you
have to do is that you have to put that
dependency into the
specific pom.xml file there and
depending on that the execution will be
really performed and executed as a chair
right so let's talk about the demo now
so let's see that how exactly we can go
for this demo and we can perform the
various kind of automations
so this is the virtual machine which we
have here on which the maven is already
installed so we can run like mvn
so maven will be available as in three
point six point three here now i'm going
to run a particular command called uh
mvn archetype generate here
let me create a directory here our temp
directory
and to perform this activity over there
so mvn
arc type
generate now once we run that so what
will happen that it will uh download
some of the binaries there because
uh ultimately what we are trying to do
is that we are trying to generate a new
project like a maven project so a couple
of uh particular plugins will be
downloaded by the maven executable so
that it can achieve that particular
execution so we just have to wait for
downloading all these values now here
it's trying to give us a particular
attributes like it's asking the
different attributes over here so what
exactly we want to configure so if you
want to configure you can provide that
details otherwise you can
perform or whatever the setup you want
to perform now here it's asking for the
version so which kind of version we want
to follow so i'm going to follow like
five here so i'll press five
then a group id which is there so uh
it's basically a kind of a group
mechanism so i can say like com
dot simply learn so that's the value
which i'm providing here artifate id i
can make it like a
sample project or something like that uh
i can do
so that will be the artifact uh
id which is there so
version i'm keeping the same only so
and uh yeah so package same here
so i just want to create so i'll just
provide the value called yes and enter
so with this what will happen that a
sample project will be created here
right so whatever the artifact id you
provided so according to that the
project is created in this directory so
you have to go into this directory and
see that what exactly the files are
created there so you have the pom.xml
file now this form.xml file when i open
so you can see here that there are some
attributes like you can have the values
uh related to what version or group id
you want to follow so this is the group
id this is the artifact id so this is
jar file by default you can change it
according to your requirement then this
is the version and if you feel that you
want to do the changes to the name that
also you can perform here so by default
the junit dependency is added but if you
want to keep on adding your own custom
dependencies you will be able to do that
now in this case if you run like mv and
clean install so it will be considered
as in particular maven project a powered
xml file is already there present in the
local directory so according to that the
execution of the steps will be performed
and according to that you will be able
to get some desired values here so
ultimately in the target directory you
will be able to see that some couple of
jar file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the target directory this jar file or
this artifact is generated here so this
is a way that how we can actually go for
a generic one like a new uh particular
project and later on you can depending
on your understanding you can keep on
adding or you can keep on modifying the
dependencies and that's how you can get
the final result there
so that's it for this demo uh in which
we have find out that how exactly we can
go for a particular project preparation
with the help of mvn executable
so that's it for this demo things
right so that was the demo in which we
uh saw that how exactly we can go for
the maven and we can execute some build
process related to maven there hey
everyone i welcome you all to this junit
full course by simply learn in this
complete course we will learn everything
we need to know about junit and mokito j
unit
we have anuch to guide us through this
journey we shall begin with
understanding the basics of junit and
have a look at different aspects of
junit
in these aspects we shall understand the
relevance and features of junit
moving forth we shall learn the working
of junit with java and eclipse with the
help of a hands-on demo
after we have a complete knowledge about
junit and it's working we shall go on to
explore mojito
in mokito j unit we shall understand
what mocking is and how we can perform
it
while we are at it we shall know about
the basics of stub and how to create it
to better understand the mokito j unit
we shall see all these processes and the
entire working of mokito with a hands-on
demo
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
don't forget to click on the bell icon
so you never miss an update from
simplylearn welcome everyone to yet
another topic on junit tutorial now in
this one we are going to talk about
what exactly is in junit uh tool all
about and how we can do various kind of
test implementations with the help of
junit so let's talk about the agenda
which we are going to cover here now in
this one specifically we are going to
talk about like what exactly is j unit
uh what is this particular framework all
about then we are going to talk about
junit installation how we can do the
installation of junit and what are the
different steps we can get involved on
that and then we are going to talk about
the features of junit what are the
different uh typical features of junit r
or about then j unit annotations we are
going to talk about and then junit in
java and the actual implementations some
tutorials or some demos on how to
implement junit with eclipse so these
are some of the main topics which we are
going to cover all together over here as
such
now let's talk about what exactly is the
junit tool all about like what are the
different things we can implement with
the help of this tool here so junit is
basically a kind of unit testing
framework which is there for the java
so it's kind of a default offering for
the java programming language that we
can use the junit for the unit testing
framework for performing the unit
testing now the main benefit of the
junit is like it's using the same syntax
like a java programming language so it
makes it very easy for a java developer
to write and execute the test cases so
most of the times when the developers
are going to work on the java
programming languages so they prefer
that junit as a default unit testing
framework for them because they get the
language advantage they get the easily
integrations and the eclipse so those
benefits helps the developers to decide
junit specifically for writing the test
cases and running the test cases there
now whenever these test cases are
actually being executed whenever you add
up a new piece of source code so uh all
the unit test cases will be executed
will be again executed there every time
when you run a new belt so all the unit
test cases gets executed but you also
need to take care that if you are adding
up a new functionalities you also have
to add the corresponding test cases to
that so increasing more and more code
will uh will be done by the developers
but at the same time you have to sync or
you have to keep your test cases up to
date also and as a part of every build
each and every test cases will be
re-executed every time you're doing the
build five times
six times a day every time the
all unit test cases will be executed
over there and the response will be
given back
right now let's talk about what exactly
is the unit testing now unit testing
refers to the testing of these small
small modules or the small piece of
chunks or the codes here now it's
basically used to have the early
identification of the defects and the
bugs because you cannot simply rely on
the
qa team to perform the testing and then
provide the feedback whereas on the uh
with the help of this unit testing
framework we can immediately get the
feedback right away once we are running
the test cases immediately we will be
able to know like these are the
different test cases which we have got
over here now the developers don't even
have to spend more time on fixing the
bugs and issues because these test cases
will help them with the easy and the
fast feedback so according to that they
can fix the bugs and they can take the
decision whether the source code is
working fine as expected or there is any
kind of issues as such present with this
one so unit test casing is something
which is very important from the
developer's perspective also because it
helps the developers to understand that
they whether they have written a
successful code or if there is any kind
of scope of issues or bugs over here
also it uh the successful unit test
cases uh increases the overall
confidence of the developers because it
uh increases the overall
performance and the quality of the
product also so by having the successful
executions of the unit test cases
developers can understand that yes the
source code is working fine as expected
and there is no scope of bugs or any
issues as such with this source code
here
so that's the main benefit which we get
with unit testing that with this fast
feedback channel we will be able to take
uh the decisions whether the source code
is ready for the production environment
deployment or not so that's a main
benefit which we get with the
unit testing here now of course this can
be done in two ways manual testing and
automatic testing now in case of manual
testing you have to do this thing
manually within a manual tester or a
manual testing approach and in this one
you will not be depending on any kind of
automated tool which can be scheduled or
which can be executed in non-interactive
manner on the other hand automatic test
case is something which uh is used to be
executed using the tool and it is
something which is being done so that
you will be able to get the complete
automation there is no manual efforts
which is required as such you are going
to have like complete uh deployment and
automations being done as such in this
case so automated testing is something
in which you will be giving more focus
on the automated automation tools you
may be having one or a couple of tools
which using which you can write the
automated test cases and you can perform
the complete automation in case of
manual testing it's quite a
you know less reliable because you are
dependent on the uh a particular tester
which can ha perform the testing
according to his efforts and it's quite
a time consuming also because you can
only run the test cases for probably
eight to nine hours per a day
whereas on the other hand the automated
test case is something which is uh quite
reliable because it does not depends on
a human so so requirements so it can be
done like 24 crore 7 so anytime you can
run those
test cases and that's the reason why
these test cases are quite faster as
compared to any other manual testing
approach here
so junit test cases and the automated
test cases really helps the developers
and the qa professionals to test the
source code much faster as compared to
the manual testing now let's talk about
the joint installation now as part the
of the installation of junit you don't
require to install any exe file or any
kind of program there there are a couple
of jar files which is required which
needs to be there into the a class path
so that every time when you write some
junit test cases you should be able to
refer those jar files because without
having those jar files into your class
part of your project you will not be
able to run the change in test cases so
that's the only dependency you require
if you are running a maven build then
these dependencies will be added up into
the power xml file if you are referring
or doing the build from the eclipse or
doing the development from the ecrips
then you have to put up these jar files
into the
class part of the project so that these
jar files can be loaded up and dj unit
can be referred over here so the
installation is pretty straightforward
but let's see like what are the
different steps we need to follow now as
a pre request of understanding the demo
about junit the first initial two things
is like you require a jdk to be
installed now you can download the jdk8
over here from this oracle website and
uh this is something which you can
download for the windows or whatever
platform you have you can pretty much
install it for whatever platform is
there so for windows platform you can
download for 32-bit and the 64-bit both
option over here and once it's installed
so you should be able to use the eclipse
latest tool now um all you need to do is
like you need to go to eclipse.org and
there you can download the latest
version of the eclipse now these two
main things which you require because
eclipse will be required for creating
the change unit test cases and of course
how a kind of id where you can run some
test cases changing test cases and all
and then oracle is something which is
required as a runtime for running the
jdk also and the junit uh test case is
also an eclipse here
so that's a pre-request which we got
over here in this one so i have already
got these two things installed into my
system and i have
eclipse there so let's move on to the
eclipse and see that how it going goes
on there but before that you also
require the junit jar files because in
order to have a particular junit
framework loaded up we require some uh
particular files jar files over here in
this case so i can just search for j
unit
4 over here and when you search for j
unit 4 so what happens like this
particular page
will help you or give you all the
details about the junit 4
now you can go for the uh version notes
of the different different versions but
uh if you want to download all you need
to do is like you can say like download
and install and the moment you go there
so it will give you the details now
there are two jar files which is
required junit dot jar file is required
over here
j uh ham crest iphone core dot jar file
these two jar files are required here if
you want to download it into the test
class path if you feel that you want to
uh use a maven based uh project then in
that case you have to specifically go
for this dependency into palm file and
according to that that particular
version will be downloaded and will be
referred over there so these are the
ways that how you can get the particular
softwares the required things into the
place so i'm going to put up this jar
files into a location so that i should
be able to get the particular details
uh stored and i can refer to them into
my eclipse so i'm going to download this
one here from the maven central
so i'm going to download this jar file
and then i'm going to go back
and crest hyphen code so that also i
want to download
download chart
so these two jar files i have uh
downloaded and i will be referring these
ones into my project because these are
the ones which has been required into my
project as such so let's go back to the
eclipse and uh let's place this jar
files into a location so that into my
class i can refer the complete folder
with all these two java files inside
that so let's go ahead with that so
let's create a particular new project
over here so we'll go for new
java project
and here i can give it like a simple one
a simple project name i can provide here
and uh jdk i'm using like 1.8 so that's
the jdk version which i have utilized
over here
and then finish
so this is the project which i have got
like in the source directory now i'm
going to create a simple uh file over
here a new class file over here so i'll
create it like
j
unit class so i'm going to create a
class over here in this one and of
course i need to have a particular white
main also over here in this
specific class over here because this is
the initial class i'm trying to create
over here in this one i can create a
custom
particular methods also over here but uh
let's see like if we can execute or we
can run some particular functions as
such over here now i'm going to declare
a function over here public
void
junit
method
so i'm just going to create a method
over here
i'm just going to run a particular
print
statement over here
executing
j unit
test
cases right
now this is a kind of a method which is
there which of course i can run into my
uh public void main and uh this function
will be executed uh will be called upon
over here now the thing is that uh right
now uh since it's just a normal function
but the moment i convert it like i
have uh at the rate test mentioned over
here so what will happen like this will
be converted into the form of a test
cases
now of course like right now there is no
imports which is available there as part
of this one so you can see that the uh
the the time i have added this
annotation at the rate test i will be
able to see like yes add junit 4 library
to the build path is something which is
coming up over here or it's saying like
add junit five so whatever the library
you feel that you want to add you can do
that and that particular library will be
added up over here now let's go for the
junit 4 library here the moment i do
that what will happen
you will see some changes first you will
see the changes in the top saying that
import orj dot junit dot test that's a
first import and second import will be
like junit four you will see like these
two jar files is automatically being
picked up by the eclipse now even if you
don't download these jar files this is
the main benefit of the eclipse that
these are already a part of the plugins
you can see their paths that these are
already installed in plugins directory
so the moment you use these uh
particular methods that you want to use
the junit these will be automatically
imported over here into your system now
you can just simply call this method
into the main void main and then the
specific method will be executed as a
form of test cases
so this is the mechanism that how you
will be
setting up the project initially you got
the imports you got the uh particular
annotations configured and with that the
uh specific jar files will be
automatically being added up into your
class path whatever the java files we
added up we downloaded previously we can
also have that added up into the custom
class path we can modify this build path
of junit 4 which is coming up
automatically we can just simply say
right click
build path and configure so this jf unit
4 we can actually import we can remove
it from our system and we can add our
external jar files also into the uh
build path or the class path over here
so that depends upon you that how you
want to perform the customizations
around that part but yes the particular
main benefit of using the
eclipse is that it's already having the
junit plugin installed both four and
five version is installed whatever
version you feel that you want to
include it will be included and the
plugins are already installed so you
don't even have to download the jar
files manually so that's how you will be
able to do a very basic initial uh setup
of junit and how a basic project can be
created over here in case of chair unit
in the upcoming demos we'll see like how
we can execute these uh particular test
cases and we'll get the response we'll
come to that point so let's go back to
the main content right so that was the
uh junior installation demo which we saw
and we saw like how we can put up or
load the jar files related to changing
it into a class path and we can resolve
the
basic uh you know features about the
chair unit about the test cases now
let's talk about some of the certain
features of the chair unit here now
there are a lot of features which we get
primary with the chair unit let's
discuss about that one by one so the
very first feature about junit is that
it's an open source network
now it's something which is available as
an open source to you
we have also seen the installation so
you don't have to really go for any kind
of
license or something like that so you
can do any number of test cases with
this particular tool and this uh
specific automation tool here you can
automate it into jenkins no way you
require any kind of license around this
so um these can be easily integrated
these are already a part of most of the
latest eclipse installation so you don't
even have to configure these manually
because it's already a part of your
system
right second is that it provides
annotations now
main annotation we have already seen in
the previous case that when we converted
a normal function or a normal method
into the test method by using an
annotation called at the rate test so it
provides a mechanism to identify that
which particular method is a test method
and which method is a normal method
according to our classes so these
annotations really help us to identify
the methods also and it provides us the
flexibility that these uh particular
methods are not the normal methods we
need to execute you need to run it in
the form of test cases so that
identification is something we will be
able to do with the help of these
annotations here uh also it provides the
excitations uh to identify like what
exactly the results are there because uh
definitely when we are running the test
cases in our test cases we need to
assert that what should be the value so
using the assert you know we can
assertions we can actually compare that
okay this method is giving this value
suppose there is an addition
method which is available there which is
giving like a plus b is equal to c so c
is like 5 plus 15 is 20. so with the
help of asset i'm saying like uh
whatever the response i'm going to get
from the function when i give the values
a and b as 5 and 15 so that should be 20
value so in the asset i can hard code
like okay this is the value this is the
response which i should be getting and
once the function is executed i should
be able to get this particular output as
in 20 over here so that comparison when
you do you will be able to understand
easily that yes when we are doing the
asset i am getting the proper response i
am getting the proper output over here
so assertion is something which is very
important to compare the things to
compare the inputs which we are getting
from the application source code
next it provides the uh test runner so
we can basically run the test runners
over here to execute the test cases so
you can uh configure this within the
pipelines you can configure it with
eclipse and various automations during
the build automations also you can
configure it so that flexibility you
will be able to get with these test
runners here and it also allows you
provide a better feedback channel
because it acts like a very good
feedback provider because the moment you
are done with the development you will
be able to get an instant feedback so
the overall quality of the code is going
to be increased in this case and that's
definitely helpful for you because with
this uh approach with this junit uh
framework you will be able to get a
quite faster and a perfect uh code
writing tool or a quality tool which is
available there so definitely the
overall quality of the code is going to
improve with the help of this junit
framework
and it provides the automations also
because these unit uh test cases are
having the flexibility that you can
configure it within the pipelines you
can automate it with the help of this
framework that you can completely help
or you can have a complete automated
workflow with the help of this
particular framework and it provides you
an instant feedback the feedback channel
is quite instant in case of this change
unit
now let's talk about the junit
annotations we have already seen like
the main benefit of the annotation is to
define uh to provide the metadata about
the methods to the different ones so
annotations also refer to the
synthetical uh method data added to the
java source code so having a particular
better of feasibility and
identification is also quite easy so
also the overall structure of the source
code can be done in a better way and the
readability is also good when we talk
about the annotations here the biggest
main difference between the uh j unit
and dj unit 3 was the in the
introduction of the junit annotations so
uh earlier before jth unit 3 we were not
able to identify like if this isn't kind
of a test method or this is a kind of a
source method over here so that
identifications is quite easy after the
involvement or the introduction of the
junit 4 framework over here
also like this is something which is
really helpful to us to see like how
exactly we can overall uh read the
overall source code because you have so
many so many source code there present
to your project so annotation should be
able to uh you know help you to identify
the that these are the main portions
with these are the components which is
part of the unit test cases not the
actual source code so at the rate test
is something which is uh uh you know
going to tell us that uh the the
specific method with the public void
declaration can be run or can be
executed as a test cases this is not a
simple method this is not an application
source code method this is a test method
over here now at the date before is
something which is uh used to run some
statement before each and every test
case is executes maybe having some
additional or initial connectivity is
something you can do with the help of
add that it before
at the rate after is something which you
can do after the execution of the test
cases like some statements which you
want to execute after the uh test cases
so that's something you can do or you
can go with the help of at the date
after
and at the rate ignores is something
which you can configure if you feel like
during the test execution you feel to
ignore some statement so that's the way
you can use the ad that it ignores there
so add that it ignores under it after
add that it before and after it test
these are the four annotations which is
being used most of the time into your
junit test cases
right let's talk about some bit more now
after it before is something which is
being used to execute the classes uh
some statement before even you know any
kind of test class executes so not only
uh
you know before executing any method
this is something before even loading up
any kind of uh test classes so before at
the at the rate before class is being
used
similarly at the rate after will be
there to execute it after all the test
classes and uh if we have a timeout
configured so what will have that we
will be able to set up a timeout while
executing the test cases so timeout
value can be configured over here and
then if you feel like if you want to
handle some exceptions during the test
execution so that's where we can use
this custom annotations over here to
have the exceptions handled or
configured over here in this one so
these are some of the very important
annotations which is available there on
the chair unit perspective
now let's talk about some another demo
on chair unit testing in the java like
how we can pretty much configure the
test cases in junit for a programming
language called java and how we can get
along or get execute those things so now
we are going to see like how exactly we
can you know go for the
uh execution of some java files onto our
command line and how we can uh using the
command line run some execution of the
test cases typically we do it from the
eclipse but uh from the command line
also we are going to see like how
exactly uh you know we are performing
the setup and the executions over here
now what we really need to do is like we
need to see like how we can proceed
further with the execution so i'm going
to open this uh particular java file
over here so to get a better
understanding here so i'm going to use
the uh oj.unit junit uh class over here
in this case so we are having a couple
of imports these are the standard
imports so you can do like orj dot unit
junit dot star also if you don't want to
go for the specific imports here now
here we are going to create a test unit
as an sample class and in this one we
got the
void main over here which is the main
portion of any kind of class here the
only thing which we got over here is
that we have created a test method over
here called test print
message so we are assigning a value
called message a variable over here as
and simply learn now what happens like
we will be able to uh like you know do
the assert equals over here that if the
value of message is like simply learn
so it will be able to help us with the
proper output and uh there will be no uh
errors as such over here so everything
will be smooth and that's what we are
trying to execute over here in this case
and we are running into the null void
that these are the test cases we want to
run or we want to execute over here now
all we need to do is we need to compile
this one we really need to compile this
scale test cases over here this file and
then we have to run that one so for that
let me open the command prompt
so now in this case we will be using the
java c command prompt here and we will
be copying the j unit into the uh class
path so that we will not be able to get
any kind of uh class not found issues
over here so test unit junit.java we are
going to run so if there is no
exceptions as such we will be able to
get no errors here now i'm going to run
the particular class file with the help
of java command because java c is to
convert the dot java file to the dot
class file the compile format and then
in order to run the dot class file we
have to go for the java command line
here now this means that there is no
issues as such with the test cases and
everything is working fine as expected
over here in this one so the assert
equals is going to help you to identify
that if the
execution is proper and let's say like
if we put up some content like some
different content over here in this
asset equals so i'm going to again
execute this one so that i will be able
to see like if you know what will happen
that if this message value and this
value does not matches like in normal
situations it will say like okay uh the
uh particular uh you know output is
going up and there is no errors as such
right so let's see like what exactly uh
it will happen that if we go for the
executions like if we save this file in
such a way that we are providing some
wrong inputs and what will happen to our
asset equal over here so i'm going to
again compile the file here so again a
new class file will be available and
this time i'm going to execute this
class file again over here in this case
and the moment you did it the assert
will give you the uh comparison over
here saying that there is a failure of
the comparison why there is a failure of
the comparison because according to the
code base it was expecting the value
called simply learn but it simply got
the value called simply learn one two
which means that your test cases over
here got failed on so this is the real
way that how you will be providing the
comparison like what you should be
putting up to the application and what
kind of response you should be getting
in in return of that so that's where you
will be able to provide a proper and a
complete comparison here which will help
you to understand that what exactly
output you're going to get over here and
that's where the output will be
completely
available to you and you will be able to
get a proper output asset here
right so this is the way that how the
comparison will be performed and how you
will be able to see like these two
comparison being done here as such so
this is the way that how you're going to
run the test cases in the form of the uh
from the command line here so let's go
back to the main document right now the
next one which we got over here is the
j-unit test cases using the eclipse
because from the command line we saw
like using the command line we can do
but we got like so many test cases which
is available there so it's not easy for
us to run those one by one so we will be
doing it through the eclipse so that we
can see like how the execution can be
really done and we can get a hold of
those particular components so let's go
back to the eclipse and this time we are
going to run the test cases in the
eclipse here now let's create a new
project again here
j
[Music]
unit
project
right
and finish so a new j project a junit
project will be created now in this one
you can see like there is no
executables libraries for junit but you
can include it now also but i'm going to
do it later on so i'll go for the
j unit
project class right so this is a kind of
a test class here so i'm not going to
put the null the public void mean over
here in this one so finish
now in this case what i'm going to do is
like i'm going to you know replace this
content over here so uh with this uh
particular ones
and uh going to have some basic core
base added up over here so i'm going to
import some uh particular junit uh
libraries over here so over here like
oj.junit i'm going to import these ones
and i got like this class over here
junit uh you know project so i just have
to rename it a little bit so that it can
be the name of the actual class uh name
here so that's fine so everything is
fine but the only thing is that we are
getting some failures and problems over
here because it's not able to identify
these uh specific uh junit related
executables like the functions and the
methods for this one again the previous
like previous case you have to do the uh
particular addition of the
library to the build path so that you
will be able to have like these
automatically resolved over here in this
one right so you can see now that the
unit 4 started reflecting over here in
this case and you did not got any kind
of errors now over here in this one so
you can simply save this and now you can
you are good to go for running the
executions over here so you can simply
say like right click over here run s and
j unit test
and when you do that on the left hand
side you will be able to get a little
bit different viewpoint over here which
says like yes test and score j unit is
something which is executed perfectly
fine if for any reason let's say like i
change the value of string one here as
in string one just an typo error i'm
trying to do here so that i can show you
that how the test cases really fails so
assert equals is basically helping to
find out that if the comparison between
the two attributes is correct that means
that uh you know the inputs which we are
putting up and whatever the output we
are getting it's both the same here when
you do that you will say like there is
an failure over here to the test cases
now i'm seeing the failure trace over
here so i'll just move this one to the
console view so it says like it should
be like string but i got like string one
over here which is causing the problem
here because of the typo error which i
did the whole execution of the test
cases got failed so i'm just going to
revert my changes back here and again
run the test cases
it will all be okay right now again over
here so that's a main reason that how
the execution really happens in the
overall mechanism and the system can be
implemented over here in this case so
that's how we basically go on and we
execute some junit test cases here now
in this one we are going to talk about
like how exactly we can use both
marketer and junit here to go for the
unit testing but before even talking
about these two tools here let's focus
on to understand like what is exactly a
unit testing here now there are various
kind of testing which is actually
available into our particular industry
and into our software testing world
there but yes there is a very important
scope and a position of the unit testing
here so unit testing is something which
uh we also call is an kind of a
component uh uh testing is actually a
software testing technique in which
single component of a software is being
tested we are not talking about like how
exactly our application is going to
interact with other applications and
it's going to interact with uh it's not
a complete full-fledged application
testing
so
in this case what we are looking forward
is like it this is something in which we
are focusing on how exactly we can only
validate and test out a single component
a single component is what we are
basically talking about over here right
and uh when we say like how exactly
uh we want to perform we want to achieve
the setup here so this is the main
mechanism or this is the main kind of
testing which an individual developer
performs at its own end to see like
whatever the piece of source code he's
writing whether it's working fine as
expected or not
so this is where we are able to see like
uh
the exactly what we are trying to
achieve here and how a full-fledged or a
basic testing validation can be done now
the main objective of this unit testing
is to
pick a unit a very basic small small
unit of the source code to verify it so
that it will be
the moment the developer develops the
code base at that moment of time only
this thing will be validated and will be
fixed on so this is something which we
are looking forward over here to achieve
like how the automation needs to be done
and needs to be achieved over here in
this case
next thing is what exactly is the
marking here now we talked about like j
unit here but next one is like what
exactly we are talking about as in a
particular marking over here now when we
talk about mocking so we are basically
uh trying to understand like what
exactly uh we are performing for what
purpose we are going for the mocking
process here so mocking refers to the
development of objects which are mock or
clone of real objects they are not the
exact uh objects or we can say like
that's not the exact scenario which we
are going to implement but it's kind of
a duplicate or it's kind of a temporary
marks which we are creating so that we
will be able to get it implemented so
mocking is something which is kind of a
reference or a kind of a clone of an
existing or a real object here
so in this technique what happens that
the mock objects are being used instead
of the actual real object so it's not
like we are directly or we are going to
access the exact real objects over here
so we are talking about like uh using or
going through the
specific mock objects over here in this
one so that's where we are putting up
the
main focus right and mock objects
actually give a particular output uh
for each and every input whatever the
inputs you pro you are going to provide
you are going to get any particular
desired output so the marking is going
to process all these inputs give you the
desired output and to understand like
how the implementations and the setups
can be done right so for this kind of
mocking process mocking a framework is
something which is quite popular so uh
marketer is one of the framework which
is available there which uh is desired
for this kind of uh work or this kind of
approach only where we are trying to see
like how we are we want to perform a
mocking implementation over here right
so let's talk about the marketer tool
because that's a primary tool which is
there for the mocking activity and we
have already focused on like marketing
is and process in which we are trying to
uh process uh the mock objects rather
than the real objects so that's kind of
uh verification here so marketo is a
kind of a job-based framework which is
being used for uh doing the unit testing
on the job application so if you have
written the source code in java
programming language then marketer is a
kind of a framework for you
so this is something which is helpful
for validating the development of the um
kind of application source code here so
you will be able to validate it how your
application is going to behave and it's
going to work so when we talk about
market market over here so it basically
gives you a variety of information like
what exactly approach you are looking
forward and what is the end result you
are trying to establish over here so
that's the main focus of the market oh
which we are going to get and it's for
the basic uh approach over here
so java reflection api is basically used
uh internally to generate the mark
objects that's a core component you can
say like the backbone of this whole uh
mocking approach over here mokito is
used to simplify the test development
by marking the external dependencies and
using them in the source code so it's
kind of a
blending in the whole environment there
so that your application is going to get
the desired
environment and uh
being in that environment it can start
processing the inputs and then give the
desired output accordingly so this is
what we are trying to uh
you know implement as such over here to
see like how exactly this mocking can be
done and mokito can really help us in
this approach here
right now what are the different
prerequisites which we require to learn
more
so we basically need two important p
request over here first of all we need
the hands-on experience in java
programming language so java programming
language is very important because
mokito is something which we can write
in the java programming language it uses
the java programming language syntax so
that's a very important thing there to
be considered and second one is the
junit framework implementation so these
two things we basically require for
performing a complete full-fledged
marketer approach or mocking testing
over here so these are the two important
uh components or you can say like the
two core prerequisites which we need to
process before going for the mokito
implementation
right so let's go to see understand like
how mokito framework can be configured
in eclipse because eclipse is the prime
tool for creating the uh development
source code for the java programming
language so we need to see like how we
can configure the emojito framework over
there because that's the one that's a
single id which will be utilized by the
developers there so let's go ahead in
that
in this demo we are going to talk about
like how we can create a simple uh junit
and mokito related uh program over here
so that we can have a basic project
created and we can also have some basic
program created on that part so let me
open the eclipse here now in this one
what i'm going to do is like first of
all i'm going to create a maven project
once my maven project is created then
i'm going to include market to nj unit
related dependencies and after that i'm
going to write a very small source code
up just to see like how exactly our
dependencies are getting dissolved and
my source code which will come up as an
error earlier will come up as unhealthy
over there
so all i have to do is i have to just
right click over here
new and here i need to go for project
like i want to go for a particular maven
project here so i can expand the maven
over here and go for maven project
here it will basically ask me certain
values uh i want to use the default
workspace location so i'll just say next
um then i want to have it uh like i want
to go ahead with this overall process so
these are all projects like what exactly
uh you know archetype you architecture
type you want to go so i can just go for
the default whatever is selected i can
just go with that
and here i will be providing like what
is a group id so i can provide a group
id called com.simplylearn or depending
on your organization you can actually
provide it so here i can provide makito
and the version will be like this and
this is the same way like how the
project will also be created the package
will be created in case of the project
here so then i'll just say finish
and uh on the left hand side i will be
able to see like my uh specific
source code which is available there so
this is something which is uh going to
come up over here so it's actually
trying to
resolve some of the uh particular
options like some of the uh
you know like uh the components like
test executions those are required over
here so i'll just
uh go for this particular reservation
later on
right so i'll just open this palm.xml
file here
and this is the palm xml file right so
it's basically looking forward for
certain changes like this
jar file so this jar file is not
actually available over here so
once i ran the build and you know those
kind of setup can be done then it will
be able to download those particular
dependencies so if you right click on
this one you will be able to see that a
particular maven build option here so i
can just run the maven build or you can
just run the movement clean here
so according to that the maven will be
downloading certain plugins and it's
just trying to do some uh particular
process over here so
on the left hand side the source
main
test
the same package which is available
there the same packages is coming up
there so
app test is available there so here the
test
is being available here i can see like
some couple of junit related test cases
is already being there like i created a
kind of a sample project so in here a
basic java and a basic uh class file or
a test suite is already being available
here so all i have to do is like i have
to just try to see like if i can go
ahead with this uh executions there now
it's using like junit uh 3.8.1 over here
so i can definitely go for a version
which is a higher like around junit four
or five there but let me try to do a
clean build over here may even build
over here so uh to see like if it really
works on there so uh what are the goals
i need to do i need to go for the goals
called clean install so that's a goal
which we need to do here so uh mvn will
automatically be resolved there but
clean install is the goal which i want
to look forward over here so let's see
like what it really happens so it's
going to download some couple of plugins
whatever the plugins i'm trying to
provide here some dependent plugins will
be downloading so all that stuff will be
downloaded this is the first time we are
running there so that's why it may
download some little bit more uh jar
files than expected ones not you must
have seen like these are all jar files
is not like something we are using into
our project but these are kind of for
jar files which is being used by the
plugins by the maven itself so for that
purpose it's actually going to that
particular level but once these are
cached up there next time if you do the
run if you do any kind of burst there
you are not going to see all these
entries so let me rerun the build here
to show you like how clean the output
would be there
so i can just go for clean install again
and say run
and this time the output will be a
little bit less there so in this case as
you can see
if i expand the output
so here first of all it ran like it
performed the clean activity then it
compiled my source code here it also
compiled my test cases here in this one
then my test cases got executed over
here so you can see like it's something
which got xx
executable executable over here so this
is the test which is available i can
click on that and i can see that and
after that uh it went on and prepared
the final artifact here which also means
like it performs both the compilation
and the test cases execution and this is
what we are doing in any kind of
movement project and on top of that i'm
using a j-unit related frameworks so
this is a mechanism where we can have
some dependencies like i can go for
j-unit here i can increase the
dependencies i can try out the pair so
all that stuff i can do here
right and one more dependency which i
can include is of the marketo here so i
can include the marketo related
dependency also over here so that uh we
can see like how exactly the response is
coming up there so uh you can see like
it's uh you know
when i go for the resolution over here
like clean build
clean install so i can just go ahead
with this
so this time it's actually going for the
mokito one so you can see like all the
steps has been executed and we have got
the end result so the build is
successful and i have got the test cases
also so this is the test file where i'm
actually loading up some junit related
uh
executables there so i can just go with
that and
whatever the activity assert we are
using over here so using which we can do
the comparison so this is a way like how
a basic project can be created in maven
and on top of that how we can manage the
dependencies for mokito and for change
unit here right so that was a demo in
which we talked about like how exactly
we can configure mokito into our eclipse
here now let's see like when exactly we
uh require the marketer to be
implemented now in this case
what happens like uh when when exactly
you feel like you need to have a mokito
implementation or how we can go for the
mokito uh implementation all together
here so for example when a component is
to be tested or a single unit needs to
be tested so this unit or component
actually depends on some other component
which is uh kind of uh in in development
process or maybe some other developer
owns that component and you are not
exactly validating that component you
are validating your own component but
since it's actually dependent on other
component or some other
unit of the of the whole application so
that's the reason why you may not be
going you may not be able to perform the
end-to-end testing but yes with the help
of mokito you will be able to get the
mock objects so that you can perform the
uh testing there you don't have to held
up with that other component dependency
you can resolve all these dependencies
like that and you can just proceed
further with your verification and your
implementation so this is the main
benefit which you get when you talk
about the marketer so that you can get
see that a full-fledged understanding
like how exactly these different
components are going to be processed
here
right and uh when there is any kind of
concern like uh if if uh you know like
if you feel like there are some
infrastructure components which is
making the testing impossible so in that
case also we can use the marketer to
mark some infrastructure components so
that we can proceed further with the
validation and the testing here so all
the hindrances and all the problems
which we normally face when we talk
about the implementation all those
things can be really implemented with
the help of mokito here so that's a main
benefit which you get over here in this
one
now let's talk about the next concept so
the next concept which we have is what
exactly is a stub very important concept
here so stub is a kind of object
which holds up a predefined information
a predefined data we cannot do a kind of
a dynamic verification in case of unit
testing because we have to
uh
limit the scope of testing we are
putting up some inputs over here just to
see like how our application is going to
behave
these predefined data will act like a
inputs and
the test cases are going to process
these inputs and give us the desired
output so these outputs we will be then
analyzing to understand that how our
application is going to behave or in
other terms like how application is
reacting to these inputs so that we can
get an end-to-end desired output as such
here
also it can be referred to as an object
that looks like
exactly a carbon copy of a real object
of course it's not a real object it's a
kind of
mock object over here in this one but it
will give you the exact different
details or you can say like things that
output as such over here in this one so
that's a main benefit which we get with
the stuff that it helps us to get a mock
object instead of the real object so
that we can get ahead with the testing
and we can get all our environment for
our test uh executions here
right and stubs actually uh they can
actually return the specific uh output
here like whatever the output you
require so that will be returned over
here whatever the inputs you provide
that is going to be processed by this
one and the desired output will be
provided to you over here in this one
now these stubs are used to reduce the
complexities right so that occur while
uh creating the real object so that's
also the complexity which is going to be
reduced when we talked about the these
specific stubs as such here so whenever
we talk about these tabs we talk about
the implementation so this is where the
complexities get reduced when we talk
about the uh replication or the marking
of the real objects here
right so let's talk about like how we
can see the
stub in real action so that we can get a
better understanding because from there
we will be able to know like what is the
mean importance of stub in the whole
mocking approach here so let's go ahead
with that
in this demo we are going to talk about
like how we can create some pre-request
for testing out a stub here so i'm going
to create a required maven project and a
couple of class files over here to make
a kind of environment so that we can
test it out the stub implementation in
mokito so first what i need to do is
like i need to just go ahead with the
maven project so movement project is
what i need to create a very basic
project i want to create over here uh
you don't have to do much of the changes
like not uh much things you need to talk
about over here
so uh the package direction i can make
it like
uh okay i just want the uh particular
package if uh if you don't want to have
the package and you would want to
directly store the source code in source
meaning java and you want to put the
class directly over there without having
any kind of a particular comment all
that stuff so you can do that also over
here in this case so that will be much
faster so you then you can just go for
the finish here
and you will be able to see like a
project created like a source main java
then uh this particular package name is
there and source uh test java is also
there so here is the test file here is
the main file
i i can go ahead with this one i can
create a file over here uh you can
pretty much do that stuff also so uh or
you can change like this existing one
also
so what i'm going to do is like i'm
going to create a new class file here so
i'm going to say like okay create new
class file and in this one i'm going to
put the particular class name and a
specific content
so uh let's see like how exactly we can
go so we can go for a particular uh
class creations as a chair or we want to
create so one class and one interface we
want to create so that we will be
creating over here so i'm going to
create a interface here
right
so
to
do
surface so that's the interface name
which i'm trying to provide here
and uh
in this one
i'm just pasting the content
so this is already configured here so
i just have to configure like this
right so uh then i'm just going to
resolve
this one so the
java.util.list is also resolved so this
is the to do service.java which is
available there now what i have to do is
like i i'm just trying to create it over
here and i'm just uh trying to create an
another class file over here in this one
so which is like my to do business impl
over here which will be using this
interface
right so i'm going to
create
a particular class file in this one
and
we are going to create it
okay great so in this one again i'm
going to paste this content so
i have to
just sync
this one so this is what so i have to
just rename it a little bit of this one
so
i have to just
rename as in particular
this as over here
great
so now
i'm pretty much done here so whatever
the imports are required
i can actually go it just this delta i
want to remove it
and uh here we go so
we are creating a particular to do
service
uh mechanism over here in this one so
we are also talking about
the uh list here so this list where i
can
go for the auto resolution here so i'm
just going to save it
and then i'm going to see like for to do
here so to do is something which is
coming up as an uh particular
uh
service here so a little bit changes in
this uh
interface also so
i can just you just have to sync it on
the names
so uh whatever name you are following
you are using so that you need to change
over here in this case so here also in
due due service i have got it renamed so
that's where it got successfully
resolved and as far as the error list is
confirmed so i can just import that also
so i'm just done here so if you by
chance change this class name then you
change the java file name also calling
there so that you will be there in
proper sync up over here
so that's uh
something which is available there which
we can use to see like how the
implementation can be done and that's a
basic output which you're getting over
here now this is where we have got all
the required source code available there
when we will be testing out the stub so
at that time we can actually use these
one interface and one class over here so
this class is basically going for the
interface call over here in this one and
that's how it's going on the
implementation
so we'll come back during the testing
during the verification of this stuff at
that moment of time this will act as a
kind of basis for us here so this is a
kind of basic structure that how you
create a basic uh program or a basic
source code over here in this one so
what i'm going to do is like i'm going
to just create these stubs over here in
this one to test it out to validate that
the things there so last time we created
the java source codes here now the stubs
we will be creating over here in this
one
then we are just trying to
create first one is for the to do
service so to do
service
stop so that's the name which i'm going
to use and just finish it off and uh i'm
just going to put the content over here
so just in order to try out the
particular matching over here in this
one so to do stub is what we are trying
to implement so that's what we are going
to see here so i'm just going to remove
this mechanism so i'm able to see like
all the imports is working fine
in this case we are just trying to put
some a dummy information so you can see
like this is the array this is the error
list content which we are trying to
provide over here in this stuff so uh we
are basically trying to understand like
how in the mocking activity we are
trying to mark some particular inputs
here so that my stubs will be able to
pick those up and they will be able to
return those there so that's what we are
trying to do here now as far as this uh
stub is configured this is done so we
have to go for another stop here which
will be there for the to do business
impl so we have to create uh this one
for uh that particular
implementation so we have to put the
content over here in this one to do to
put the two
uh do business impl stuff here right so
i'm going to paste the content here just
to just to match up the things so i have
to uh just put this
content here so i have to just rename
this one
because uh
even if we create some file sometimes we
may have to rename it
so that keeping in mind i can just put
this one here and say okay and uh i'm
just going to remove this component here
and here we go so we have got like uh
these components like this is something
which is available there we have got uh
the implementations which we are trying
to do we have got to do service and to
do service stuff both here but i can
these are the kind of wrong interfaces
so idly my interfaces is com dot
simply learn dot stub
so that's where we have got
the particular to do service over there
and uh similarly here also we have got
the particular ones which is available
so which is also there in the uh
specific com dot simply learn dot stop
dot to do service stub here so this is a
mechanism where we will be able to find
out even if i don't give this import
that's totally fine because i'm already
there in that package so i can just
refer it from there and we also have the
junit related ones which is available
there so we are getting the errors for
the j unit uh components over here in
this case so
we also have the pom.xml file here in
which my junit is being utilized
so uh you know in this one we are
basically trying to use some references
around the j unit here so you can get it
on board on that case
so i can just try to run on the
particular movement build here to see
like if all the dependencies are getting
implemented so that we will be able to
download some required dependencies so
clean install again i'm going to just
refer it over here
i can just uh run the
specific test also like if i feel but
i'm just trying to download some couple
of components over here in this case
so if there is any kind of issues which
you're getting during the execution so
you will be able to see over here for
instance like oj.junit does not exist
over there right so uh since these
packages are not downloaded or not
installed so that's why you're getting
the issues as such over here in this
case
right so these are the uh references
which is available there i can just go
ahead and import some of the
junit related ones in this case
if i feel like i want to run it so i can
run this java file also over here this
file also i can run it over here right
so those are different options which is
available which we can utilize in this
case
so i'm just adding the junit 4 library
so that my uh all references related to
junit should be resolved here and the
moment i picked up that one you can see
like all the errors related to j-unit is
gone now i can run my build here to see
like if it's getting successful so
this time okay so uh it's it's going for
that particular mechanism so i can
change
the specific
version as in 4.0 let's see like
uh it's getting resolved so it should be
able to download that particular
artifact so i just have to find out that
what is the version what is the latest
version we want to provide and according
to that the artifacts will be there and
it will be executed so uh there are some
cases when we are using uh
the default mechanism of creating a
junit or um even project in eclipse
sometimes it actually uses an older
version so it was using 3.8.1 version
which is old version so i'm using 4.0 so
this source code is actually prepared
according to 4.0 and the moment i
started using that the moment i tried on
that one there so you can see like here
it got executed like both the test cases
got executed over here i have got the
response over here in this one like
these two test cases is being provided
over here so test run is two there is no
failure all good and then ultimately it
went on to the jar file preparation here
so this is a way like how the stub is
actually going to uh particular uh you
know it's going to call the particular
specific classes but yes in this case we
are just trying to input some values
some static values which is not the real
objects but it's kind of a mock often a
real object and that's how we are going
to continue with our test cases just to
see like you know some inputs if they
are not there we can still go for the
testing and we can do the verification
here so this is a mechanism like how we
can test out a stub to go to see like to
understand how the overall mocking is
going to happen here
so that was the main uh implementation
on how this stuff can be implemented in
the whole process to see like how
exactly we can go ahead with done now
the next uh demo which we are going to
talk about is like how we can full
fledge implement the complete marketer
code here so that the end-to-end
implementation of the marking of real
objects is what we can get over here in
this one so this will give us the
complete insight about this whole
process
now first we will be creating a specific
uh we are taking up a stock inventory
kind of example over here so we are
going to create a java file over here
which is named as stock.java so i'm just
going to create a class file here called
stock
and in that case we will be providing
the content here so i'm going to create
a stock class which is having certain
methods certain functions stock is the
main function which is available there
now we have to create a particular
interface which is going to uh you which
is going to be used to get this talk
there and then ultimately at last we
will be getting a one test file which
will be testing out this thing the
communication and see like if the
marketer is getting passed or the test
case is getting passed or not so this is
the class file which is available there
get stock id set stock id so basic
getter and setters are being used as
used over here in this case
so now i have to create a particular
interface here
with the name called stock service
and in this case
i have to
call
the
get price over there
so get price is basically configured
over here in this one
right so we are going to just call upon
on that to see like how exactly it goes
out there right
so we will be utilizing this one so this
is the interface which is calling up the
class called stock.java
now once the stock main class in stock
service or stock interface has been
created now we have to create a
particular portfolio class here this
portfolio is a kind of uh interface
which is going to
uh consume this specific stock here so
portfolio uh class is what we are going
to create here so i'm just going to use
it
and
it's using some list operations so i'm
going to just import the java.util also
so that these can be imported so these
are some couple of
activities like under this one we are
also calling up these
stock service interface so that that can
be calling up the stock internally and
this is kind of a business logic which
is happening so portfolio.java is kind
of a business logic business layer where
i'm just trying to call them the main
class there to fetch the details through
an interface and in this one we are
basically doing the all processing like
whatever the activities i'm trying to do
so here i'm doing the processing about
the data here right so this is what we
have uh from the source code perspective
now we will be moving on to the test
cases perspective where we will be
writing a test file to
do the mocking over here and to get the
stocks and try to do some verification
so now i'm going to create a particular
portfolio tester here
which
will be testing this specific
portfolio here so that's what we are
going to do
right
so
it's going to use some of the mokito
related uh jar files here and since we
already have those uh dependencies like
the we already got those added up to our
palm.xml file so and these are also
being shown up as an maven dependency
here so both 4.0 and this market to
dependency is there in the maven
dependencies and that's why we are not
getting any errors for these imports
here
and we are getting some list related
errors so let me import those also and
uh we should be fine by now here
so as you can see like here we are when
we are doing the a verification right so
using this portfolio tester we are
actually inducing some stacks so here
you can see like we are doing some setup
we are calling that stock service over
here so that we will be able to call
upon or we will be able to get the
information and here we are actually
putting up some content so the whole
idea why we are putting up this content
just to uh have the implementation we
are just trying to replicate uh real
objects here uh these are not the actual
real uh
configurations or real information which
we are getting from the
end users but these are the the dummy
informations or the dummy data which we
are trying to provide here and depending
on that we will be able to get like how
it's going on there so we are basically
trying to
call a function called tester.setup
there tester dot setup is what we are
trying to uh call upon over here which
will set up the initial information and
then we are calling the test market
value so my test market value will
basically give me a a pass or fail kind
of uh result set here so that depending
on that i can decide that whether it's
successful or not and this test market
value only here we are putting up some
dummy informations and against these
dummy informations the test cases will
be executed so let's just run it my
build is already success so i don't have
to run it again there so what i need to
do is like i need to go for this
portfolio tester dot java here so that i
will be able to get the results and here
we go we are getting the pass
output over here in this one
right so this is what we are trying to
do just to see like how the
implementation should be done there i
can go for a negative scenario like
where i can just a little bit modify uh
something over here in the output and
i'm just trying to change a little bit
of uh specific uh output so that's what
i'm trying to do here so um i can
definitely go and see like if this is
something going to uh process properly
or is there any kind of problem which we
are getting over here
i can also remove this decimal value
just to see like if uh i'm getting
successful over here or not so i'm just
running the test cases again
and here we go we got the response as in
failure because uh the expected thing is
not coming up like whatever we are
returning so that's where the failed uh
it's going down for the failure i'm
going to roll back my things here and
see like if it's again getting success
or not
so
yes here we go we got the pass success
over here the past status over here in
this one so just like that you can
actually mock the objects you can put
some inputs and according to that the
responses will be coming up there and
you can go ahead with that particular
mechanism so this is the way that how
the things really gets moved on when we
talk about the uh marketer and how we
can mark the real objects and we can
test out our application here so that's
what we do with the market okay so that
was a complete uh marketo code or you
can see like a complete demo over here
like how the overall process really gets
implemented over here in this one
right now what are the different
benefits of mokito let's process that
one by one so
the main benefits of mokito is like
first of all we'll get started with the
very first one is like the no
handwriting so that's a very first
benefit which is coming up over here now
second one is the object creation
third one is the safe refactoring
then we have an exception support uh
benefit which we get over here then we
have got like the annotation support
which is available there and then the
order support so these are some couple
of benefits which we got over here to
completely understand like how exactly
the uh particular mokito can be really
achieved over here in this one right so
this is the real benefits of marketer
here hello and welcome to continuous
integration tutorial using jenkins my
name is chidanand and i am with the
simply learn team today let's get
started with jenkins jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for sun microsystems
way back in early or mid 2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into a
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wide adoption since it
is released under mit license and is
almost free to use
jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing all kinds of
plugins plugins is the heart and soul of
jenkins because using plugins one can
connect jenkins to anything and
everything under the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial i will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing jenkins post which i will go
ahead and install jenkins on a windows
box there are a few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
i will be covering those as well so once
i have jenkins installed and configured
properly i will get into the user
administrative part i create few users
and i will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users i will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and i will
also show you the powerfulness of
jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule i
will also connect jenkins with github
github is our source code where source
code repository where i've got some
repositories put up there so using
jenkins i will connect to github pull up
a repository that is existing on github
onto the jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pull from github
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either a build going bad or
build being good or build being
propagated to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
contains integration servers to be
sending out notifications so i will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure jenkins for sending out emails
i will also get into a scenario where i
will have a web application a maven
based java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and i
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually i will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the master slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a master slave
configuration so i will bring up a slave
i will connect the slave with the master
and i will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally i will let
you know how to use some plugins to back
up your jenkins so jenkins has got a lot
of useful information set up on it in
terms of the build environments in terms
of workspace all this can be very very
easily backed up using a plugin so this
is what i'm going to be covering as a
part of this tutorial jenkins is a web
application that is written in java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install jenkins i have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
jenkins is usually installed on in any
system the topmost one is as a windows
or a linux based services so if at all
you have windows like the way i have and
i'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so i would download a msi installer
that is specific to jenkins and install
this service so whenever installed as a
service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
jenkins and i have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic warp file and as long as
you have jdk installed you can launch
this war file by the command opening up
a command prompt or shell prompt if
italy on linux box specifying java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if i told you you want to
stop using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a ctrl c
and then bring down this prompt and your
jenkins server would be down other older
versions of jenkins were run popularly
using this way in which you already have
a java based web server running up and
running so you kind of drop in this war
file into the root folder or the httpd
root folder of your web server so
jenkins would explode and kind of bring
up your application all user credentials
or user administration is all taken care
of by the apache or the tomcat server or
the web server on which jenkins is
running this was a very older way of
running but still some people use it
because if they don't want to maintain
two servers if they already have a java
web server which it's being nicely
maintained and backed up jenkins can run
attached to it all right so either ways
it doesn't matter however you're going
to bring up your jenkins instance the
way we're going to operate jenkins is
all going to be very very same or
similar one with the subtle changes in
terms of user administration if at all
you're launching it through any other
web server which will take care of the
user administration otherwise all the
commands are all the configuration or
the way in which i'm going to run this
demo it is going to be same across any
of these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running jenkins as i
mentioned earlier jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is written
in java so all that it needs is java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there is always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to set in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the way open source
projects discover themselves is using
this environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so i already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what i would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
home page and just type in or search for
install
jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle home page
you'll have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is
that you can pick up based upon the
operating system on which you're running
so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system so i will not get into the
details of downloading this or
installing it let me show you once i
install this what i've done with regard
to my path so
if you get into this environment
variables
all right so i have just set in a java
home variable
if you see this column program files
java jdk 1.8 this is where my my java is
located c program files
c program files java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what i have been i've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run java
or java c from a command prompt ensure
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere i will see yes there you go c
colon program files java jdk 1.8 pin so
with these two i'll ensure that my java
installation is nice and you know good
enough so to check that to double check
that or to verify that let me just open
up a simple command prompt
and if i type in java iphone version
all right
and java c
iphone version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path and if at all i do this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i am good to go
ahead with my jenkins installation
now that i have my prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies i would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that
long term support is good enough and as
i mentioned there are so many flavors of
jenkins that is available for download
all right so what i want is
yes this is the war file which is a
generic war file that i was talking to
you earlier and this is the windows msi
installer so go ahead and download this
msi installer i already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance
or other installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called jenkins home this is
where jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an msi
installer all your installation gets
into c colon program files 86 and
jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user id with
which you're running your war file the
jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
jenkins or you want jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
i don't need to do any of these things
so i've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation
all right so this is my jenkins msi
installer i would just i don't want to
make any changes into the jenkins
configuration c colon program files is
good for me yeah this is where all my
destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this i don't want to change
this
i would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so i'll have to just copy this
path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station so as a part of the
installation it just asks you to do this
so
if that is not great it'll [ __ ] about it
but this looks good
so it's going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is
a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plugins that is required for
jenkins in order to run properly so
jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in terms of network so
in case your you know your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on openly
or mirrored sites and sometimes some of
them may be down so do not worry in case
some of these plugins kind of fail to
install you'll get an option to kind of
retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 90 95 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins so
after that i get to create this first
admin user again this is one important
point that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it all right so i'm going to create a
very very simple username and password
something that i can remember
i will
that's my name and
an email id is kind of optional but it
doesn't allow me to go ahead in case i
don't so i just given an admin and i got
a password i've got i remember my
password this is my full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys
but if at all you're a java guy you know
how painful it is to write ui in java
you will kind of appreciate you know all
the effort that has gone into the ui
bottom line you are a little hard to you
know wrap your head around it but once
you start using it possibly you'll start
liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as manage jenkins
this can be viewed like a
main menu for all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance
few things to kind of look out for this
is a home directory this is a java home
where all the configurations all the
workspace anything and everything
regarding jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's probably show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can kind
of visualize it like a thread that can
be run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough
in case at any point in time there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
at the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the cpu usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors 2 for my system is kind of
good label for my jenkins i don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your jenkins this is good
for me because i only have a primary
server that is running so i want to use
this node as much as possible quite
pretty each of these options have got
some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn
email notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails
and what i've done here is i've just
configured
the smtp details of my personal email id
in case you are in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email id that
is set up for a jenkins server so you
can specify the smtp server details of
your company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me i have configured my
personal email id which is on my gmail
for sending out notifications so the
smtp server would be
smtp.gmail.com using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id and my password i'm using the smtp
port which is 465 and i'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine i can
just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf so i've done already that
i'm just trying to see if i can send a
test email with the configurations that
i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your uh you
know your gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that i'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so i come back to managing
kens
okay one other thing that i want to kind
of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know
what kind of a code base it's going to
pull in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required
for building the appropriate kind of
code that you're going to pull in from
you know your source code repositories
so just to give you an example in case
your source code is a java source code
and assuming that you know because in
this demo this is my laptop and i've put
in all the configurations jdk everything
on my laptop because i'm a developer i'm
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case i want
jenkins to you know run a java code i
would need to install jdk on it i need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since i already have the jdk
installed and i've already put in the
java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly i don't
need to do it git if at all i want the
jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command
bash or the command prompt for for
running git and connecting to any other
git server so you would need git to be
you know installed on that particular
system and set the path accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system which is your continuous
integration server you will have to come
in here and configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it will crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything
managing let me see what else is
required yes configure global security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these usernames
and kind of stores them
so as of now it jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your jenkins repository rather
jenkins tool
so you would specify your ldap server
details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once i put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff
that's good for me so enough of all
these configurations let me put in a
very very simple job
all right so job new item you know a
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so i'll
just say you know first job this is good
for me i just give a name for my job i
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me i don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not be up i'll give a
description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
jenkins job all right
i don't want to choose any of these
again there are some helps available
here
i don't want to choose any of this i
don't want to connect it to any source
code for now
i don't want any triggers for now i'll
come back to this in a while build the
environment i don't want any build
environment as a part of this build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of complete this
particular job so since i'm on a windows
box i would say execute windows batch
command
all right so what do you want to do i
will let me just echo something echo
uh hello
this is my first jenkins job
and possibly i would want the date and
the timestamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job
all right so once i save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then i need to build this job and you
would see some build history out here
nothing is there as of now because i've
just put in a job i have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a time stamp so if i click on
this you will see a console output if i
go here
okay as simple as that
and where is all the job details that is
getting into
if you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home
so all the job related stuff that is
specific to this particular jenkins
installation is all here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i've created whichever i'm
running would be wrong there will be
individual folders specific to the jobs
that has been put up here all right so
one job one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
i would say second job
i would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
i just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because at the core of jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server
all right so what i'm going to do i will
just keep everything else the same i'm
going to put in the build script pretty
much similar to
second job
that
gets triggered
automatically
every
minute all right let me do that
percentage date
and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what i was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger
so a build can be triggered using
various triggers that is there so we'll
get into this github
triggering or hook or a web hook kind of
a triggering later on but for now what i
want to do i want to ensure that this
job that i'm going to put in would be
automatically triggered on its own let's
say every minute i want this job to be
run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of help
that is available for me so for those of
you who have written cron jobs on linux
boxes you'll find it very very simple
but for others don't panic let me just
put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's
one
two
three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in and jenkins got a little
worried and he's asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah i want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do i check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not i just don't do
anything i'll just wait for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job
in a minutes time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got trigger
if i go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this jog would be
automatically triggered
now that i have
my jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my jenkins
instance i would need a way of
controlling access to my jenkins server
this is wherein i would use a plugin
called role based access plugin and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global rule and a project rule
project specific growth i can have
different roles and i can have users who
have signed up or the users who might
create kind of assign to these roles so
that each of these users fall into some
category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my jenkins
instance and
ensuring that people don't do something
unwarranted all right so first things
first let me go ahead and install a
plugin
for doing that so i get into manage
jenkins and manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there is updates available
installed in advance as of now we don't
have the role based plugin so let me go
to available it will take some time for
it to get refreshed all right now these
are the available plugins these are the
install plugins
all right so let me come back to
available and i would want to search for
my role based access plugin so i would
just search for role and hit enter
okay role based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a role
based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
all right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance so typically many
things would work the same way unless
and until you want to restart jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of a big
installations or big patches on your
jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restart it otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go and restart
your jenkins instance but for now i
don't need that it looks good i've
installed the plugin so where do i see
my plugin i installed the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into
yes
global security
and i would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role-based plug-in so
this is what i would want to
enable because i already have my own
database set up and for the
authorization part in the sense that who
can do what i'm going to install i mean
i've already installed a role based
strategy
plugin and i'm going to enable that
strategy all right i would say save
okay
now i've installed the role based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know i would go ahead
and create some roles and ensure that i
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to manage jenkins
configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role-based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules i'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so i would
create a role called developer typically
the jenkins instance or the ci instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by qa
guys so qr guys would need to provide
some sort of uh you know limited access
to developers so that's why i'm creating
a role called developer
and i'm adding this role at a global
role level so i would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if we hover over it you would see some
sort of a
help on what what are these uh you know
permissions specific to
so what i want is like you know it
sounds a little you know different but i
would want to give very very little
permissions for the developer so from an
administration perspective i would just
want him to have a read
kind of a role credentials again i would
just want to view kind of a rule i don't
want him to create any agents and all
that stuff that looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read few things i would not
give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job
check you know have read only access to
the job run
no i don't want him to give him any any
particular
access which will allow him to run any
jobs view configure
yeah possibly create yeah
delete i don't want read yes definitely
and this is the specific role so what
i'm doing i'm just creating a global
role called developer and i'm giving him
very very limited roles in the sense
that i don't want this developer to be
able to run any agents nor create jobs
or build jobs or cancel jobs or
configure jobs at the max i just want
him to read a job that is already put up
there
okay
so i would save
now i created a role
i still don't have any users that is
there on the system so let me go ahead
and create some user on the system
that's not here house configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
i would call this user as yeah
developer1 sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember
okay his name is developer1
d at
t dot com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that i have configured
so still have not set any rules for this
particular user yet so i would go to
manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign rules
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer1 i would add this particular
user and now this particular user what
kind of a role i want him to have
because this is the global rule that had
created so developer i would assign this
developer 1 to this particular global
row
and i would go ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qr person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights so the rights that
he set out by creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who's
tagged as a part of this developer role
would get the same kind of permissions
and these permissions can be you know
fine grain it can be a project specific
permissions as well but for now i just
demonstrated the high level permission
that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an aws instance or
you want to connect jenkins to a docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if i want to connect jenkins
to bitbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available okay so
bottom line jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install maven and jdk
on your jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or a
microsoft build you would need to have
ms build installed on your on your
jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from github you will need github
specific plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plug-in that is installed on your
jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect jenkins build you can build
a job on jenkins and push it to sonar
cube and get sonar cube to run analysis
on that and get back the results in
jenkins all of these works very well
because of the plugins now with that let
me connect our jenkins instance to
github i already have very very simple
java repository up on my github instance
so let me connect jenkins to this
particular github instance and pull out
a job that is put up there all right so
this is my very very simple uh you know
repository that is there called hello
java
and this is what is there in the repo
there is a hello hello.java application
that is here or a simple class file that
is there it's got just one line of
system dot out so this is already
present on github.com at this place and
this would be the
url for this repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
steepest url so what i would do is i
would connect my jenkins instance to go
to github provide my credentials and
pull out this repository which is on the
cloudhostedgithub.com
and get it to my jenkins instance and
then build this particular java file
i'm keeping the source code very very
simple it's just a java file how do i
build my java file how do i compile my
java file i just say java c and the name
of my
class file which is hello java and how
do i run my java file i would say java
and hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so i
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here it says git job it
will be a freestyle project that's good
for me i would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so i'm going to
put up a source code and git would show
up because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and jenkins connects wonderfully
well to all these particular source
control tools okay so i would copy the
https url from here i would say this is
the url that i'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from
but all right that sounds good but what
is the username and password so i'll
have to specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password i just save this i say add
and then i would say you know use this
credentials to go to github and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me i'm going to grab this
url what am i going to do
this step would pull the source code
from the github
and then what would be there as a part
of my build step
because this repository just has a java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this i would just say
execute windows batch command and i
would say java c
hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it i
would just say java
hello pretty simple two steps and this
would run after the repository contents
are fetched from github
so java c java that sounds good i would
say save this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executes
git on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my repository
and it kind of builds this whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my
workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the github repository all right so
this was the same program that was here
and jenkins on our behalf went over all
the way to github pulled this repository
from there and then you know it brought
it down to my local system on my jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that i've integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what i will do is i
have a maven based web application that
is up there as a repository in my github
so this is the repository that i'm
talking about it's called amv and web
app it's got it's a maven based
repository as you would know maven is a
very very simple java based
build tool that will allow you to run
various targets and it will compile it
will based upon the goals that you
specify it can compile it can run some
tests and you can you can build a war
file and even deploy it into some other
server for now what we're going to use
maven is just for building and creating
a package out of this particular web
application it contains a bunch of
things and what is important is just the
index.jsp it just contains an html file
that is there as a part of this web
application so
from a perspective of requirements now
since i'm going to connect jenkins with
this particular repository git we
already have that set we only need two
other things one is maven because
jenkins will use maven so in order to
use maven jenkins would have to have a
maven installation that is there on the
jenkins box and in this case the jenkins
box is this laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download i'll let you know how to
quickly uh download and install the
tomcat all right so download maven first
the various ways in which you can kind
of download this maven there is zip
files
binary zip files and archive files so
what i've done is i've just already
downloaded maven and if you see i've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven
so as you know maven again is is one
open source build tool so you'll have to
set in a few configurations and set up
the path so mvn hyphen iphone version if
i specify this after i set in my path my
one should work and if at all i echo m2
home which is nothing but the variable
environment variable specific to my
onenote it is already set here
so once you unzip my one just set this
m2home variable to the directory
variable unzip jmi1 also just set the
path to this particular directory slash
bin because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system i just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download apache tomcat server 8.5 is
what i have on my system
so i'm just going to show you where to
download this from
this is where you download tomcat server
and
i already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration i have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080. since we
already have our
jenkins server running on port 8080 we
cannot let tomcat run on the same port
there will be a port clash so what i've
done i have configured tomcat to use a
different port so if i go to this
configuration file here there is a
server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080. i've just
modified it to 8081. so i've changed the
port on which my tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by tomcat so for that i need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my jenkins
instance
so i would go to tomcat users.xml file
here
i've already created
a username called deployer and the
password is deployer and i've added a
role called manager hyphen script
manager hyphen script will allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials i will enable or
i'll empower jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required
let me just start my tomcat server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here and there's a
startup dot startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go tomcat server
is up and running now this is running on
port 8081 so let me just check if that
looks good
so localhost
8081.
okay my tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what i'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
i'm good to use maven as a part of my
jenkins so i will put up a simple job
now
i will say job
mbn
web app i'll call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository
is this guy https url
okay
that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that are
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after i get this since i said this
is a simple maven repository i will have
some maven targets to run
so the simple target first is
let me run maven package this creates a
war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package
so this is all that is required maybe
let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see
if it connects well if there's any
problem with my war file or the war file
gets created properly
okay
wonderful
so it built a war file and if you see it
all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built
now i need to grab this particular war
file and then i would need to deploy it
into tomcat server
again i would need a small plugin to do
this because i need to connect tomcat
with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and
install the plugin for the container
deployment so i would go to manage
plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need i will
install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder
i would see this web application war
file that is already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that i've
created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm gonna just
create a package that's all fine
now
add a post build step
so after the war file is built as a part
of this package directive let me use
this
deployment to container now this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify
the what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that'll
allow you to
from the root folder it'll pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the tomcat server
i will just say mvn web app that's the
name of my thing now i need to specify
what kind of a container that i'm
talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular
server so if you remember i had created
a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential
i would say i would say add a new
credential jenkins credential the
username is deployer
and the password is
deployer
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is find found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path is a main
web use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this localhost
which is there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it okay so that is all that
is required so i would say just save
this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like the deployment went ahead
perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the jenkins instance and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo i'm running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
ip address all that you've got to go and
change is the url of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different ipa that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using jenkins and
maven
distributed build or master slave
configuration in jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of jenkins server up and
running all the time and also i told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the cpu utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you're heavily
reliant on the jenkins server you don't
want your jenkins server to go down so
that's when you kind of start
distributing the load that is there on
the jenkins server so you primer will
have a server which is just a
placeholder or like a master who will
take in all kind of jobs and what he
will do is based upon trigger that has
happened to the job or whichever job
needs to be built he if at all he can
delegate these jobs onto some other
machines or some other slaves you know
that's a wonderful thing to have okay
use case one use case two assuming that
you know if you have a jenkins server
that is running on a windows box or on a
linux one and if at all you have a need
where you need to build based upon
operating systems you have multiple
build configurations to support maybe
you need to build a windows you know
windows based dotnet kind of a projects
where you would need a windows machine
to build this particular project you
also have a requirement where you want
to build linux linux based systems you
also have a mac you you support some
sort of an apps or something that is
built on mac os you would need to build
you know mac based system as well so how
are you going to support all these needs
so that's where in a beautiful concept
of master slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some sort of triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there's a way nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control a lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple runner or
a slave that is a simple jar file that
is run as a low priority thread or a
process within these systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the master slave
configuration so what i'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is i will set
up a simple slave but since i don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what i'll do is i will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so i've got the c drive and d drive my
jenkins is on my c drive so what i do is
i would just use my e drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there i'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my jenkins master and configure
him to you know talk to an agent
so there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what i'm going to choose is something
called as jnlp java network launch
protocol so using this i would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that i need to
ensure that i kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jnlp agent's
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so i'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but java network launch protocol
and you know i'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jlp so for that i need to enable this
guy so i enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so i make him random i make
him you know enabled and i say save this
configuration
all right so now i've configured or has
made a setting for the master
so that the jlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and you know create an agent
so i'll go to managed nodes so if you
see here there's only one master here so
let me provision a new node here so this
is the way you know in which you bring
up a new node you have to configure it
on the server jenkins would put in some
sort of security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular agent so that he can
connect to our jenkins master so i would
say new node i would give a name for my
node i would say windows
node because both of these are windows
only so that's fine i just give an
identifier saying that windows node i
would say this is a permanent agent i'll
say okay
so if you see the name let me just copy
this name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system i'll keep the number of executors
as 1
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since i have both my
my master is running on my c drive c
drive program files 86
or not 86
c column program files
it is indeed 86
all right jenkins so this is where my
master is running so i don't want the c
drive what i'll do is i'll use something
called as a drive i have another drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so i create a
folder here called jenkins node and this
is where i'm going to place my or i'm
going to provision my slave
and i'm going to run him from here so
this is the directory in which i'm going
to provision my slave node so i'm going
to copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or slave so i just copied here the label
you know probably this is fine for me
and usage
how do you want to use this guy
so i would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs i will only build jobs
with label expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them they
will have to specify this particular
label so imagine this way if i have a
bunch of windows system i name it as
windows star
anything that says from windows i can
give a regular expression and say that
anything that matches windows run this
particular task there if i have some mac
machines i name all these mac agents as
a mac star or something like that and i
can delegate all tasks you know saying
that start with whatever starts with mac
this node run the mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there
all right so launch method you know we
will use java web start because we're
going to
we we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good directory i think
nothing else is required availability
yes we'll keep this agent yep online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right i'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if i click on this node i get a bunch
of commands along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there i need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
[Music]
text here in my notepad
not bad plus plus is good for me
okay i copy this whole
but there i also want to download this
alien.jar
i would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this uh sorry
for launching this agent is found this
agent.jar so typically i need to
take this jar file onto the other system
and then
kind of run it from there so
i have this alien.jar i copy this or
whether i cut this i come back to my
folder my jenkins node i paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and i need to use this whole
command ctrl a control c and then launch
this particular agent so let me
bring up a command prompt right here
and then launched it so i'm saying in
the same folder where there is agent.jar
i'm going to launch this a particular
agent java hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp
this is the url of my server in case the
server and client are on different
locations or different ips let us
specify the ipad address all this any
way would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
have connected very well so let me come
back to my
jenkins instance and see you know if you
told me you see earlier this was not
connected now let me refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a jenkins node and then i
copied all the credentials or the
slave.jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of
ran it from there since i don't have
another system i've just got a separate
directory in another folder another
drive and i'm launching the agent from
here as long as this particular agent is
up and running or this command prompt is
up and running the agent would be
connected so once i close this the
connection goes down
all right so successfully you've
launched this particular agent now this
would be the home directory of this
jenkins node or the jenkins slave so any
task that i'm going to delegate to this
particular slave would all be run here
it'll create a workspace right here all
right so good
so let me just
come back and let me kind of put up a
new task here
i will say that you know delegate job is
good i say freestyle project i'm going
to create a very very simple job here
i don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
echo
delegate to the
slave negative 2. i don't like the word
slave delegate it to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am i going to ensure that
this particular job
runs on the agent or on the slave that
have configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we gave a label
right so now i'm going to put in a job
that will only match this particular
label
so i'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
windows node so this job will be
delegated out there so i save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this i just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this
it runs successfully
and where is the workspace
the workspace is right inside our
jenkins node it created a new workspace
delegated job it put in here so my old
order my primary master
job is in sql
program files under jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of master slave configuration or
distributed build and jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up
so one quick way to do that would be or
one dirty way to do that would be just
you know take a complete backup of our
sql colon program files colon jenkins
directory because that's where our whole
jenkins configuration is present but we
don't want to do that let's use some
plugins for taking up a backup so let me
go to manage in cans
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so i would
recommend one of these plugins that i
specifically use
so this is the backup plugin so let me
go ahead and install this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins
stop this plugin is there
so
hang on backup manager so you will see
this option once you install this plugin
so first time i can you know do a setup
i would say back up this particular i'll
give a folder uh this folder is
pertaining to the folder where i want js
to backup some data
and i would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my
you know backup this is good i want it
in verbose mode i don't want to shut on
my jenkins or should i shut it down no
okay one thing that you got to remember
is that whenever a backup happens if
there are too many jobs that is running
on the server
it can kind of slow down your jenkins
instance because it's it's in the
process of copying a few of those things
and if the files are being changed at
that moment it's little bit problematic
for jenkins so typically you back up
your servers only when there is very
less load or typically try to you know
bring it to a shutdown kind of a state
and then take a backup
all right so i'm going to backup all
these things you know i don't want to
exclude anything else i want the history
i want the maven artifacts
possibly i don't want this guy i would
just say save
and then i would say
back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this
recording and get back to you once the
backup is complete so there you go the
backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular
zip file so at any instance if at all i
kind of crash my system for some
instance or say hard disk failure and i
bring up a new instance of jenkins i can
kind of use the backup plugin for
restoring this particular
configurations
so how do i do that i just come back to
my manager cans
come back to
backup manager and i will say restore
her that's an or
jenkins configuration
monitoring as the term says you're
monitoring you're watching you're
logging your production environment so
of course there are a whole bunch of
monitoring tools so they become an
important part of your production
environment and a lot of these
monitoring tools are also i've seen them
also being used especially in your uac
environment
and
you can optionally have them for some
time even in your you know development
environment
no not not developing different
development services are usually not
very
high end configurations but you know
maybe a decent uh development flash
integration
server especially if you have uh
long-running scripts and if you have uh
programs that use a lot of uh servers uh
you know maybe cpu or processing power
so then you can have monitoring tools
when you're writing such scripts and you
know
uh you are
doing the ua unit testing for those
scripts
so that you know to see uh what kind of
server utilization
happens when you run this script you
know if you'll put this in production
will it actually you know slow down your
production server and what kind of
impact that you have on the you know
your rest of your application
or other applications running on that
server
but
this particular chapter is more in
context with production environment
so these uh tools they basically monitor
your server they monitor your switches
of course they monitor your application
then any services that you have deployed
on your
servers
and they generate alerts when something
goes wrong and that's the whole job of
monitoring it's just continuously
watching continuously looking at what is
running what is happening what is going
up what is going down
when is the cpu peaking when is memory
peaking and all that so that you can
you typically send limits for these uh
all these different parameters
and anytime any of these parameters goes
outside of that limit you know even more
than that or less than that
these monitoring tools usually send out
an alert
uh and these alerts could again be sms
alerts the email alerts and there are
there are usually people monitoring
these monitoring tools uh to look
look out for any
issues reported
and they also generate alerts when the
problem has been resolved so it will
work both ways
so nagios
is an open source
monitoring tool and it can
even monitor your network services
there's a little diagram here which
is too small
but here is najib somewhere what i can
read
and
status
these are different devices
[Applause]
i think no no no yeah these are
different devices to which nagios is the
sending the status there's a browser
there's an sms there's an email
and then there's a graph also
and these are different objects
that nigel's is basically monitoring
this is an smtp
so i can read smtp
this is
i don't know tcpip no i don't know some
database server okay this is a database
server and this is an application server
this is which router okay okay i can
read that now so this is the different
kind of objects these are different kind
of servers that nigeria's
monitors
and
these are the different kind of uh
devices or statuses that it can send
so it helps monitor your cpu usage your
disk usage and you know even your system
logs
and it uses
plug-in script that can be written you
know in
any scripting language actually
do not use remote plug-in executors are
basically agents that allow remote
scripts
to be executed as well and
these scripts are usually executed to
monitor
again
your cpu just usa number of uh users
logged in who is logged in who's logged
in at what time logged out at what time
and all uh
so all these monitoring tools work on
the concept of polling
so
polling is more like you know they
so the nrp agent is a program that will
continuously keep polling a machine
for certain parameters that are
configured
in nodules to be monitored so this
program continues to keep pinging the
server bringing the program
uh you know to keep checking for what it
has been asked to check so in case of
logged in users you keep checking uh at
a you know like maybe every 30 seconds
or every one minute
you keep pinging
uh to see how many users have logged in
onto this server and who are the users
who have logged in what time they're
logged in what time they logged out and
things like that
so now just poll agents on remote
machines this is what basically it means
that you have agent programs that can
you know help you
uh
pull
or ping even remote machines
the nigeria's remote data processor is
an agent that allows the you know
flexible data transport and you know it
uses uh http and
xml protocols to do that
and we're talking about the
essentially your databases and uh
data server usages like you know within
if you have an oracle database how many
database instances are there you know
how
your load balancing is set up on that
how
data is moving
between different
database servers within oracle
and how
data is moving within the load balancers
and um there's always a dip uh there's
always a backup with database so that's
why you see me mention trp as soon as i
say the word database
and
if there's a
backup plan you know
uh
how how's the data moving how much time
does did the backup take did it take too
much time
and why you know why did it take so it
helps you do all those kind of
monitoring
the ns client is basically mainly used
to monitor windows machines and
typically when we talk about servers
we end up
talking more about you know unix or
linux servers
of course now with a lot of microsoft
technologies being
robust than they were you know
like sharepoint or
things like that there are windows
servers too but
ten years ago if you
would talk about having a windows server
it was
actually
kind of frowned upon especially for
production
and again you know this helps you
monitor as usual your cpu your this
usage and
it pulls the plugin and this particular
agent listens to this particular port
always so that's a reserved port
and usually your system administrators
or server admin administrators know all
these things
so a quick overview uh on uh
genius so it's a tv architecture
basically for monitoring system
so it has an instrumentation layer which
you know has all your software agents
that are called netpro sits on all your
monitoring system nodes
uh monitoring system knows basically you
know what all
objects you want
to monitor
you know what all different kind of
objects different kind of servers you
want to monitor then it has an analysis
and consolidation layer you know which
basically
deploys all these networks this agent
programs that you have
set on your nodes
and
they will basically go and
start monitoring what you want them to
monitor by processing the data they're
receiving from servers from applications
from databases from
user activity etc
and of course then it has a
visualization
layer
that basically is a control that lets
you view the status of environment and
you know any current alerts if this
these kind of monitoring tools usually
have a very good ui i mean they will do
a whole bunch of things in the
background but when you look at the user
interfaces
they're pretty crisp you know there's
like a way a place for you to see
uh things that need your immediate
attention they'll use a lot of color
coding you know to indicate something is
amber uh
green red etc etc
so this thing also has a control where
you can see the status of different
environments you know where your
networks are deployed and what's that
status everything is fine everything's
green if there's a spike uh you know
when was the spike what happened did
anything crash
uh how did it stabilize after that
and of course you know any alerts that
are being thrown on any of these nodes
this is uh an overview of the
architecture so these are basically your
different controls your visualization
there
you can have multiple controls
doing that you can even have the phone
or a tablet
to
view that and then this is your analysis
and consolidation layer you know which
has your
different rules uh what i'm what am i
monitoring you know
capturing data for monitoring computing
that and also
they have knowledge base based on what
limits your set what you wanted to
monitor which
which off limits uh
you wanted to monitor and it you know
does the appropriate database logging
and sends out the appropriate
notifications and then these are your
networks different nodes where your
networks are running which are basically
doing the monitoring for like one two
three here see here these boxes
represent your server
see very clean um
easy to understand hello everyone
welcome to simply learn's youtube
channel in this full session we will
learn about puppet chef and ansible from
scratch
right from their installation to a
full-fledged use case we will begin the
session with the comparison between chef
puppet ansible and soul stack
followed by that we will learn what is
chef then we will learn the installation
of chef in our local system once the
fundamentals are done then we will start
with a complete tutorial where you can
learn chef with us with the perfect
hands-on experience
next in the same way we will get started
with puppet and lastly we will have
ansible in the stack and finally we will
wind up the session with the most
frequently asked interview questions to
make sure that you're on the safer side
during your interviews so i hope i made
myself clear with the agenda but before
we begin make sure that you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
don't forget to hit that bell icon to
never miss an update from simply run
so without further ado let's get started
hello this is matthew with simply learn
and today we're going to go through a
real tough battle we're going to decide
which is better for your operations
environment is it chef puppet antipal or
salt stank all four are gonna go head to
head so let's go through the scenario of
why you'd want to use these tools so
let's meet tim he's our system
administrator and tim is a happy camper
putting and working on all of the
systems in his network but what happens
if a system fails if there's a fire a
server goes down well tim knows exactly
what to do he can fix that fire really
easily the problems become really
difficult for tim however if multiple
servers start failing particularly when
you have large and expanding networks so
this is why tim really needs to have a
configuration management tool and we
need to now decide what would be the
best tool for him because configuration
management tools can help make tim look
like a superstar all he has to do is
configure the right codes that allows
him to push out the instructions on how
to set up each of the servers quickly
effectively and at scale all right let's
go through the tools and see which ones
we can use the tools that we're going to
go through are chef puppet and support
and salt stacks and we have videos on
most of these software and services that
you can go and view to get an overview
or a deep dive in how those products
work so let's go and get to know our
contestants so our first contestant is
chef and chef is a tool that allows you
to configure very large environments it
allows you to scale very effectively
across the entire ecosystem and
infrastructure chev is by default an
open source code and one of the things
that you find is a consistent metaphor
for the tools that we recommend on
simplylearn is to use open source code
the code itself is actually written in
language of ruby and erlang and it's
really designed for heterogeneous
infrastructures that are looking for a
mature solution the way that chef works
is that you write recipes that are
compiled into cookbooks and those
cookbooks are the definition of how you
would set up a node and a node is a
selection of servers that you have
configured in a specific way so for
instance you may have apache linux
servers running or you may have a my
server running or you may have a python
server running and chef is able to
communicate back and forth between the
nodes to understand what nodes are being
impacted and need to have instructions
sent out to them to correct that impact
you can also
send instructions from the server to the
nodes to make a significant update or a
minor update so there's great
communication going back and forth if we
look at the pros and cons the pros for
chef is that there is a significant
following for chef and that has resulted
in a very large collection of recipes
that allow you to be able to quickly
stand up environments there's no need
for you to have to learn complex recipes
the first thing you should do is go out
and find the recipes that are available
it integrates with git really well and
provides for really good strong version
control some of the consoles are really
around the learning speed it takes to go
from beginner user with chef to being an
expert there is a considerable amount of
learning that has to take place and it's
compounded by having to learn ruby as
the programming language and the main
server itself doesn't really have a
whole lot of control it's really
dependent on the communication
throughout the whole network all right
let's look at our second contender
puppet and puppet is actually in many
ways very similar to chef there are some
differences but again puppet is designed
to be able to support very large
heterogeneous organization it is also
built with ruby and uses dsl for writing
manifests so there are some strong
similarities here to chef as with a chef
there is a master slave infrastructure
with puppet and you have a master server
that has the manifests that you put
together in a single catalog and those
catalogs are then pushed out to the
clients of an ssl connection some of the
pros with uh puppet is that as with chef
there is a really strong community
around puppies and there's just a great
amount of information and support that
you can get right out of the gate it is
a very well developed reporting
mechanism that makes it easier for you
as an administrator to be able to
understand your infrastructure one of
the cons is that you have to really be
good at learning ruby again as with chef
you know the more advanced tasks really
need to have those ruby skills and as
with chef the server also doesn't have
much control so let's look at our third
contender here ansible and so ansible is
slightly different it is the way the
ansible works is that it actually just
pushes out the instructions to the
server environment there isn't a client
server or master slave environment where
ansible would be communicating backwards
and forwards with its infrastructure it
is merely going to push that
instructions out the good news is that
the instructions are written in yaml and
yowell stands for yaml a markup language
yaml is actually pretty easy to learn if
you know xml and xml is pretty easy if
you know xml you're going to get yammo
really well ansible does work very well
on environments where the focus is
getting servers up and running really
fast it's very very responsive and can
allow you to move quickly to get your
infrastructure up quick very fast and
we're talking seconds and minutes here
really really quick so again the way
that ansible works is that you put
together a playbook and an inventory or
you have a playbook so the way that
ansible works is that you have a
playbook in the playbook it then goes
against the inventory of servers and
will push out the instructions for that
playbook to those servers so some of the
pros that we have for ansible we don't
need to have an agent installed on the
remote nodes and servers it makes it
easier for the configuration yaml is
really easy to learn you can get up to
speed and get very proficient with the
ammo quickly the actual performance once
you actually have your infrastructure up
and running is less than other tools
that we have on our list now i do have
to add a proviso this is a relative less
it's still very fast it's going to be a
lot faster than individuals manually
standing up servers but it's just not as
fast as some of the other tools that we
have on this list and yaml itself as a
language while it's easy to learn it's
not as powerful as ruby ruby will allow
you to do things that at an advanced
level that you can't do easily with the
ammo so let's look at our final
contender here salt stack so sort stack
is a cli based tool it means that you
will have to get your command line tools
out or your terminal window out so you
can actually manage the entire
environment via a salt sac the
instructions themselves are based on
python but you can actually write them
in yammer or dsl which is really
convenient and as a product it's really
designed for environments that want to
scale quickly and be very resilient now
the way that salt snap works is that you
have a master environment that pushes
out the instructions to what they call
grains which is your network and so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons that we have here with saltstag so
sourcetech is very easy to use once it's
up and running it has a really good
reporting mechanism that makes your job
as an operator in your devops
environment much much easier the actual
setup though is a little bit tougher
than some of the other tools and and
it's getting easier with the newer
releases but it's just a little bit
tougher and related to that is that
saltstack is fairly late in the game
when it comes to actually having a
graphical user interface for being able
to create and manage your environment
other tools such as ansible have
actually had a ui environment for quite
some time all right so we've gone
through all four tools let's see how
they all stack up next to each other so
let the race begin let's start with the
first stage architecture so the
architecture for most of our
environments is a server client
environment so for chef puppet and salt
snack so very similar architecture there
the one exception is ansible which is a
client only solution so you're pushing
out the instructions from a server and
pushing them out into your network and
there isn't a client environment that
there isn't a two-way communication back
to that main client for what's actually
happening in your network so let's talk
about the next stage ease of setup so we
look at the four tools there is one tool
that really stands out for ease of setup
and that is ansible it is going to be
the easiest tool for you to set up and
if you're new to having these types of
tools in your environment you may want
to start with ansible just to try out
and see how easy it is to create
automated configuration before looking
at other tools now and so with that said
chef puppet and source tech aren't that
hard to set up either and you'll find
there's actually some great instructions
on how to do that setup in the online
community let's talk about the languages
that you can use in your configuration
so we have two different types of
language with both chef and ansible
being procedural in that they actually
specify at how you actually supposed to
do the task in your instructions with
puppet and sort stack it's decorative
where you specify only what to do in the
instructions let's talk about
scalability which tools scale the most
effectively and as you can imagine all
of these tools are designed for
scalability that is the driver for these
kind of tools you want them to be able
to scale to massive organizations what
do the management tools look like for
our four contenders so again we have a
two-way split with ansible and sort
stack the management tools are really
easy to use you're going to love using
them they're just fantastic to use with
puppet and chef the management tools are
much harder to learn and they do require
that you learn some either the puppet
dsl or the ruby dsl to be able to be a
true master in that environment but what
does interoperability look like again as
you'd imagine with the similar to
scalability interoperability with these
products is very high in all four cases
now let's talk about cloud availability
this is increasingly becoming more
important for organizations as they move
rapidly onto cloud services well both
ansible and softstack have a big fail
here neither of them are available in
the most popular cloud environments and
puppet and chef are actually available
in both amazon and azure now we've
actually just haven't had a chance to
update our chef link here but chef is
now available on azure as well as amazon
so what does communication look like
with all of our four tools so the
communication is slightly different with
them chef has its own knife tool and
whereas puppet uses ssl to secure
sockets layer and to ansible and
saltstack use secure socket hashing and
ssh as their communication tool bottom
line all four tools are very secure in
their communication so who wins well
here's the reality all four tools are
very good and it's really dependent on
your capabilities and the type of
environment that you're looking to
manage that will determine which of
these four tools you should use the
tools themselves are open source so go
out and experiment with them there's a
lot of videos our team has done a ton of
videos on these tools and so feel free
to find out other tools that we have
then covered so you can learn very
quickly how to use them but consider the
requirements that you have and consider
the capabilities of your team if you
have ruby developers or you have someone
on your team that knows ruby your
ability to choose a broader set of tools
becomes much more interesting if however
you're new to coding then you may want
to consider yaml-based tools again the
final answer is going to be up to you
and we'll be really interested on what
your decision is please post in the
comments below which tool you have
decided to go with and what are the
challenges that you're coming up with
because we'll help answer those
challenges for you today we're looking
at how we can use chef to improve the
way that you administer hardware within
your devops environment there's going to
be six things that we're going to step
through the first is really looking at
what is the world that many of you
already work in today how do you
administer your networks and your
systems today then we're going to look
at how chef can be the tool that really
helps improve the efficiencies of
creating a consistent operations
environment we're going to look at the
tools and the components and the
architecture that takes to construct
chef and then finally we're going to
take a use case of one of the many
companies that is using chef today to
improve the efficiency of their
operations environment so let's take a
step back at what life was like before
chef this may well be the life that
you're experiencing right now so as a
system administrator typically the way
that you work is that you are
responsible for the uptime of all of the
systems within your network and you may
have many many systems that you are
responsible for now if one system goes
down that's not a problem because as a
system administrator you can get
notifications and you can jump right on
to the problem and solve it when things
start getting really difficult however
is when you have multiple systems and
you are not able as a single person to
get to all those systems and solve them
as quickly as possible the problem that
you start having is that your
environments are not in sync if only
this could all be automated well this is
where chef comes to the rescue for you
so let me take some time and introduce
you to the concepts behind chef and why
it's a tool that you would probably want
to be using in your environment so what
actually is chef so chef is a way in
which you can use code to fix your
physical hardware environment and so
what does that look like well the way
that we write out scripts in chef is
that you can actually code your entire
environment so you don't have to
actually be managing your environment on
a hardware by hardware basis but
actually use scripts called recipes that
will actually manage the environment for
you so chef will actually ensure that
every system is automatically set to the
right states that meet the requirements
you have defined in your code so you
don't have any issues where hardware and
starts to fail because it references the
code to reset the state within that
environment and that makes you a happy
system administrator so let's go through
the mechanics of how this actually works
with chef so chef is ultimately an
automation tool that converts
infrastructure to code and you'll often
hear the term infrastructure as code or
iac and this really starts as a output
of the work that chef has done because
you take the policies that you as an
organization have created and you
convert that into a scripted language
that can then be implemented
automatically this enables chef to be
able to manage multiple systems very
very easily and considering how broad
and deep our systems become it's very
easy to see how this can help you as a
system administrator the code is then
tested continuously and deployed by chef
so that you're able to guarantee that
your standards and appropriate states
for your hardware and operating
environment are always maintained so
let's step through the different
components that are available in chef so
the first one is actually creating the
actual recipes for chef so you actually
work on these on a workstation and
you'll write out your code which is
referred to as a recipe and that recipe
will be written using a language called
ruby good thing for you is that there
are a lot of examples of ruby's recipes
that have been created by the open
source community a lot of examples knife
is the command tool that you use that
communicates between the recipes and the
server so your recipe is the instruction
and knife is the tool that makes that
instruction work and sets the
appropriate state on the server
environment when you create more than
one recipe you start creating a
collection those collections are
referred to as cookbooks and you may
take an environment such as a large
network where you have multiple nodes
potentially hundreds of servers that
have to all have a consistent and equal
state environment and you would put that
cookbook and use that cookbook to ensure
with chef that the state of each of
those nodes is consistent and then ohi
fetches the current state of your nodes
and then the chef client configures the
nodes as defined within your cookbook so
let's step through the architecture and
working environment of chef so for an
administrator a systems administrator
you only have to now work from your
workstation and from that workstation
you can then configure all the nodes of
your environment you can use
different recipes that you create and
those recipes can be compiled into a
cookbook that can be then applied to a
node the thing that's of value is that
as you change the environment as you
move and mature as an organization and
your nodes need to mature consistently
and quickly with your organization all
you have to do is roll out a different
recipe to your notes and then the nodes
will use the tools within chef to make
the updates so you can create a second
recipe or even a third recipe to be
deployed out to your server environment
knife is going to be the tool that does
the hard work of doing the updates on
the server with the server you have your
collection of recipes in a single
cookbook however understanding the state
of the individual nodes is important to
ensure that the information is broadcast
from the server with the instructions on
how to set up the network within those
nodes in this instance we use ohi and oh
hi will fetch the state of the nodes and
send that back to the server and get the
information from the cookbook using the
chef client
in your chef node network there is the
potential at times that maybe one of
your node fails if there are two failed
nodes then a request is sent back to the
server and information on the latest
node structure that is identified and
defined in the cookbook will be sent to
the failed nodes if that fails to reset
the nodes then the workstation is
notified and you as the administrator
will receive a notification to manually
reset those nodes it should be noted
that this is a very rare occasion within
the chef network set up so let's step
through a use case in this instance
we're going to look at herpolium and how
they used chev so
polam is a bank and it's the largest
bank in israel and they have a mixture
of linux and windows servers that they
have to maintain and as you can imagine
this requires a lot of constant
configuration and work and this has led
to issues in the past so the challenge
that the team polium faced was creating
and hardening software that ran the
major tasks and was repeatable on those
servers that it didn't matter who the
people were forming the jobs that there
was consistency in the work that was
being done and addressed the problem
that the servers including the hardware
on the servers was not consistent
throughout the organization chef
addresses those specific problems and
became the go-to product for herpolium
they were able to write the recipes and
the cookbooks that could be deployed out
to the network effectively and it didn't
matter what the system was the recipes
reflected the standards that the system
administration team put together and
they were able to ensure and test each
script and use standard testing tools
for those scripts it didn't matter what
kind of environment that apollo had if
certain ports need to be closed or if a
firewall needs to be uh installed or
modified or if custom strong passwords
had to be created all of this could be
done using the recipes that chef offers
and once those recipes had been
finalized they could be packaged into a
common cookbook that could then be
deployed to the entire network ensuring
a consistency in results for the company
and also it didn't matter whether the
cookbooks were being deployed to linux
or windows machine because the scripts
were being put together in the recipes
and were written in ruby you could
actually go through and update and
modify those scripts depending on the
environment so if you needed to make a
modification for linux you could make
those modifications so they were
consistent across all the linux servers
or all the windows servers and this
really drove in the ability to harden
and secure the environment in the entire
network within a matter of minutes using
chef versus the days and weeks that it
previously took so we take a before and
after scenario using a chef before chef
tasks were repeated multiple times and
it was just hard to keep track of all
the people doing the work and the
reality is because so many people were
touching all the different systems
specific standards that the banks had
established was simply not being met
after chef all of the tasks could be
scripted using ruby and using the recipe
and cookbook model that chef has created
the chef tool was able to deploy out to
the entire network specific cookbooks
that provided a consistent experience
and consistent setup and operation
environment for all the hardware the end
result is that the system administration
team could guarantee that the standards
of the bank were being met consistently
so just the takeaways that we have here
of chef so life before chef is
complicated if one server goes down you
can probably get it back up and running
but if you are working in a modern
system administration environment you
have many systems and if multiple
systems start going down or having
failure points it is difficult to
identify where those failure points are
and how to solve them chef resolves this
issue and it does so by turning the
environment that you're managing with
hardware and software into code and once
you have it written as code you're able
to then test that code chef itself is
made up of a number of key components as
a system administrator you work on your
desktop at your workstation and you
create recipes those recipes are then
bundled together into a cookbook and
that cookbook communicates with the
server the main chef server and the node
of servers within your environment and
knife is the tool that does that
communication ohai and the chef client
on the various node servers will
communicate back to the chef server what
the standards and the environment are so
that they can provide a two-way
communication to validate that the
system has been set up and is being
maintained to the same standards as
defined by the individual recipes as an
architect and working in this chef
environment it makes it much easier for
you to be able to control the entire
system administration instead of having
many people having to work on all the
servers you can now have one person
controlling hundreds of servers
simultaneously and our poem have been
able to prove conclusively that chef is
the tool that can help improve the
consistent experience of working with
hardware a very warm welcome to all our
viewers this is anjali from simply learn
and today we'll be looking at the
installation for the tool chef as you
probably already know chef is a
configuration management tool so that
basically means that chef is a tool
which can automate the entire process of
configuring multiple systems it also
comes with a variety of other
functionalities which you can check out
in our video on what a chef and the chef
tutorial so before we move on to the
installation process let me just explain
to you in brief the architecture of
share so chef has three components
there's the workstation which is where
the system admin sits and he or she
writes the configuration files here your
second system is the server the server
is where all these configuration files
are stored and finally you have the
client or the node systems so these are
the systems that require the
configuration you can have any number of
clients but for a demo to keep it simple
we'll just have one client now i'm using
my oracle vm virtualbox manager as you
can see here i'll have two machines the
master and the node both of these are
centos 7 machines as of the server we'll
be using this as a service on the cloud
so let's begin let's have a look at our
master system first this is my master
system the terminals open over here and
the terminal color here it's black
background with green text
and this is my note system so the
terminal here has a black background
with white text so you can differentiate
between the both so we start at our
master system the first thing we need to
do is we need to download the chef dk so
you can write w get which is the command
for downloading and then go to your
browser and just type chef dk here
the first link
so here you have different versions of
chef dk depending on the operating
system that you're using you need to
select the appropriate one i'm using the
red hat enterprise version and that's
number seven so i'm using centos 7 so
this is my link for downloading chef dk
just copy this link and go back to your
terminal
and paste it here
so your chef dk is being downloaded this
will take a while right after we
download the chef dk our next step is to
install it on our system
so chef dk is downloaded now let's
install it
so guys this is the version of chef dk
that you have downloaded so make sure
this is exactly what you type down here
to
so great our chef dk is installed so
basically our installation for the
workstation is done right now but just
so you understand how the flow is we'll
also write a sample recipe on our
workstation so before we do that let's
first create a folder
my folder name chef repo basically the
chef repository
and let's move into this folder
okay so we're in next what we need to do
is as i mentioned earlier all your
recipes will be within a cookbook so
let's create a folder which will hold
all our cookbooks
and let's move into this too
okay so our next stage is to create the
actual cookbook within which we'll have
our recipe so the command for creating
the cookbook is chef generate
cookbook
sample because so samples the name of my
cookbook so guys please notice here cook
books is the directory that i created
which will hold all our cookbooks and
here cookbook is the keyword so sample
is that one cookbook that we are
creating under our folder cookbooks
and our cookbook's been created great so
that's done moving into our cookbook
okay so when our cookbook sample was
created automatically there's this
hierarchical structure associated with
it so let's have a look at this
hierarchical structure to understand
what our cookbook sample exactly is
before we move on so the command for
looking at a hierarchical structure is
tree so as you see here within our
cookbook we have a folder recipes and
under this this the default.rb recipe
this is where we'll be creating our
recipe so we'll just alter the content
of default.rb so let's move on to
finally writing our recipes so we'll
move into this recipes folder first
so now we'll open our sp default.rb in g
edit
so the recipe for this particular demo
is to install the httpd package on our
client node that is basically your
apache server and we'll also be hosting
a very simple web page so let's begin
so the recipes in chef is written in
ruby
so i'll explain you the recipe in a
while
okay so the first line is where you
install httpd the second line for
service is where you start or enable the
http service on the client node that's
our first task the second part where we
need to create our web page
so this is the part where your web page
will be stored
if you have written any html file
previously you know that this is
probably like a default path where our
web pages are created
yep that's it so this is the content
that will be displayed on your web page
if everything works right and i'm pretty
sure it will so now we can save our
recipe and that's done close your g-era
so now that we have created the recipe
all our work at the workstation is
completed the next thing we do is we
move on to the server so as i mentioned
earlier we'll be using the server as a
service on the cloud
so go to your browser and here just type
manage dot chef dot io
so this is the home page of your chef
server
click here to get started we need to
first create an account for using the
chef server it's completely free we just
need to give our email id and a few
other details it's in fact a lot like
creating an account on facebook or
instagram
fill in all the details check the terms
of service box
so the next thing you need to do is go
back to your inbox and verify your email
id so i have my inbox opened here on my
windows machine so this is my inbox you
would have received a mail from chef
software just click on this link to
verify it and create your password
and that's done so let's continue this
on our workstation machine
so type in your username and password
so the first time you log into your chef
server you'll have this pop-up appear
where you need to create a new
organization so create your organization
so this organization is basically the
name that will be associated with the
collection of the client machines first
thing you do go to your administration
tab and download the starter kit so guys
when you're doing this part make sure
that you're on your workstation that is
your opening your shep server on the
workstation because you need this folder
to be installed here
you save the file so this gets
downloaded so the chef starter kit is
the key to connecting your workstation
with the server and the server with the
node so basically it has a tool called
knife which we'll come across later in
our demo this knife is what takes care
of all the communication and the
transferring of cookbooks between the
three machines in our case the two
machines the workstation and the node
and the one server so let's go back to
our root directory
so our chef starter zip file is within
our downloads folder what we do first is
we'll move the sip folder into our
cookbooks folder and then we'll unzip it
there because our cookbooks folder is
the one that contains the recipe and
that is where we require knife tool
command to be present so we can send
this recipes over to the server
so we'll just check the contents of our
cookbooks right now to ensure that our
chef starter.zip file is within the
cookbooks
yep so it's here so next thing we do is
we need to unzip this folder
great so that's unzipped
and this means that our workstation and
our server are now linked so we just
need to use the knife command tool to
transfer or to upload our recipes which
we created on the workstation onto the
server so before we execute this command
we need to move into our cookbooks
directory as you know that is where we
unzipped our chef starter kit so that is
where our knife command is present to
and now let's execute the knife command
so it's knife
cookbook
upload and sample so as you probably
recall sample is the name of the
cookbook that we created and within
sample we created our rsp which is
default.rb so we're uploading the entire
cookbook onto the server execute the
command
great so our cookbooks uploaded now
let's check this on our server so move
to your browser where you opened your
chef server and go to policy so here you
go this is the cookbook we uploaded
sample and it's the first time we
uploaded it so the version
0.1.0 the first version now what you
would notice is if you go to the notes
tab there are no notes present so if you
have no nodes you basically have no
machine to execute your cookbooks and
the nodes are not seen right now because
we have not configured them yet so
that's the next thing we need to do all
this so far was done on your master
machine now we'll move on to the node
machine
so before moving on let's just check the
ip of our node machine
so that's our ip note this down
somewhere and now we move back to our
workstation
as we already saw that we uploaded a
sample workbook next thing we need to
make sure that our server and node are
able to communicate with each other so
again we use the knife tool for this
tool
the command here is knife bootstrap and
enter the ip address of your node which
we just checked
we'll be logging in there so we'll be
using the node as the root user
and then we also need to specify our
root password for the node
and we give a name to this node so this
is the name by which we'll be
identifying our node at the server
so as you have probably noticed here we
are using the term ssh which is a secure
shell so it basically provides a channel
of secure communication between two
machines in an unsafe environment
okay so it's done so if your command has
executed right which in our case as we
can see has our chef's server and our
chef node must be able to communicate
with each other so if this is so we
should be able to send the cookbook that
we previously uploaded from our
workstation onto the server now from our
server to our node so to do that before
we move on to the node machine we need
to go back to our chef's server let's
refresh this page and as you see here
previously under the notes tab we did
not have any node mentioned now we do
chef node which is the node we wanted to
identify our node by which is a centos
platform and that's our ip so it's
active for two hours that's the uptime
last check-in the last time we checked
into our node was a minute back and yeah
that's pretty much it so now we'll
create a run list and we'll add our
sample to this run list
so just click on your node and you'll
see the small arrow here in the end
click on that
edit run list and under available
recipes we have a cookbook sample
present so drag and drop this to the
current run list and accept it okay so
now that we updated our run list our
recipe is sent to our node what we next
need to do is that we need to execute
this at our node so now we'll move on to
our node machine
chef client is the command to execute
your
so while this recipe is executing you
can see what exactly is happening our
recipe was to install http package first
which is your apache server so the first
line that's done and it's up to date the
second line it's enabled third line the
service is started and the fourth line
is where your contents created for the
web page at this very location so by the
look of this everything should work fine
so how do we check this we can just go
to our browser and the search bar just
type localhost and there you go so our
httpd package which is the patchy server
is installed and our sample web page is
also hosted if you look at the devops
approach or the devops life cycle you
will see that chef falls under
operations and deployment so before we
begin let's have a brief look at all
that you'll learn today first we'll get
to know why should we your chef and what
exactly is the chef two of the most
common terms used with chef
configuration management and
infrastructure as code we'll have a
brief look at these we'll also have a
look at the components of chef and the
chef architecture quickly go through the
various flavors of chef and finally
we'll wrap it up with the demo a demo on
the installation of apache on our notes
so let's begin guys why should we use
chef well consider a large company now
this company caters to a large number of
clients and provides a number of
services or solutions of course to get
all of this done they need a huge number
of servers and a huge number of systems
basically they will have a huge
infrastructure now this infrastructure
needs to be continuously configured and
maintained in fact when you're dealing
with an infrastructure that size there's
a good chance systems may be failing and
in the long run as your company expands
new systems may even get added so what
do you do well you could say the company
has the best system administrator out
there but all by himself could he
possibly take care of an infrastructure
that size no he can't and that's where
chef comes in because chef automates
this entire process
so what does chef provide chef provides
continuous deployment so when you look
at the market space today you see how
products and their updates are coming
out in a matter of days so it's very
important that a company is able to
deploy the product the minute it's ready
so that once it's out it's not already
obsolete chef also provides increased
system robustness as we saw chef can
automate the infrastructure but in spite
of this automation there's a good
possibility that errors do creep in chef
can detect all these bugs and remove
them before deploying them into the real
environment not only this chef also
adapts to the cloud we all know how
today the services tools solutions
everything is revolving around the cloud
so chef does really play along by making
itself easily integratable with the
cloud platform so now that you know why
to use chef let's look at what exactly
is chef chef is an open source tool
developed by ops code
of course there are paid versions of
chef such as chef enterprise but other
than that most of it is freely
accessible chef is written in ruby and
airline if you would have gone through
any previous material on chef i'm sure
you would have come across ruby being
related to chef but not erlang so this
is why because ruby and erlang are both
used to bill chef but when it comes to
actually writing the codes in chef it's
just ruby and these are the codes that's
deployed onto your multiple servers and
does the automatic configuration and
maintenance and this is why chef is a
configuration management tool so i've
used this term configuration management
a couple of times what exactly does this
mean let's start with the definition of
configuration management configuration
management is a collection of
engineering practices that provides a
systematic way to manage entities for
efficient deployment so let's break this
down configuration management basically
is a collection of practices and what
are these practices for these practices
are for managing your entities the
entities which are required for
efficient deployment so what are these
entities that you need for efficient
deployment they are code infrastructure
and people code is basically the code
the system administrators write for
configuring your various systems
infrastructure is the collection of your
systems and your servers and then
finally you have the teams that take
care of this infrastructure so codes
need to be updated whenever your
infrastructure needs a new configuration
or some sort of updation in the
operating system or the software
versions your code needs to be updated
at first and as the requirements of the
company change the infrastructure's
configuration needs to change and
finally of course the people need
coordination so if you have a team of
system administrators and say person a
makes some change to the code person b c
d and so on need to be well aware when
the change is made as to why it was made
what was the change made and where
exactly this change was made so there
are two types of configuration
management on our left we have the push
configuration here the server that holds
the files with instructions to configure
your notes pushes these files onto the
node so the complete control lies with
the server on your right side we have
the pull configuration in case of pull
configuration the nodes pole against the
server to first check if there's any
change in the configurations required if
there is the nodes themselves pull these
configuration files shelf follows pull
configuration and how it does this we'll
see further in our video another
important term often used with chef
infrastructure as code so let's
understand what this term infrastructure
as code means through this small story
so here's tim tim's a system
administrator at a large company now he
receives a task he has to set up a
server and he has to install 20 software
applications over it so he begins he
sets up the server but then it hits him
it would take him the entire night to
install 20 software applications
wouldn't things have been much simpler
if he just had a code to do so well of
course codes do make things much simpler
codes have a number of advantages
they're easily modifiable so if today
tim is told we need
mysql installed on 20 systems tim simply
writes a code to do so and the very next
day tim is told we changed our mind we
don't need maya skill i think we'll just
use oracle this does not bother him
because now he just opens the file he
makes a few corrections in his code and
that should work just fine code is also
testable so if tim had to write ten
commands to do something and at his
tenth command he realized the very first
command he wrote there was something not
right there well that would be quite
tiresome wouldn't it with codes however
you can test it even before running it
and all the bugs can be caught and
corrected codes are also deployable so
they're easily deployable and they're
deployable multiple times so now that we
saw the various advantages of having
codes let's say what infrastructure as
code exactly is here's the definition
infrastructure as code is a type of id
infrastructure where the operation team
manages the code rather than a manual
procedure so infrastructure as a code
allows the operations team to take care
of a code which automatically performs
various procedures rather than having to
manually do those procedures so with
this feature all your policies and your
configurations are written as code let's
now look at the various components of
chef so our first component is the
workstation the workstation is the
system where the system administrator
sits he or she creates the codes for
configuring your nodes now these codes
which in case of chef are written in
ruby are called the recipes and you'll
have multiple number of recipes so a
collection of recipes is called a
cookbook now these cookbooks are only
created at the workstation but they need
to be stored at the server so the knife
is a command line tool so it's basically
a command that you will see us executing
in one of our demos that shifts these
cookbooks from the workstation over to
the server a second component is the
server so servers like the middleman it
lies between your workstation and your
nodes and this is where all your
cookbooks are stored because as you saw
previously the knife sends these
cookbooks over from the workstation to
the server the server can be hosted
locally that's on your workstation
itself or it can be remote so you can
have your server at a different location
you can even have it on the cloud
platform and a final confidence the node
so nodes are the systems that require
the configuration in a chef architecture
you can have a number of nodes oh ohio
is a service which is installed on your
node and it is responsible for
collecting all the information regarding
your current state of the node this
information is then sent over to the
server to be compared against the
configuration files and check if any new
configuration is required chef client is
another such service on your node which
is responsible for all the
communications with the server so
whenever the node has a demand for a
recipe the shift client is responsible
for communicating this demand to the
server since you have a number of nodes
in a chef architecture it's not
necessary that each node is identical so
of course every node can have a
different configuration let's now have a
look at the chef architecture so here we
have a workstation one server machine
and two nodes you can have any number of
nodes first things first the system
administrator must create a recipe so
the recipes that are mentioned in our
chef architecture are just dummy recipes
we look into actual functioning recipes
later in our demo so you have one recipe
two recipes three recipes and a
collection of recipes forms a cookbook
so guys if you look at the recipe in
source you have simply learn 3.erb erb
is the extension for your ruby files so
the cookbooks are only created at the
workstation they now need to be sent
over to the server where they are stored
and this is the task of the knife knife
is a command line tool which is
responsible for transferring all your
cookbooks onto the server from the
workstation here's the command for
running your knife knife upload simply
db where simply db is the name of the
cookbook we then move on to our node
machines at our nodes we run the ohi
service the ohi service will collect all
information regarding the current state
of your nodes and send it over to the
chef client when you run the chef client
these informations are sent over to the
server and they are tested against the
cookbooks so if there is any discrepancy
between the current state of your notes
and the cookbook that is if one of the
notes does not match the configurations
required the cookbook is then fetched
from the server and executed at the node
this sets the note to the right state
there are various flavors of chef we'll
quickly go through these first we have
chef solo with chef solo there's no
separate server so your cookbooks are
located on the node itself now this kind
of configuration is used only when you
have just a single node to take care of
the next flavor is the hosted chef with
hosted chef you still have your
workstation and your note but your
server is now used as a service on the
cloud this really makes things simple
because you don't have to set up a
server yourself and it still performs
all the functioning of a typical chef
this is the configuration you will
notice that we'll be using in our demo
chef client server with shift client
server you have a workstation you have
server and you have n number of nodes
now this is the traditional chef
architecture this is the one we have
used for all the explanations previously
and finally we have private chef private
chef is also known as enterprise chef in
this case your workstation server and
node all are located within the
enterprise infrastructure this is the
main difference between chef client
server and private chef in case of shep
client server all these three machines
could be dispersed the enterprise
version of chef also provides the
liberty to add extra layers of security
and other features and we reach the
final part of our video where we'll have
the hands-on so before we dive into our
demo let me just quickly give you an
introduction to it we'll be using two
virtual boxes both centos s7 one will be
used as workstation while the other will
be a node so we are just using one node
to make things simple the server will be
used as a service on the cloud now these
are the steps we'll be performing during
our demo we'll first download and
install the chef dk on our workstation
we then make an empty cookbook file and
we'll write a recipe into it we need to
then set up the server so as i mentioned
earlier server will be a service on the
cloud so you'll have to create a profile
but this will be completely free we then
link the workstation to the server and
will upload the recipe to the server the
notes will now download the cookbooks
from the server and configure themselves
so now that you have some idea about
what we'll be doing let's move on to the
actual demo we begin our demo
here's my oracle vm virtualbox manager i
have two machines here i've already
created my workstation and node both of
these are sent to s7 machines
just for you to differentiate this is my
terminal and for my workstation it's a
black background with white text and as
of my note it's a black background with
green text
the first thing you do is you go to your
workstation box and open a web browser
search for chef dk installation
go to the first link which is your
chef's official page and under red hat
enterprise because our system's a red
hat system
select the link of the version that
you're using so i'm using centos 7 so my
operating system version is 7 so i'll
take this link now this is the link for
downloading your chef dk you copy this
link and go to your terminal guys notice
i'm in the home directory of my root
user so let's install our chef dk
and it's getting installed now this will
take some time because it's quite a
large file
and chef dk is downloaded next step we
need to install it
and this is the version of the chef dk
that we have downloaded
so type the same
okay so that's done so now we need to
make our recipes and the recipes will
exist within cookbooks so first let's
make a chef repository so within that
we'll have a folder for holding all our
cookbooks and within our cookbook we'll
write our recipe so we start with the
directory for chef repository
[Music]
move into it
create a folder called
cookbooks within which we'll store each
of our cookbooks
move into this
folder
[Music]
okay so we'll just check the contents
here right now so we have our chef dk we
have a chef repo folder here and let's
check the content of the chef repo
and this has cookbooks okay so our first
cookbook that we'll be making will be
under this folder cookbooks so let's
move into cookbooks
we are in now we need to create our
first cookbook so the instruction for
creating your first cookbook is chef
generate
cookbook
and the name of your cookbook so i'm
just giving the name a sample
yeah so our cookbook sample is created
now when you create your cookbook you'll
notice that a hierarchy is also
automatically created so let's just
check the hierarchy of our cookbook
let's move into sample
and tree is the command for checking the
hierarchy so here as you can see we have
recipes and under recipes we have
default.rb so we'll be editing this
default.rb to create our recipe okay so
let's begin with that let's move into
our recipes folder
and open your default.rb
and here we are so now we'll type in our
code
so what's our recipe for a recipe is for
installing the httpd package
on our note and then we'll also create a
small index file where we'll just have a
simple content such as welcome or
something like that just to check if our
httpd is working fine so let's begin
typing the code here package httpd
service
httpd
do and what must be done with this
package is that once it's installed it
needs to be enabled
and it needs to be started
and so that's our first task our next
task
is creating our html file
so as you know all your html files
will follow this path name
and this is the content of your file
you have successfully
configured
your node
and that's it that's our simple code
so our recipe is now ready save it and
exit back to your terminal now what we
need to do is that we need to configure
our server so go to your browser
on the search engine type manage dot
chef dot io
so as i mentioned earlier we'll be using
a server as a service on the cloud
so you'll enter your
login page for the chef server most of
you may not have a profile already so
you go to click here to get started and
fill in the details
it's just like creating an account on
facebook so i already have my account
i've put in the credentials here i'll
just sign in now the first thing once
you sign in is you'll get an option to
create an organization so all you have
to do there is you gotta enter the name
of your organization and just below that
there's another box for entering a short
form of your organization now my
organization name was simply learn and
the short form was slp one two three so
when you come to the administration tab
under organization you can see this
organization name next step click on
this arrow and you gotta download your
starter kit okay so once you click on
down starter kit you'll come to this
page where there's a button for download
starter kit
so do download it
save the file
so now come back to your terminal
so you come back to your terminal and
next what you need to do is you need to
unzip your shiftstarter.zip so for that
first we'll move our chef's starter to
the root so it's currently present under
the downloads folder let's move it
so we have moved our chefstarter.zip now
let's unzip it
first let's just check
the contents of our root directory right
now
so we have a chef repository
chef repo
folder that we created the chef starter
zip that we just moved and of course the
chef dk so now we can unzip our
chef starter kit
and that's done so our next step we
gotta move the chef
starters.zip file into a cookbooks which
lies inside the chef repository this is
done because we'll be executing our
further commands to connect our
workstation with the server from the
cookbooks because that is where our
sample cookbook is
and that's moved
so now we'll run a knife command so what
knife does is that it uploads your
recipes or your cookbooks onto the
server so here's the command for running
your knife
samples the name of the cookbook that
you're uploading and uploading sample
0.1.0 and uploading sample yeah so our
cookbook is uploaded now let's just
check this at our server how we do that
is
go back to your browser where you have
open your server
so there's no node here yet
because we have not configured our node
with the server but we have configured
our workstation with the server
and you see here our cookbooks
uploaded sample so our workstation and
our server are connected so now we need
to connect our node with the server so
first we move on to our node machine
we need to take the ip address of our
node machine
so for the ip address
we'll just type ifconfig
[Music]
right so this is your ip address
192.168.2.190
note this down somewhere guys
now that's done
go back to your workstation
i'll just keep it this way so i can see
both okay go back to your workstations
terminal
but this time to connect our server with
the node so we have taken the ip of our
node and this is where we'll be using it
192.168.2 point the username which is
root in our case
and then enter the password
and then finally you enter your node
name
so this is the name that will appear for
this particular node on our server i'm
just giving it chef note you can give it
whatever you like we'll just check the
command knife bootstrap the ip address
ssh user our user which is root
ssh password the password for the root
and finally the node name
and the nodes getting created
so once the node is connected to your
server we'll go back to our browser open
our server service on the cloud and
we'll check the node tab so ideally your
node name should appear there
great so our node is added also if you
notice here our chef client service on
the node has started running so let's
just check this with the server
go to your nodes
and here we go so chef node a centos 7
platform
this is our ip so it's all done so now
we need to add a cookbook to the run
list of this node so come here click on
this arrow
edit run list
here's sample this is the cookbook that
we want to run on our node put on the
current run list and here we have the
run button just click on that so this
should have transferred our cookbook
onto the node let's check that go to
your node machine
clear this
we need to be the root
let's run the chef client service
so we're running it once again because
after it was started we did add
something to our run list the changes in
the run list is updated
so in 1 minute 56 seconds
our cookbook has
run
on our note so the configuration changes
should have been made
let's check that it's pretty simple just
go to your browser
on the search engine just type localhost
and here's our html page that we created
on our workstation congrats you
configured your first note and i really
hope you did so that is the end of our
demo we have successfully installed the
httpd package
on our node and we have also executed a
html file so with that we come to an end
to our video now let's have a quick look
at everything you learned today first
you saw why you should probably use chef
then what exactly is this chef we looked
into the two most important terms often
used with chef configuration management
and infrastructure as code we also saw
the various components of chef and how
these components work together to
provide the capabilities that chef does
we looked into the four flavors of chef
and finally we wrapped it up with the
demo on installing httpd package on a
note and also writing a simple html file
hello this is matthew from simply learn
we're going to focus specifically on
puppet so in this session what we're
going to do is we're going to cover what
and why you would use puppets what are
the different elements and components of
puppet and how does it actually work and
then we'll look into the companies that
are adopting puppet and what are the
advantages that they have now received
by having puppet within their
organization and finally we'll wrap
things up by reviewing how you can
actually write a manifest in puppet so
let's get started so why puppet so here
is a scenario that as an administrator
you may already be familiar with you as
an administrator have multiple servers
that you have to work with and manage so
what happens when a server goes down
it's not a problem you can jump onto
that server and you can fix it but what
if the scenario changes and you have
multiple servers going down so here is
where puppet shows its strap with
puppets all you have to do is write a
simple script that can be written with
ruby and write out and deploy to the
servers your settings for each of those
servers the code gets pushed out and to
the servers that are having problems and
then you can choose to either roll back
to those servers to their previous
working states or set them to a new
state and do all of this in a matter of
seconds and it doesn't matter how large
your server environment is you can reach
to all of these servers your environment
is secure you're able to deploy your
software and you're able to do this all
through infrastructure as code which is
the advanced devops model for building
out solutions so let's dig deeper into
what puppet actually is so puppet is a
configuration management tool maybe
similar tools like chef that you may
already be familiar with it ensures that
all your systems are configured to a
desired and predictable state public can
also be used as a deployment tool for
software automatically you can deploy
your software to all of your systems or
to specific systems and this is all done
with code this means you can test the
environment and you can have a guarantee
that the environment you want is written
and deployed accurately so let's go
through those components of puppet so
here we have a breakdown of the puppet
environment and on the top we have the
main server environment and then below
that we have the client environment that
would be installed on each of the
servers that would be running within
your network so if we look at the top
part of the screen we have here our
puppet master store which has and
contains our main configuration files
and those are comprised of manifests
that are actual codes for configuring
their clients we have templates that
combine our codes together to render a
final document and you have files that
will be deployed as content that could
be potentially downloaded by the clients
wrapping this all together is a module
of manifest templates and files you
would apply a certificate authority to
sign the actual documents so that the
clients actually know that they're
receiving the appropriate and authorized
modules outside of the master server
where you'd create your manifest
templates and files you would have
public client is a piece of software
that is used to configure a specific
machine there are two parts to the
client one is the agent that constantly
interacts with the master server to
ensure that the certificates are being
updated appropriately and then you have
the fact that the current state of the
client that is used and communicated
back to through the agent so now that we
know what puppet is let's look into the
puppet architecture so puppet has a
master slave architecture as you can see
here on the top we have the puppet
master and below we have the puppet
clients so the puppet master is the
system where your system administrator
sits the clients are those systems which
require configuration you can have n
number of clients connected to the
puppet master so don't worry we look
into each of these components in detail
firstly we have the puppet master so the
puppet mask is where the system
administrator sits and he or she types
in the codes here so the codes are not
only written in the system but they are
also stored here and whenever the client
requires these codes for their
configuration they simply request it so
manifest is the first sub-component of
the puppet master these are the actual
files where the codes are written so in
case of puppet these are ruby files
modules tie manifests templates and
files into a single unit
now these codes dictate the instructions
for performing various tasks on your
client the next component is templates
so if manifests are your code templates
are the data so let me explain this to
you with an example consider you want to
create a file called index.html on one
of your client machines so what you do
is you write the code for creating this
file in your manifest and the content of
this file is written in your templates
then you simply link them but here's the
thing when you divide your code and data
in this way it's a very clean structure
so it's preferred to do it in this
manner files are your static contents so
the files are basically sent to your
client and they are simply downloaded at
the client there is no execution or
compilation involved with your files now
this is where files and templates are
extremely different because with
templates they are never sent over to
your client the templates are simply
read by the parser at the master itself
modules ties the manifest templates and
files into a single unit so modules is
not a separate component as such it just
provides a very clean hierarchy this is
the most important component of the
puppet master ca which stands for
certificate authority
now as we will see later in this video
the puppet master and the puppet client
communicate through an exchange of ssl
certificates so when the client sends
over the certificate to the master ca
provides the master the authority to
sign these certificates the minute the
master signs a certificate the master is
basically saying that yes this client is
registered with me and i agree to
exchange data with this client our next
component puppet client of course these
are the systems that require to be
configured agent is a service installed
on the client the agent is solely
responsible for all the communication
between the master and the client and
finally we have factor so factor is
responsible for collecting all the data
about the present state of our client
and sending this data over to the puppet
master at the master this data is
compared against the manifest which are
your code files and then these manifests
are sent over to the client depending
upon the results of this comparison so
now that we had a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together
so we have a master and we have three
clients now before any information can
be transferred between the master and
the client it's important that these
components recognize each other also
there needs to be an encrypted channel
of communication between each pair of
master and client now all the data which
is transferred between the master and
the client it flows through this channel
so let's see how this entire procedure
of recognizing each other works the core
of this procedure are the ssl
certificates ssl stands for secure
socket layer secure socket layer is a
security protocol and it forms an
encrypted channel between two components
what this encrypted channel ensures is
that all the data that is passed through
this channel is not accessible by any
other system outside so it provides
complete security okay so we will
consider a very general scenario we have
a master and a client here this is not
the puppet master or the puppet client
they're just two systems and we're just
going forward with master slave
architecture so the client so far is not
a client it is just a system and we will
refer to the system as system a so
system a sends over a client certificate
to the master associated with this
client certificate is the host name of
system a now master goes through the
certificate it sees the host name and
then it decides whether it wants to form
a communication link with the system a
if it does it signs the certificate and
the signed certificate is sent back to
system a now the system a is officially
a client the minute the master signed
the client certificate it said that yes
i am willing to exchange information
with this system and i do take the
system as one of my clients so now that
the system is officially a client it can
request for data from the master and the
master will simply send over the data
now we are here to talk about puppet so
if this was a puppet master and this was
a puppet client then the first three
stages will be the same so the puppet
client sends over the certificate to the
master the master signs the certificate
sends it back and the client requests
for data now by data here of course we
mean the configuration data those are
the manifest or even could be your files
so what happens after this request after
this request the factor service which is
present on your clients collects all the
information regarding the present state
of your client so this information could
include the operating system that's
installed on them the various number of
software present on them the versions of
these software now all this information
is collected it's called the fact and
it's sent over to the master at the
master this information that is the
facts is compared against the manifest
so why does the master do this the
master basically compares the facts
against the manifest to know if what the
manifest is about to perform is already
performed on these systems so if the
manifest has some additional
functionality they are compiled into
catalogs and then these catalogs are
sent over to the client now remember
those agent services which existed in
your clients here's where they come in
the agents take the catalog and execute
them on the client once executed these
catalogs make the required changes on
the client and a report is generated
this report is then sent back to the
master so the master keeps record of all
the changes that's made in the system
and this comes very handy when one of
the systems fail and it's required to be
rolled back to its previous working
state so this entire procedure can be
repeated n number of times and can be
repeated at regular intervals so if you
have a scenario where a system needs to
be configured every 30 minutes what you
can do is you can set your interval and
automatically every 30 minutes your
systems will be configured so today i'll
be showing you how you can use puppet to
install apache on one of your client
machines so we'll be using two machines
here we'll have a server and we'll have
a node machine the server is essentially
your master the node is your client i'm
just using the term server and node
instead because i want to keep it very
close to as they are used in the
commands now both these machines are
going to be sent to a seven machines and
i have oracle vm virtualbox installed on
my machine so on that i've simply
created two virtual boxes both centos 7
of course so before we move on to the
actual demo i'll just take you through
the various steps so first we'll install
the puppet server on our server or
master machine we'll then start the
server service we then shift over to our
node or the client machine and we'll
install the puppet agent service we will
then start this service too and the
minute you start the puppet agent
service an ssl certificate is created so
this certificate will have the host name
of your node attached to it and this is
how the master or the server will
recognize this certificate and then it
will sign this certificate so once your
master or the server signs the
certificate you can write your manifest
so the manifesto is just the code for
configuration and once that two is done
you shift back to your client or the
node system and you run the asian
service so once you run the agent
service your manifest or your catalogs
because as you know the manifests are
compiled into catalogs these are
executed on your node and this will make
the required changes so that's how this
entire process is going to work now
let's move on to the actual demo
this is my oracle vm virtualbox manager
the last two machines you see here are
the ones we'll be using for this demo
the puppet server is your puppet master
puppet client of course is the client so
let's just have a look at these two
machines
this is my puppet server so just so you
can differentiate guys the terminals
have been set accordingly puppet server
has a black background with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background with green text
so we'll move on to server machine or
the master machine because that's the
one we'll be working on first so before
we begin we need to set the hostname of
our master to puppet so this is a very
essential step in the configuration of
puppet if you miss this out there are
quite a lot of other changes you'll have
to make in certain files so let's do
this first
so that's the command to set the host
name the last word you see there that's
the new host name you want
okay so now we'll just check if our host
name is set so just type host name
and yeah it's puppet
so next we will check the ip of this
machine
so for that you just type if config
enter
so this is your ip guys
under enp0s3
in its value that is
192.168.2.183 of course the ip will
differ for you guys
needless to say
so note that down somewhere because
we'll require it when we are configuring
our client
okay so now you want your puppet server
and your client to communicate so for
this we need to remove certain firewalls
so the command for this is
sudo because we want the root permission
system
ctl
stop
firewall
d
and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process so we download the puppet
labs at first now guys ensure that your
systems your virtual boxes in this case
are connected to the net
also you won't be getting an ip if it's
not for the first time
so here's the command to download the
puppet lag
enter the password again
okay so the puppet labs is downloaded
now you need to install this
so installation guys we will be
installing the puppet server on the
master machine or the puppet server
machine
so this may take a while
so that took a while so i just skipped
to the last part where it's completed
the installation process is over
now we need to make a small change
in our system config puppet server file
so let's just move to the file first
this file will open in vi editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server now you do
not need 2gb
so we are going to reduce the size
512
mb should be enough
so guys notice here i did not type the b
okay so i just change this to xms
512
m
let's save that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite troublesome
okay so now we can start a puppet server
service
we enable the
service okay so that's done so basically
our puppet server service
has started it's running presently
so for a while we are done with the
server machine
let's move on to our client machine
okay first things first we open our edc
host file
with sudo because you need to make a few
changes and save it
open this in the vi terminal
okay guys so here
you have to add this one line at the end
type in the ip
for your puppet server machine
puppet
puppet
dash
master
so let's save this file
now we'll move on to downloading puppet
labs on our puppet client so the command
is the same that we use for puppet
server
so puppet labs is downloaded now we need
to install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet servers
installed let me just clear this window
now that our puppet agent service is
installed we'll start this service so
i'll just type in the command for
starting the puppet agent service
okay
as you can see here ensure changed
stopped to running
so basically the service was not running
before and now it's changed to the
running state
and while we executed this command not
only did the service start running but
an ssl certificate was also created so
this certificate should have the host
name of this machine that's a puppet
client machine attached to it so let's
just check what the host name of our
machine is
that's
localhost.localdomain so our certificate
should have this attached to it so guys
the first time your client sends a
certificate the name of the certificate
itself is usually the host name of the
machine so our certificate's name should
be localhost.localdomain
we'll check this on our master system
and that's where we'll sign the
certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since we have
just one client
and we just started the client we should
have technically just one certificate
and it will be so
yeah so this is a certificate localhost
dot local domain
we'll now sign the certificate
okay sorry about that just
need to remove these
brackets
here as you can see here the certificate
is signed
sign certificate request
here
so once the certificate is signed the
request for signing the certificate is
removed that's this line
now that a certificate is signed we can
begin to write a manifest so let's move
into a manifest folder and we'll create
a placeholder file
so we'll create a file called sample.pp
this is just a sample file
we won't be writing anything in this
file as of now so we are just checking
here we are just creating this file and
then we'll go to our client machine and
just check the if we can access this
file from there
so now we'll move to our client machine
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it says applied
catalog in 0.03 seconds so our catalog
is executed
on our client machine
now a catalog was just a placeholder
basically so the file that we created
which is sample.pp had no content and we
were just testing our client now let's
go back to our master server
put some content into this file and see
how the execution takes place
so we'll open our file sample.pp which
we created earlier in the vi editor
let's type our code here
so node and then within the brackets we
enter the hostname of our client machine
so this ensures that our manifest is
executed on this particular machine
now the apache service package on centos
is called the httpd
so this line that i just typed in is the
action it will ensure that the httpd
package is installed on your client
and that's it so this is our code we'll
save it
now let's go back to our client machine
and test it
so this is our client machine
and our catalogs applied on the client
so i just cleared the screen now we'll
start the apache service
okay so how do we see if it's running we
just need to go to our browser
and at localhost you must have the
testing page for your apache
so we type localhost
enter
and yeah this is the testing page for
apache
so as you can see we have successfully
used puppet to install the apache
service on our puppet line
and this is the end of
so let's have a look at companies that
are using puppet today there are a
number of companies that have adopted
puppet as a way to manage their
infrastructure so companies that are
using puppy today include spotify google
att so why are these companies choosing
to use puppet as their main
configuration management tool the answer
can be seen if we look at a specific
company staples so staples chose to take
and use puppet for their configuration
management tool and use it within their
own private cloud the results were
dramatic the amount of time that the it
organization was able to save in
deploying and managing their
infrastructure through using puppets
enabled them to open up time to allow to
experiment with other and new projects
and assignments a real tangible benefit
to a company so let's look at how you
write a manifest in puppet so so
manifests are designed for writing out
in code how you would configure a
specific node in your server environment
the manifests are compiled into catalogs
which are then executed on the client
each of the manifests are written in the
language of ruby with a dot pp extension
now if we step through the five key
steps for writing a manifest they are
one create your manifest and that is
written by the system administrator two
compile your manifest is compiled into a
catalog three deploy the catalog is then
deployed onto the clients four execute
the catalogs are run on the client by
the agent and then five end clients are
configured to a specific and desired
state if we actually look into how
manifest is written it's written with a
very common syntax if you've done any
work with ruby or really configuration
of systems in the past this may look
very familiar to you so we break out the
work that we have here you start off
with a package file or service as your
resource type and then you give it a
name and then you look at the features
that need to be said such as ip address
then you're actually looking to have a
command written such as present or start
the manifest can contain multiple
resource types if we continue to write
our manifest and puppet the default
keyword applies a manifest to all
clients so an example would be to create
a file path that creates a folder called
sample in a main folder called etc the
specified content is written into a file
that is then posted into that folder and
then we're going to say we want to be
able to trigger an apache service and
then ensure that that apache service is
installed on a node so we write the
manifest and we deploy it to a client
machine on that client machine a new
folder will be created with a file in
that folder and an apache server will be
installed you can do this to any machine
and you'll have exactly the same results
on those machines now let's have a look
at the puppet community
the puppet community is a rich community
of a lot of people officially there is
no count but counting the various
channels where people collaborate there
are a little over 2 900 committers to
github projects who are directly or
indirectly associated with puppet labs
there are
4893 modules on the official puppet
forge these include modules from the
puppet labs and also from open source
contributors to github
so that's nearly five thousand modules
of ready-made code available on the
puppet forge so before you write any
code for puppet you can check to see if
it's already been written by someone
now there's a mailing list which has
6588 participants apart from this on
slack overflow you have a big tag of
puppet labs and puppet which gives you a
list of only puppet questions that's a
good playground for you to interact with
people who are already using puppet
and who are contributing and helping
others now let's have a look at puppet
forge
so puppet forge is a github client for a
repository which is hosted by puppet
labs that has almost five thousand
modules of puppet code so these are both
puppet labs and community contributed
the best thing about this is that
they're easy to customize so when you
have a requirement for anything you're
doing with your infrastructure you can
just grab one of those five thousand
modules and then you can customize it
according to your needs one of the other
benefits is they have built-in tests so
they follow all of the best practices
now if you write your own module you
also have to write your own tests and
you have to spend extra time writing
best practice code
all of that has been taken care of and
you can just download any one of those
and customize it according to your needs
and you're good to go
so that's the benefit you get from such
a large community where people
contribute to the modules and the code
and share with the community the puppet
dsl puppet dsl is a puppet domain
specific language
it's the puppet's primary programming
language it's just like plain english
and you don't really need to be a
programmer to write code in it it's kind
of a sub child of ruby because it
approaches and uses is equal to and
greater than marks to define things so
it's very easy to learn
you can specify packages that you want
to install you can specify services to
be managed you can do things based on
the operating system you have so we'll
be writing a small puppet module which
will be using this puppet dsl
we will do that after we install the
puppet server and the client and then we
will write a simple puppet module to
show how to use the puppet dsl
let's have a look at the demo we are
going to do so you will be setting up
the machines using pseudodns because we
want to have a resolvable dns because
only by having a resolvable dns can we
use puppet because puppet uses the ssl
certificates
now we'll be installing the puppet
server and the client will be signing
the certificates of the client on the
server side and then we'll proceed with
writing an ntp module which we'll be
using for installation of ntp on the
client and then we'll look at the puppet
programming language or dsl now we're
going to look at a demo here so we will
be setting up the machines we'll set up
a pseudo dns locally because puppet
requires a fully qualified domain name
in order to run since there is a
certificate communication taking place
here
we will be installing the puppet server
the puppet client will be signing the
certificate and finally we will write an
ntp module and make it run
so now we will be starting a puppet
master and a client i have two machines
here one is the puppet master and the
second is the puppet client the puppet
master has got almost four gig of ram
and four vcpus which i can show you here
because it's a ruby on rails application
it requires a lot of cpu and ram
for the client i don't need that much
ram and cpu so i've allotted one
gigabyte of ram and one vcpu
i will start both of these machines and
find out the ip addresses right click
normal start
both of these machines are starting up
the puppet client has started up and the
first thing i'll do is log in using root
and red hat password and then i will
change the host name so i'll say vim etc
hostname
this will open a hostname file in a text
editor which is vim
then we'll do a dd which will delete
that existing hostname
and then i press the i for insert mode
and finally i'll type
the puppet hyphen client
which will be the host name of this
machine i'll save this file by doing
escape semicolon wq exclamation mark
and i'll reboot the machine
similarly going to the puppet master
i'll say root red hat
i'll open the hostname file
say dd then i'll say puppet hyphen
master
i'll save this file and reboot the
machine for the hostname change to take
effect the hostname change does not take
effect unless you reboot the machine
now both these machines are ready
i'm going to find out the ips and use
the mac terminal to log into these
so this is 23 and 21 so 23 is my server
and 21 is my client
i'll ssh to 23 first
now in order for the puppet master to be
installed i need a fully qualified
domain name here and a fake dns which
means a fully resolvable dns name so if
i do hostname here you see my host name
is puppetmaster in order to set up a
fake dns i need to go to the etc hosts
file
go to the end
then i say ip address host name local
then space host name
now this is one of the techniques which
makes the linux server believe that
there's a fully qualified domain name on
this machine
i'll save this
then i do a host name hyphen f
you see it has a fully qualified domain
name now
so now we will be downloading the puppet
labs repository for ubuntu 16.04 which
is xenial
so i'll say curl hyphen 0 https
apt dot puppet labs
dot com
slash puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dab
you can see there is a debian file which
has been downloaded here i will import
this using the dpkg command so i'll say
dpkg hyphen i puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dap
and then i'll say apt-get update which
will update my apt package indexes on
this machine
and now i'll install the puppet server
so i'll say apt-get install
puppet hyphen
puppet server hyphen-y
so the puppet server is now installed
and we will be configuring the memory
allocation for the puppet server so i'll
say etc default puppet server so by
default
it has only
got two gigabyte allocated we'll give it
three gigabyte because it's jvm
i'll make this three and i'll change
this to three as well
and i'll save this file
i'll make sure the unconfigured firewall
allows port 8140 which is the puppet lab
puppet server port
the rules have been updated to allow
that i'll now start the puppet server so
i'll say systemctl
start puppet server
it takes some time because it's jvm so
it takes a couple of minutes to start
the puppet server
so the puppet server is now running
i'll also enable it at boot time so i'll
say systemctl enable puppet to server
it will enable it boot time
now i also need to configure a fully
qualified domain name here so okay so
i'll do that by going into the hosts
file
i'll go to the end and i'll say
192.168.1.23 and then puppet
hyphen server dot local and then puppet
hyphen server
if i do a hostname hyphen f
put hyphen master.local because the
current hostname is
puppet hyphen master
so the trick is to have the
hostname.local in front of the ip
address in the host file
having a fully qualified domain name now
now we will go to the client setup
the client setup is almost the same with
just a small difference
the package which we need to install on
the client is puppet agent so we will go
to the client
so you see this has got a hostname
now we also need to set up the fake dns
here so i'll copy this hostname
open the host
line go to the end
write the i p address
and then dot local and then host name
again
so this will give me a fully qualified
domain name
so when i do a host name
it says puppet hyphen client when i do a
host name hyphen f it says puppet client
local to install the puppet agent on
this machine i will need to download the
zenio packages so i'll say wget https
apt.puppetlabs.com
slash puppet labs
hyphen release hyphen pc one hyphen
xenial.dap
i'll download this and then i'll say
dpkg hyphen i puppet labs iphone release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dap
so this is the repository package which
i'll be downloading here and then i'll
say apt-get
update hyphen y this will update my apps
caches on this machine
and now i'll finally install the puppet
agent
so i'll say apt-get install puppet agent
hyphen agent hyphen y
now the puppet agent is here i'll start
the puppet agent and i'll enable it at
boot time so i'll say system control
start puppet
then system control
enable puppet
now puppet is enabled now we have set up
the fully qualified domain name on the
client and the server but each of them
should know each other so we'll have to
do a cross certificate host mapping so
we will be copying the host file entry
of the client and adding it to the
server so i'll go to the etc hosts on
the server side go to the end paste it
there
okay and i'll be adding the entry of the
master on the client side
okay now both of the servers will
recognize each other now because one of
them has the host entry of the other
so if i do from the master ping puppet
iphoneagent.local
if i ping the agent from the server
hyphen client dot local
it is able to ping it and if i ping the
master from the client
if i say ping puppet hyphen
hyphenmaster.local
both of them will be able to ping each
other
now the next step would be to create a
certificate signing request so i'll go
to my to this directory which is opt
puppet labs puppet bin
and i'll say puppet agent hyphen t
hyphen knife and server
is equal to
and i'll give the fully qualified domain
name of the puppet master
then i'll say
hyphen f
when i do this it will create a
certificate signing request you see
now if i go to the server and i do an
opt
i'll check and see how many certificates
are pending to be signed
you'll see there is a puppet client
certificate which is pending to be
signed which is denoted by the absence
of a plus sign here
i'll be signing the certificate so i'll
say puppet search sign and then the name
so puppet hyphen client
dot local this will sign the
certificates
and when i go to the server on the
client side if i run the puppet agent
again
you see it's actually pulling down the
catalog as of now it has an empty
catalog
that says there is nothing
now we have configured the puppet agent
and the master now we will be taking a
module from puppet forge
puppet forge is a big collection of open
source modules which are free to use as
a first step we will be using a
ready-made module
and that would be a demonstration for
how to actually get up and running with
a module so search for apache module
here
this is the puppet labs apache module
i'll be using the puppet command line
puppet module install
this is the command for that but i will
make sure i run this command from the
puppet home so i'll go to the master
i'll go to etc puppet labs
code environments production
in this i'll do modules
now i will run it from the binary which
is present at the opt puppet labs bin
puppet
and then module install
puppet labs hyphen apache and then this
version so we are specifying the latest
version
and i'll hit enter when i press enter it
starts downloading from the forge api
so you see the module is downloaded in
addition to the dependencies so there is
concat std lib and apache
so now i'll go to a folder here which is
one level up called manifest so this is
the file here etc puppet labs code
environments production manifest so in
this there's a file which i'll be
creating called site.pp the site.pp will
specify and this is the main controller
of how the infrastructure looks in the
site pp i specify
that i want
puppetclient.localnode to have the
apache module included
i'll save this file and the only thing i
need to do now is
since all is set on the server side i
need to go to the client side and run
puppet agent it will automatically
download the apache module and compile
it and it may then make sure the server
is in a state so
when i press enter we see a lot of
output it tries to configure apache on
this machine and done now when i go to
the front end of this machine on this
port i should be able to see apache's
default page so this is apaches default
page
so the module which we downloaded from
the forge was actually written in a way
that
apache would be installed and run at
boot time so that is why it's running
here
and that is all we have from the uh
puppet module
and this concludes the demo today i'll
be showing you how you can install the
configuration management tool ansible so
let's have a brief about why one would
use ansible and what exactly is ansible
so if you consider the case of an
organization it has a very large
infrastructure which means it has more
than probably hundreds of systems and
giving one or even a small team of
people the responsibility to configure
all these systems makes their work
really tough repetitive and as you know
manual work is always prone to errors so
ansible is a tool which can automate the
configuration of all these systems with
ansible a small team of system
administrators can write simple code in
yaml and these codes are deployed onto
the hundreds and thousands of servers
which configures them to the desired
states so ansible automates
configuration management that is
configuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an order in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible so here
is my oracle vm virtualbox manager i'll
be using two systems there's the node
system which is basically my client
system and there's the server system or
the master system so let's begin at our
server system
so this is my master system guys so the
first thing we do is we download our
ansible tool
so one thing we must remember with
ansible is that unlike
chef or puppet ansible is a push type of
configuration management tool so what
this means is that the entire control
here lies with your master or your
server system this is where you write
your configuration files and these are
also responsible for pushing these
configuration files onto your node or
client system as and when required
create so ansible tool is installed now
we need to open an ansible host file and
there we'll specify the details of our
node or client machine
so this is a ansible host file as you
can see here the entire file is
commented but there's a certain syntax
that you'd observe for example here we
have a group name web servers under
which we have the ip addresses or
certain host name so this is about how
we'll be adding the details for our
client system first we need to give a
group name
under this group basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the ip address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the ip address
192.168.2.11
once you have typed in your ip address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for our client machine
so all communications between the server
or the master system and the client or
the node system takes place through ssh
ssh basically provides a secure channel
for the transfer of information
follow this up with your password
in my case it's the root's password
and that's it we are done so now we save
this file and go back to our terminal
so now that our hosts file is written
the next thing we do is we write our
playbook so playbook is the technical
term used for all the configuration
files that we write in ansible now
playbooks are written in yaml yaml is
extremely simple to both write and
understand it's in fact very close to
english
so now we'll write our playbook the
playbook or any code in yaml first
starts with three dashes this indicates
the beginning of your file next thing we
need to give a name to our playbook
so name
and i'm going to name my playbook sample
book
we next need to specify our host systems
which is basically the systems at which
the configuration file or the playbook
in our case will be executed so we'll be
executing this at the client machines
mentioned under the group ansible
servers so we had just one client
machine under it we'll still mention the
group name
we next need to specify the user name
with which we'll be logging into our
client machine
which is root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root to execute this
playbook so becoming the roots called a
privilege escalation
next we need to specify our tasks so
these are basically the actions that the
playbook will be performing so you would
have noticed everything so far is
aligned that is name host remote user
become and task because these are at one
level now whatever comes under task will
be shifted slightly towards the right
although yaml is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing
so my first task is install httpd which
is basically a apache server
so now my command yum and this will be
installing the httpd package
and the latest state of it will be
installed so that's our first task
now our second task would be running our
apache service
so name
run httpd
and the action which is service
will be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd
and state
must be started
now we come to our third task
so here we'll create a very simple web
page that will be hosted
so create content is the name of our
task
and the content that we are creating
here will basically be copied
to our note system at a particular file
location that we'll provide
our content will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for all
our html files
and that's it we are done writing our
playbook
just save this and go back to your
terminal
before we execute the playbook or push
the playbook onto our note system let's
check the syntax of our playbook so the
command for doing so is
and if everything is fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the playbook to
our node or the client machine
and that's the syntax for doing so now
as your playbook is being sent over to
the client machine you can see that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had httpd so it says
okay because this does not need to be
changed our next task was running httpd
now although our system had the apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were okay now
everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that you check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now that everything's fine here we can
move on to our note system
and we'll just go to our browser so if
our playbook has been executed here what
should happen is that the httpd service
must be in the running state and the web
page that we created should be hosted so
let's just type localhost
and great everything's working fine so
our webpage is displayed here so we come
to an end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool ansible if
you have any doubts please post them in
the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you as soon as
possible ansible today as one of the key
tools that you would have within your
devops environment
so the things that we're going to go
through today is we're going to cover
why you would want to use a product like
ansible what ansible really is and how
it's of value to you in your
organization the differences between
ansible and other products that are
similar to it on the market and what
makes ansible a compelling product and
then we're going to dig into the
architecture for ansible we're going to
look at how you would create a playbook
how you'd manage your inventory of your
server environments and then what is the
actual workings of ansible as a little
extra we're going to also throw in
ansible tower one of the secret source
solutions that you can use for improving
the speed and performance of how you
create your ansible environments and
finally we're going to go through a use
case by looking at hootsuite social
media management company and how they
use ansible to really improve the
efficiency within their organizations so
let's jump into this so the big question
is why ansible so you have to think of
ansible as another tool that you have
within your devops environment for
helping manage the service and this
definitely falls on the operations side
of the dev ops equation so if we look
here we have a picture of sam and like
yourselves sam is a system administrator
and he is responsible for maintaining
the infrastructure for all the different
servers within his company so some of
the servers that he may have that he has
to maintain could be web servers running
apache they could be database servers
running uh mysql and if you only have a
few servers then that's fairly easy to
maintain i mean if you have three web
servers and two database servers and
let's face it would we all love just to
have one or two servers to manage it
would be really easy to maintain the
trick however is as we start increasing
the number of servers and this is a
reality of the environments that we live
and operate in it becomes increasingly
difficult to create consistent setup of
different infrastructures such as web
servers and databases for the simple
reason that we're all human as if we had
to update and maintain all of those
servers by hand there's a good chance
that we would not set up each server
identically now this is where anspo
really comes to the rescue and helps you
become an efficient operations team
ansible like other system solutions such
as chef and puppet uses code that you
can write and describe the installation
and setup of your servers so you can
actually repeat it and deploy those
servers consistently into multiple areas
so now you don't have to have one person
redoing and re-following setup
procedures you just write one script and
then each script can be executed and
have a consistent environment so we've
gone through why you'd want to use
ansible let's step through what ansible
really is
so you know this is all great but you
know how do we actually use these tools
in our environment so
ansible hat is a tool that really allows
you to create and control three key
areas that you'd have within your
operations environment first of all
there's it automation so you can
actually write instructions that
automate the its setup that you would
typically do manually in the past the
second is the configuration and having
consistent configuration imagine setting
up hundreds of apache servers and being
able to guarantee with precision that
each of those apache servers is set up
identically and then finally you want to
be able to automate the deployment so
that as you scale up your server
environment you can just push out
instructions that can deploy
automatically different servers the
bottom line is you want to be able to
speed up and make your operations team
more efficient so let's talk a little
bit about pull configuration and how it
works with ansible so there are two
different ways of being able to set up
different
environments for server farms one is to
have a key server that has all the
instructions on and then on each of the
servers that connect to that main master
server you would have a piece of
software known as a client installed on
each of those servers that would
communicate to the main master server
and then would periodically either
update or change the configuration of
the slave server this is known as a pull
configuration an alternative is a push
configuration and the push configuration
is slightly different the main
difference is as with a pull
configuration you have a master server
where you actually put up the
instructions but unlike the pull
configuration where you have a client
installed on each of the services with a
push configuration you actually have no
client installed on the remote servers
you simply are pushing out the
configuration to those servers and
forcing a restructure or a fresh clean
installation in that environment so
ansible is one of those second
environments where it's a push
configuration server and this contrasts
with other popular products like chef
and puppet which have a master slave
architecture with a master server
connecting with a client on a remote
slave environment where you would then
be pushing out the updates with ansible
you're pushing out the service and the
structure of the server to remote
hardware and you are just putting it
onto the hardware irrelevant of the
structure that's out there and there are
some significant advantages that you
have in that in that you're not having
to have the extra overhead weight of a
client installed on those remote servers
having to constantly communicate back to
the master environment so let's step
through the architecture that you would
have for an ansible environment
so when you're setting up an ansible
environment the first thing you want to
do is have a local machine and the local
machine is where you're going to have
all of your instruction and really the
power of the control that you'd be
pushing out to the remote server so the
local machine is where you're going to
be starting and doing all of your work
connected from the local machine are all
the different nodes pushing out the
different configurations that you would
set up on the local machine the
configurations that you would write and
you would write those in code within a
module so you do this on your local
machine for creating these modules and
each of these modules is actually
consistent playbooks the local machine
also has a second job and that job is to
manage the inventory of the nodes that
you have in your environment the local
machine is able to connect to each of
the different nodes that you would have
in your hardware network through ssh
clients so a secure client
let's dig into some of the different
elements within that architecture we're
going to take a first look at playbooks
that you would write and create for the
ansible environments so the core of
ansible is the playbook this is where
you create the instructions that you
write to define the architecture of your
hardware so the playbook is really just
a set of instructions that configure the
different nodes that you have and each
of those set of instructions is written
in a language called yammer and this is
a standard language used for
configuration server environments did
you know that yaml actually stands for
yaml8 markup language that's just a
little tidbit to hide behind your ear so
let's have a look at one of these
playbooks it looks like and here we have
a sample yaml script that we've written
so you start off your jammer script with
three dashes and that indicates the
start of a script and then the script
itself is actually consistent of two
distinct plays at the top we have play
one and below that we have play two
within each of those plays we define
which notes are we targeting so here we
have a web server in the top play and in
the second play we have a database
server that we're targeting and then
within each of those server environments
we have the specific tasks that we're
looking to execute so let's step through
some of these tasks we have an install
apache task we have a start apache task
and we have an install my sequel task
and when we do that we actually execute
a specific set of instructions and those
instructions can include installing
apache and then setting the state of the
apache environment or starting the
apache environment and setting up and
running the my sequel environment
so this really isn't too complicated and
that's the really good thing about
working with yama is it's really
designed to make it easy for you as an
operations lead to be able to configure
the environments that you want to
consistently create so let's take a step
back though we have two hosts we have
web server and database server where do
these names come from well this takes us
into our next stage and the second part
of working with ansible which is the
inventory management part of ansible so
the inventory part of ansible is where
we maintain the structure of our network
environment so what we do here is part
of the structure in creating different
nodes is we've had to create two
different nodes here we have a web
server node and a database server net
and under web server node we actually
have the names that were actually
pointing to specific machines within
that environment so now when we actually
write our scripts all we have to do is
refer to either web server or database
server and the different servers will
have the instructions from the yaml
script executed on them this makes it
really easy for you to be able to just
point to new services without having to
write out complex instructions so let's
have a look at how ansible actually
works in real world so the real world
environment with is that you'd have the
ansible software installed on a local
machine and then it connects to
different nodes within your network on
the local machine you'll have your first
your playbook which is the set of
instructions for how to set up the
remote nodes and then to identify how
you're going to connect to those nodes
you'll have an inventory we use secure
ssh connections to each of the servers
so we are encrypting the communication
to those servers we're able to grab some
basic facts on each server so we
understand how we can then push out the
playbook to each server and configure
that server remotely the end goal is to
have an environment that is consistent
so let's ask you a simple question
what are the major opportunities that
ansible has over chef and puppet
really like to hear your answers in the
comments below pop them in there and
we'll get back to you and really want to
hear how you feel that ansible is a
stronger product or maybe you think it's
a weaker product as it compares to other
similar products in the market here's
the bonus we're going to talk a little
bit about ansible tower so ansible tower
is an extra product that red hat created
that really kind of puts the cherry on
the top of the ice cream or is the icing
on your cake ansible by itself is a
command line tool however asphalt tower
is a framework that was designed to
access ansible and through the ansible
tower framework we now have an easy to
use gui this really makes it easy for
non-developers to be able to create the
environment that they want to be able to
manage in their devops plan without
having to constantly work with the
command prompt window so instead of
opening up terminal window or command
window and writing out complex
instructions only in text you can now
use drag and drop and mouse click
actions to be able to create your
appropriate playbooks inventories and
pushes for your nodes all right so we
talked a lot about ansible let's take a
look at a specific company that's using
ansible today and in this example we're
going to look at hootsuite now hootsuite
if you've not already use their products
and they have a great product hootsuite
is a social media management system they
are able to help with you managing your
pushes of social media content across
all of the popular social media
platforms they're able to provide the
analytics they're able to provide the
tools that marketing and sales teams can
use to be able to assess a sentiment
analysis of the messages that are being
pushed out really grateful and very
popular but part of their popularity
drove a specific problem straight to
hootsuite the challenge they had at
hootsuite is that they had to constantly
go back and rebuild their server
environment and they couldn't do this
continuously and be consistent there was
no standard documentation and they had
to rely on your memory to be able to do
this consistently imagine how complex
this could get as you're scaling up with
a popular product that now has tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
users this is where ansible what came in
and really helped the folks over at
hootsuite today the devops team at
hootsuite write out playbooks that have
specific instructions that define the
architecture and structure of their
hardware nodes and environments and are
able to do that as a standard product
instead of it being a problem in scaling
up their environment they now are able
to rebuild and create new servers in a
matter of
seconds
the bottom line is ansible has been able
to provide
hootsuite with it automation consistent
configuration and free up time from the
operations team so that instead of
managing servers they're able to provide
additional new value to the company
ansible is currently the most trending
and popular configuration management
tool and it's used mostly under the
devops approach so what will you be
learning today you learn why you should
use ansible what exactly is ansible the
ansible architecture how ansible works
the various benefits of ansible and
finally we'll have a demo on the
installation of apache or the http
package on our client systems we'll also
be hosting a very simple web page and
during this demo i'll also show you how
you can write a very simple playbook in
yemen and your inventory file
so let's begin why should you use
ansible let's consider a scenario of an
organization where sam is a system
administrator sam is responsible for the
company's infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems this could include your web
servers your database servers the
various repositories and so on so as a
system administrator sam needs to ensure
that all the systems are running the
updated versions of the software now
when you consider a handful of systems
this seems like a pretty simple task sam
can simply go from system to system and
perform the configurations required but
that is not the case with an
organization is it an organization has a
very large infrastructure it could have
hundreds and thousands of systems so
here is where sam's work gets really
difficult not only does it get tougher
sam has to move from system to system
performing the same task over and over
again this makes sam bored not just that
repeating the same task leaves no space
for innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system grow and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible sam can write simple codes that
are deployed onto all the systems and
configure them to the correct states
so now that we know why we should use
ansible let's look at what exactly is
ansible ansible is an i.t engine that
automates the following tasks so first
we have orchestration orchestration
basically means bringing together of
multiple applications and ensuring an
order in which these are executed so for
example if you consider a web page that
you require to host this webpage stores
all its values that it takes from the
user into a database so the first thing
you must do is ensure that the system
has a database manager and only then do
you host your web page so this kind of
an order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right
next ansible automates configuration
management so configuration management
simply means that all the systems are
maintained at a consistent desired state
other tools that automate configuration
management include puppet and chef
and finally ansible automates deployment
deployment simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact ansible can
also ensure that these applications or
the code are deployed at a certain time
or after regular intervals
now that we know what exactly ansible is
let's look at ansible's architecture
ansible has two main components you have
the local machine and you have your node
or the client machine so the local
machine is where the system
administrator sits he or she installs
ansible here and on the other end you
have your node or the client systems so
in case of ansible there's no supporting
software installed here these are just
the systems that require to be
configured and they are completely
controlled by the local machine at your
local machine you also have a module a
module is a collection of your
configuration files and in case of
ansible these configuration files are
called playbooks playbooks are written
in yaml yaml stands for yaml ain't a
markup language and it is honestly the
easiest language to understand and learn
since it's so close to english we also
have the inventory the inventory is a
file where you have all your nodes that
require configuration mentioned and
based on the kind of configuration they
require they are also grouped together
so later in the demo we'll have a look
at how the playbook and the inventory is
written and that will probably make it
clearer so of course a local machine
needs to communicate with the client and
how is this done this is done through
ssh ssh is your secure shell which
basically provides a protected
communication in an unprotected
environment
okay so we saw the various components of
ansible now how does ansible exactly
work you have your local machine on one
end this is where you install ansible if
you have gone through any previous
material on ansible you would have come
across the term agentless often being
associated with the stool so this is
what agentless means you're installing
ansible only on your local machine and
there's no supporting software or plugin
being installed on your clients this
means that you have no agent on the
other end the local machine has complete
control and hence the term agentless
another term that you would come across
with ansible is push configuration so
since the local machine has complete
control here it pushes the playbooks on
to the notes and thus it's called a push
configuration tool now the playbooks and
the inventory are written at the local
machine and the local machine connects
with the notes through the ssh client
this step here is optional but it's
always recommended to do so it's where
the facts are collected so facts are
basically the current state of the node
now all this is collected from the node
and sent to the local machine so when
the playbook is executed the task
mentioned in the playbook is compared
against the current status of the node
and only the changes that are required
to be made further are made and once the
playbooks are executed your nodes are
configured to the desired states so as i
mentioned before ansible is currently
the most trending tool in the market
under the configuration management
umbrella so let's have a look at the
various benefits of ansible which gives
it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple important and provides automated
reporting how does it do all this let's
have a look at that agentless as i
already mentioned before you require no
supporting software or plugin installed
on your node or the client system so the
master has complete control and
automatically this means that ansible is
more efficient because now we have more
space in our client in node systems for
other resources and we can get ansible
up and running real quick ansible is
also flexible so an infrastructure is
prone to change very often and ansible
takes no amount of time to adjust to
these changes ansible cannot get any
simpler with your playbooks written in a
language such as yaml which is as close
to english as you can possibly get
air important basically means that if
you have a playbook which needs to be
run n number of systems it would have
the same effect on all of these systems
without any side effect and finally we
have automated reporting so in case of
ansible your playbook has number of
tasks and all these stars are named so
whenever you run or execute your
playbook it gives a report on which
tasks ran successfully which failed
which clients were not reachable and so
on all this information is very crucial
when you're dealing with a very large
infrastructure and finally we reach the
most exciting part of our tutorial the
hands-on before we move on to the actual
hands-on let me just brief you through
what exactly we'll be doing so i'll be
hosting two virtual boxes both centos 7
operating systems one would be my local
machine and other my node or the client
machine so on my local machine first
i'll install ansible we then write the
inventory and the playbook and then
simply deploy this playbook on the
client machine there's just one thing
that we need to do is that we need to
check if the configurations that we
mentioned in our playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this is my
oracle virtualbox here i have my master
system which is the local machine and
this is the client machine so let's have
a look at these two machines this is my
client machine the terminals open right
now so the client machine terminal has a
black background with white text and the
master machine terminal has a white
background with black text just so you
can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our ansible so yum install
ansible hyphen y is the command to do so
so this might take some time
yeah so ansible is installed the next
step we go to our hosts file so a host
file here is basically the inventory
it's where you'll specify all your nodes
in our case we just have one node
that's the path to your host file
as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group for
your client notes
so i'm going to name it ansible clients
[Music]
and here we need to type the ip address
of a client machine so my client
machine's ip address is 192.168.2.1
so before you come to this it's advised
that you check the ip address on your
client machine the simple command for
that is ifconfig now once you type the
ip address put a space and here we need
to mention the username and the password
for our client
so i'll be logging in as the root user
so this is the password
and then the user
which is root in my case
that's it now you can save this file
just clear the screen
next we move on to our playbook we need
to write the playbook
so the extension for our playbook is yml
which stands for yaman
and as you can see here i have already
written my playbook but i'll just
explain to you how this is done
so a yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire playbook
so i have named it sample book
host is basically where this would be
executed
so as we saw earlier in our inventory i
mentioned clients group name as ansible
clients so we use the same name here
the remote user is the user you'll be
using at your client so in my case
that's root and become true is basically
to indicate that you need to set your
privileges at root so that's called a
privilege escalation
now a playbook consists of tasks
so we have here three tasks the first
task i've named it to install httpd so
what we are doing here is we are
installing our httpd package which is
basically the apache server and we are
installing the most latest version of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task is running httpd so for the service
the name is httpd because that's the
service we need to start running and the
state is started our next task is
creating content so this is the part
where we are creating our web page
so copy because this is the file that
will be created at the client
the content will be welcome
and the destination of the file will be
www.html index.html as you know this is
like a default path that we use to store
all our html files
now as you can see here there's quite a
lot of indentation and when it comes to
yaml although it's very simple to write
and very easy to read
the indentation is very crucial
so the first dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
playbook and all the dashes under tasks
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that they
are siblings so the priority would be
the same so to ensure that all your
tasks are coming under the tasks label
make sure they are not directly under
name so yeah that's pretty much it so
when you write your yaml file the
language is pretty simple very readable
indentation is absolutely necessary make
sure all your spaces are correctly
placed we can now save this file
next thing we need to check if the
syntax of our yaml file is absolutely
right because that's very crucial so the
command to check the syntax of the yaml
file is ansible
playbook
the name of your playbook
syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is
sample.yml which is the name of your
playbook
so our playbook is ready to be executed
the command to execute the playbook
is ansible playbook
and the name of your playbook
so our playbook is executed as you can
see here gathering facts that's where
all the facts of the note that the
present state of the note is collected
and sent to the local machine so it's
basically to check that if the
configuration changes that we are about
to make is already made
so it's not made we do not have the
httpd package installed on our node so
this is the first change that's made
also if it's not installed of course
it's not running that's the second
change that's made so it's put into the
running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okay state this means that
the contents already present in the
client machine so i made it this way so
that you can actually see the different
states that's present
so over here we have okay four so four
things are all fine the facts are
gathered two things are changed and one
is already present two changes are made
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that i was referring to
previously that ansible provides
automatically
and is very useful as you can see
the next step we need to just check on
our client machine if all the changes
that we desired are made so let's move
to our client
so this is my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the httpd
package and hosting a web page the best
way to do it
is open your browser
and type in
localhost
so there you go your apache server is
installed and your web page is hosted
hi guys in this video we have compiled
the most important interview questions
of configuration management tools chef
ansible and puppet that you might face
in a devops interview
so without further ado let's get started
so let's just get into the first section
which is configuration management
so one of the questions that you'll get
asked right away is why do you have ssl
certificates used for chef really
fundamentally your immediate answer
should be security ssl provides for a
very high level of private security and
private and public key pairing this
really is essential to ensure that you
have a secure environment throughout
your entire network the second part
should be that if you're using ssl and
you're using the private public key
model within ssl you're able to
guarantee the systems on your network
that the chef that you'll be able to
validate that the nodes within your
network that chef is validating against
actually are the real nodes themselves
not imposters so you will also be asked
some questions such as the following
which is the following commands would
you use to stop or disable the http
service when the system boots and you'll
typically get four responses and
there'll be
system ctl disable httpd dot service or
is it system disable http dot service
system disable httpd or the final option
which is system ctl disable
httpd.service
your answer should be the first one
which is hashtag system ctl disable
http.service
so chef comes with a series of tools
that allows to function effectively and
one of the tools that you're going to be
asked about is what is test kitchen and
test kitchen is essentially a command
line tool that allows you to be able to
test out your cookbook before you
actually deploy it to a real note so
some of the commands that you would use
are for instance if you want to create
an instance of test kitchen you would do
kitchen create if you want to destroy an
instance after you created it you do
kitchen destroy and if you want to be
able to combine multiple instances you
would do kitchen converge so a question
you'll get is around chef is how does
chef apply differ from chef client so
fundamentally the difference between
them is that chef apply will validate
the recipe that you're working on
whereas chef client looks to apply and
validate the entire cookbook that's run
in your server environment so one is
focused on the recipe and the other is
focused on the entire cookbook
so there are some differences when
you're working with different command
lines so for instance when you're
working with puppets and you're working
with one version of puppet and you want
to do what is the command to sign a
requested certificate the top example
here is for public version 2.7 whereas
the lower option here is for puppet
version 3. now something to bear in mind
when you're going through your interview
process is that the tools that are used
within a continuous integration
continuous delivery devops model do vary
and so you want to be able to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools so that when
you're talking to your interviewer
you're able to show the deep knowledge
that you have which open source or
community tools do you use to make
puppet more powerful and essentially
this question is going to be asking you
to look beyond the core foundation of
puppet itself and so the three options
you have is being able to track
configurations with jira which you
should be doing anyway but it's a great
way to be able to clearly communicate
the work that's being done with puppet a
version control can be extended with get
and then the changes should be passed
through jenkins so the three tools you
want to be looking at integration with
jira git and jenkins so what are the
resources in puppet well fundamentally
there are four the resources are basic
units of any configuration management
tool they are the features of the nodes
they are the written catalog and the
execution of the catalog on a node so as
we dig deeper into puppet one of the
things that you are likely to be asked
regarding puppet is what is a class in
puppet and so a class in puppet is
really the name blocks in your manifest
that contain the various configurations
and this can include services files and
packages and we have on the screen here
an example of what a class would look
like when you write it out and you may
want to memorize just one class don't
memorize just a whole set of classes
just memorize one the person that's
interviewing you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized complete massive classes but
having one small class to be able to
illustrate the experience you have is
extremely valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around ansible is what is ansible
role so a role is an independent block
of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
playbook so example we have here on the
screen actually shows you one role
within a playbook and in this role it is
to install tomcat on a node again as
with previous question within puppet of
a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a frame of reference uh
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
now they're either referred to as french
brackets or curly brackets either way
and what you'll be wanting to ask is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets within and support and
really the answer comes down into two
things one is that it makes it easier to
distinguish strings and undefined
variables and the second is for putting
together conditional statements when you
are actually using variables and the
example we have here is this prints the
value of and we have foo and we have to
then put in the variable conditional
statement of foo is defined as something
so what is the best way to make content
reusable and redistributable with
ansible and there's really essentially
three the first is to include a sub
module or another file in your playbook
the second is to import an improvement
of an include which ensures that a file
is added only once and then the third is
roles to manage the tasks within the
playbook
so a question you will be asked is
provide a differences between ansible
and puppets so if we look at ansible
it's a very easy agent-less installation
it's based on python you can configure
it with yaml and there are no support
for windows in contrast puppet is an
agent-based installation it's written in
ruby the configuration files are written
in dsl and it has support on all popular
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual architecture and it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a push only architecture in
contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to have a
complete environment managed by the
puppet architecture hello everyone today
we will be looking at the interview
questions which a typical devops
engineer faces in an interview this is
both for people who are new to the
devops world and people who are
experienced in other fields like linux
or production support and are willing or
wanting to move to devops so let's take
a look
so pretty much it'll start with
questions about yourself they'll have a
resume in front of them as obviously you
would have sent your resume to them so
they'll look at that and they will ask
you to quickly walk them through your
resume and tell them what you've been
doing in your previous project
so you'll have to summarize this in a
way in which you know kind of walk
through all three layers
and you have to tell them that you
worked on a team where you kind of
managed aw the aws part and the
automation part of it
so
that can also include telling them about
any infrastructure deployment scripts
which you have written it could also
include any configuration management
that you've done and deployment
automation you might have done
so it would also include things like
setting up a monitoring system setting
up the entire thing on the cloud
collaborating with teams uh everything
maybe what your code review process is
scrum methodology
whatever you do in your team
they will definitely ask you what your
team size was so you could say you've
been working on a team about five to six
people
which would include team leads
consultants managers scrum masters etc
what was your role in the team that's
the typical devops role in which you've
written code for automation of stuff on
the cloud
they'll ask how good are you at
programming now this is a typical
question that's asked of a devops
engineer to gauge whether he's fit for
the devops role or not so you would
answer that you've not written
full-fledged applications such as java
or ruby on rails but you're good at ruby
python shell and pearl from a scripting
language perspective
maybe i'm not a full-fledged programmer
but i know the ins and outs of scripts
one of the typical questions is are you
from the dev side or the op side and the
answer is you're from the op side but
you have a good hold on the programming
languages which are used for scripting
and configuration management and
whatever code is required you can write
that easily
they may ask how quickly can you learn
which is a gauge of the candidate's
ability to learn new things and
flexibility to adjust himself to a new
environment
given the chance can you architect an
application the answer is definitely yes
tell them you have been working with
architects recently and that you've been
contributing to the architecture from a
devops perspective
and giving your input so that the
application could be developed in a more
easily deployable manner
given the chance to lead a team can you
do that you'll say yes definitely i have
more than five years experience
typically this is true for people who
have at least five years experience
leaving a team because less than that
would really not be meaningful the next
level of questions that come up in a
devops interview are typically linux
questions these questions could be
anything from the linux world but
typically these are the most common
questions what is the command to view
the cron tab the command is crontab
hyphen l
what is an alias in linux an alias in
linux is something that tells you the
shortcuts on that system these are
defined in the etc batch rc file
what does the chmod command do the chmod
command basically allows you to change
the permission of a file in linux it can
be changed from read write in executable
mode so it could be changed from read to
read write or to read write execute
depending on the use case
what is ssh port forwarding it's a way
to actually forward your ports through
ssh protocols so it allows you to bypass
firewalls and also tunnel ports through
uh strictly guarded environments so this
is one of the ways which you can connect
to instances or services in your private
subnets in aws or your data center
the next question is what
is a zombie process now this is about
the most common linux question asked in
an interview zombie process is a process
which is in a terminated state but which
has not yet released the resources so
basically it's most commonly a child
process where the parent has exited but
the child is still there basically it's
entries in the process table they'll ask
how to check the top cpu consuming
processes
and you can use the top command to check
that the top command gives you a very
nice view of the entire linux process
table
looking at the top deployment related
questions which is one of the most
important areas people use to gauge
their candidates one of the questions
which comes up is what is a blue green
deployment so a blue-green deployment is
something that
in which you have x number of resources
running your application and say that
number is 10. so you have 10 servers in
a web farm now in a blue green
deployment what you do is take out half
of those from the actual production
state you deploy the new code on those
now in the meantime the other five or
the other half would be serving the
production traffic and these five would
not be hindered or hampered in any way
now the first five in which you complete
the deployment which you've taken out of
the actual production load you put those
back in and you wait for those to come
back into service and then you take the
other five out of the actual load and
you start deploying on those so in a
blue green deployment what happens is
you never let the end user see the
downtime it's an always up environment
how do you do a hot deployment this is
just a rephrasing of the previous
question really a hot deployment can be
done either by having two environments
of the same size and then you redirect
traffic through a load balancer or a
proxy service to one of the environments
deploy it on the other and then redirect
to the first one and apply it to the
second and just like a blue green
deployment you never showed the end user
the downtime
and what is your rollback strategy
this is something you need to be very
confident about because every deployment
should have a rollback associated with
it so let's say your deployment fails
how do you roll back the system it has
to be linked to a blue green or a hot
deployment so you have to say that you
have a jenkins job or a script
which basically does a blue green
deployment and in the middle of that
blue green deployment it checks to see
whether or not services are up and
running and at the least the sgtp
endpoints of your application are
running or not
have you used jenkins for deployment yes
i've used it and you've used it using a
couple of strategies you've used it with
plugins and i've used it with my script
so my plugins used to deploy code on the
environment using build or publish or
ssh and i have also had
my ansible or chef or puppet code which
used to do the deployment for me so we
used to use jenkins as an orchestrator
and puppet and chef and ansible for the
actual deployment of the target service
one of the other common questions from a
deployment perspective is what jenkins
plugins have you used
you would say jenkins plugins you've
used maven and gradle i've used kobetra
for testing pmd for programmatic mistake
detection aztec for ruby on rails
testing karma for angularjs testing and
integration with s3 i've also used git
plugin for checking out code svn plugin
for checking out svn repositories
upstream downstream plugin for
connecting the builds
in addition to this i've also used
archive artifacts plugin publish html
reports plugin to publish test reports
have you ever used user data for
deployment you answer yes i've used it
in aws so when you have instances behind
load balances we used to use it
it will actually define the deployment
script so that every time a new instance
comes up in the auto scaling group it
has got the latest code on it so that
latest code is checked out using the sh
command which is specified inside the
user data
looking at the aws questions
so what is a vpc a vpc is a slice of the
amazon cloud which they give you to run
your resources
what is the difference between a public
and private subnet a public subnet is a
subnet which is directly accessible from
the internet a private subnet is a
subnet that is not accessible from the
internet it's only accessible from
within the vpc
what is reserved instance a reserved
instance is an instance which is
reserved for you by amazon for a year
and they give you significant price
reductions on that you can buy that no
upfront partial upfront or full upfront
payments and you get discounts from 20
to 60 percent based on the payment type
and terms what is the difference between
spot instance and reserved instance the
spot instance is like a bid instance
where you have a specific price which
you have bid and based on that you are
assigned instances now the moment your
bid is lower than the next highest bid
your instance is terminated and it's
assigned to the next highest bidder a
reserved instance on the other hand is
not a biddable instance you have to buy
it for specific terms what is cloud
formation cloud formation is an
orchestration or an infrastructure or a
server deployment tool a managed server
deployment tool or service which amazon
provides so it takes a g sun as an input
in that json you provide everything that
is required to build up an environment
from vps to servers to buckets
everything so it's an amazon provided
service that lets you build entire
applications stacks uh from scratch
have you used route 53 yes i've used
route 53 i used it for managing dns i
use it to redirect our code id dns to
route 53 using amazon name servers and
then from there in route 53 we used to
create cnm entries a records mx records
txt records and we used to manage the
entire dns from there
what is the best feature of aws which
you like
i like the auto scaling group and the
elastic load balancer because it allows
you to infinitely scale your application
to any level
coming to configuration management
which configuration management tool have
you used
so you can say that you've used all
three chef ansible and puppet in one
project or another i have good hands-on
experience with each of them and i've
written chef cookbooks puppet modules
and ansible playbooks
what is the difference between chef and
ansible so chef is a ruby-based tool you
use ruby as its main programming
language
it's open source just like ansible chef
uses a client server and client only
architecture so the difference is that
ansible is simply an agentless tool so
there is no agent enanciable whatsoever
in chef there are two methodologies one
is agent based and the other is
agentless but if you talk about the
difference one of the differences is
that there is no agent in ansible and
the other difference is ansible uses
yaml
for defining the state of the systems
and its playbooks whereas chef uses ruby
for defining the state of the systems in
its cookbooks and it's more of a
programming language when it comes to
chef and the yaml enanciable is not
really a programming language it's more
of a statically typed code
have you written any cookbooks or
modules and
the playbooks
yes i've used both from
the repositories which each of these
configuration management tools provide
so for chef i've used the chef
supermarket cookbooks and i've also
written custom cookbooks for puffit i've
used modules from puppet forge and i've
written my own modules for custom
applications for ansible i've used a
community provided playbooks as well as
i've written my own custom playbooks for
provisioning of instances on the cloud
as well as managing
and now production support
what is the biggest issue you faced in a
production environment so you can say
that there's an application we used to
run on the cloud and there was some
application deployment error it was a
logical error in the application which
caused an error behind the elastic load
balancer so we had an elastic load
balancer which was tied to the auto
scaling group so it kind of snowballed
the application and we were not able to
control it so the application scaled
infinitely and it was snowballing the
instances so we had to go in and
manually freeze the size of the auto
scaling group once the size was frozen
we were able to go into the instances
check the logs fix the issue rebuild the
imi restart the auto scaling process so
that was one of the biggest issues in
production i've faced recently
what is your dr strategy in a live
website
so a dr strategy is that you do a
failover check using route 53 dns so one
of them is a dns based failover in which
you've got an exact replica of your
environment your web servers your
database your cache
so your database may not be synced in
real time with a dr so it could be a one
day behind sync so the traffic is
switched to dr whenever there's a
downtime in production automatically
through a dns switch
the other dr strategy is that you can
have instances in two availability zones
and then you can have your load balancer
to switch traffic based on the
availability of those two zones
but that is a same region dnr so from a
multi-region dnr the best option is to
have a dns based switch and you can also
have an interface tool interface proxy
which can route traffic based on the
health of your endpoints
how do you scale a production web
service so if you're on the cloud you
can use the auto scaling group which
will scale automatically based on demand
if you don't want to go into instances
and you don't want to manage instances
you can use the elastic bean stock for a
managed stack which takes care of the
load balancing itself
now if you have an application which is
already containerized it's a better
practice to run them on ecs on the cloud
which would allow you to scale your
applications based on demand and you can
create an application load balancer
there
if you're in house you can scale your
application by having a container
management system in which you can have
some base hosts on which you run
multiple services so you can keep on
adding multiple hosts to that cluster
and you don't have to worry about the
scaling part because the host can be
added on the fly to that hardware so
your docker cluster like a swarm or a
kubernetes can take care of getting
those new machines into your cluster and
running the containers which are
existing on your cluster on those new
machines thanks a lot everyone this is
all from the interview question
hey want to become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simply
learn's channel and click here to watch
more such videos to nerd up and get
certified in cloud computing click here
you